subscribers
next the waco investigation a house
joint subcommittee hearing on the fifth
day of testimony on events at the branch
davidian compound two years ago
today's witnesses include officials of
the texas rangers and lawyers for david
koresh
the joint oversight committees
and waco will now come to order
today will be a very interesting day
a long day we have panels that will take
us
i believe late into the evening we're
hopeful that we can move forward
and
i'm we're i talked with my colleague
bill mccullum and rather than
duplicate
some of the material he's going to talk
in his opening statement about what
we've learned so far
and i'll just quickly talk about where
we're going
from my point of view as we reach this
halfway point
we've been very committed to get to the
truth
to bring out
all the facts as to exactly what
happened at waco
we got off to a a tough start from the
beginning
but i think that we are really dealing
with substance and uh
again we learned uh some major things uh
and and again bill will get into these
in detail
but uh
in mr rodriguez testimony yesterday i
think our hearts went out to him
as he explained in great detail how he
tried to warn people that
the davinians had been tipped off
we'll hear more about that today
we also learned that that uh
though david koresh offered to have
people come in
and and see the weapons and uh again
uh these are the things that that we
really wanted to get to the bottom of
we now move into phase two
all the facts just mentioned
um accepted and we'll get into uh
basically what happened during the 51
days that followed
on march 1st 1993 the fbi took control
atf was relieved of command and the fbi
and the texas rangers began what was
come to be known now as the waco siege
the fbi controlled siege ended with cs
gas and a fire that burns in many hearts
and mines
that fire which followed insertion of cs
gas into the compound led to 22 children
and more than 60 men and women burning
alive
in just 15 minutes the people who had
been on the other end of the telephone
were dead
this week we asked the justice
department to answer tough questions
about their role
what happened that caused this second
tragedy
who made the key
decisions why were they made
and on what information
and how can we prevent anything like
this ever from happening again
we will hear from scholars lawyers and
eventually janet reno herself
did the fbi's negotiators give up
did internal tension at the fbi develop
between the tactical people and the
negotiators
were offers of surrender made and
rejected
could the texas rangers have ended the
siege
or assisted in that end if given a
chance
was the crime scene evidence destroyed
or tampered with in any way
any waco documents
what were the roles of mr potts mr
hubble the attorney general and the
president of the united states
did the president approve the use of cs
gas
did attorney general approve the use of
cs gas
who accelerated the use of cs gas
why was it used
in such great volume
and could that fire have been prevented
still as atf director mcgraw said
yesterday and i just think that after
sitting here all day in about six hours
listening to
he and ron noble
i can't help but feel good about his
comments
as he said that
constitutional oversight hearings are
good for law enforcement everywhere in
this country
they are good for law enforcement on the
local state and federal levels
for one simple reason
they remind us all the need for good
plans
good procedures and good responsible
practices
director mcgraw
i believe that you hit the nail on the
head with that statement
i would also like to say that
every single one of us
is committed
to not only finding out what happened to
those four brave atf agents but also the
men and women and children that also
perish
we have a great respect for law and
order
and i think anybody that makes any
comments anywhere anytime
that goes against that is irresponsible
our commitment is getting at the truth
we have an oversight responsible role
and that's exactly what we intend to do
i'd now like to
yield to mrs thurman from florida for
opening statement
thank you mr chairman
today we begin the next phase of our
hearings during the past four days we
heard about the role of atf in the
department of treasury in the planning
of the faithful raid outside waco on
february 28 1993.
four atf agents were killed 20 were
wounded and up to five branch davidians
were also killed on that day
yesterday we listened to heart-wrenching
testimony from robert rodriguez as he
described his experiences inside the
compound in his efforts to warn his
superiors that koresh knew agents would
be coming robert watched helplessly from
the perimeter while his fellow officers
were cut down by automatic weapons fire
we were all touched by mr rodriguez's
account
yesterday we also heard from agents
valesteros and williams the men who
attempted to serve the warrant to david
koresh mr williams and mr belceres and
every single other witness who was in
waco that day agreed that the davidians
opened fire first this is an important
fact that is now established in the
hearing record
it was has also been firmly established
that serious errors in judgment were
made by atf and other treasury officials
as i stated yesterday in my opening
statement these mistakes are clearly
outlined in the blue book once again i
have heard nothing up to this point that
leads me to believe that there was any
attempt to whitewash or cover up the
facts in this case
mr chairman yesterday we also took
testimony from secretary for law
enforcement
ron noble and atf director john mccaughe
i was encouraged to hear from both these
gentlemen of the sweeping changes that
were made in both the agencies secretary
noble stated that he issued a directive
in august of 1993 that requires the
treasury office of enforcement to be
notified of any significant operational
manners that included the business
department's bureaus in addition
secretary noble outlined the steps he
had taken to improve general oversight
within the department
director maga also talked about changes
made at atf among the changes are
increased in accurate intelligence
crisis management training for all atf
staff and finally a new atf order that
outlines undercover guidelines i was
encouraged by the statements of both
secretary noble and director maga in
response to my question about americans
constitutional rights both men said it
was important for every one of their
employees from management to field
agents to be acutely aware of citizens
rights under our constitution
today we start our inquiry into the role
of the fbi and the department of justice
in the 51-day standoff that followed the
february 28th grade we will specifically
be looking into the negotiations and the
role of the fbi we will undoubtedly hear
testimony from some of today's witnesses
that the fbi did not fully pursue
negotiations however i believe that the
testimony of miss jewell joyce sparks
and robert rodriguez all established
clearly that quresh was never going to
leave the compound in order to fulfill
his prophecy quresh needed to create his
own armageddon by surrendering he would
have been proven a false prophet to his
followers this fact is also now firmly
established in the hearing record and i
hope will be further examined during
today's testimony
another important point is that after
the death and wounding of both atf
agents and branch davidians a slow and
careful process was employed by the fbi
to negotiate a peaceful end to the gun
battle let us not forget that the fbi
maintained its channels to crash for 51
days
some will say that koresh constantly
lied and kept looking for opportunities
to spread his views as we will hear
david koresh always had another reason
not to surrender another condition
another demand another chance to
manipulate
after nearly two months of this
posturing it became apparent that koresh
was not leaving the compound under his
own accord there was no evidence that he
would have relinquished the national
spotlight which he exploited for 51 long
days he would have continued to evade
the real issue he had answered a warrant
with gunfire that killed four law
enforcement officers in closing mr
chairman let me say it again as we enter
this phase of the hearing that i that
all i seek is the fact to make sure an
event like this never happens again
thank you mr chairman and i yield back
the balance of my time
thank you mrs thurman
chair recognizes and introduces the
co-chairman of the joint subcommittees
and chairman of the judiciary
committee's crime subcommittee our good
friend bill mccollum from florida thank
you mr zelif i appreciate that
introduction and our fifth day as we
begin today to look for the first time
at the federal bureau of investigations
role in this process and what happened
on the fatal last day after 51 days of
siege i think it's appropriate for us to
very briefly look back on what we've
just witnessed and particularly what we
heard yesterday because yesterday was a
very fruitful hearing as far as i was
concerned back both sets of them were in
trying to put in perspective what
happened on february 28th and why it
happened
first of all i think there were two very
significant points that were discovered
yesterday which i certainly had not been
aware of and i don't believe were in
anybody's reporter investigation in the
kind of decisive manner we learned them
yesterday
one of those is that the atf had did not
have the capability
to conduct a siege they didn't have the
experience or the negotiators to
actually do that in the discussion
yesterday evening with mr noble we
learned that we had documentation of
that and we found out that for a fact
and that was a factor a very serious and
significant factor leading to
the decision ultimately to do the
dynamic entry that led to the tragic
deaths that we know about on the 28th of
february
the second thing that i think we learned
yesterday that was very important and
we've been building up to it with a lot
of questions on days before but really
hadn't quite gotten to the point of
getting the admissions that came out
yesterday was that the atf
actually abandoned the idea of trying to
arrest david koresh outside the compound
some 10 days or two weeks or maybe
longer before the february 28th raid in
other words they weren't looking to try
to cut him off or cut the head of the
snake off as somebody said
and try then to do whatever they needed
to do to go in and search the compound
they had completely abandoned that idea
now those two things are important for a
few reasons and i want to outline them
and in doing that i'd like to make the
observation at least it's my observation
that
if this is a case where there's plenty
of blame to go around
there's not one single thing that caused
the problems that occurred on the day of
this rate on february 28th there was a
lot of emotion out here yesterday a lot
of finger pointing understandably a lot
of conscience being brought forward
let's run through a few of those things
first of all clearly if this
element of surprise or the point of
secrecy had not been lost
this raid might have been successful the
agents all expressed that
so the loss of secrecy the loss of
surprise certainly contributed to the
failure of the raid on the 28th the but
four concept is there but for the loss
of surprise
there might not have been the tragedy
that there was but in addition to that
we can say that but for the fact that
the raid planners this came out
yesterday not having heard about or
listened to joyce sparks or anyone else
with the expertise on the religious
nature and the real true meaning of what
david koresh was trying to say but for
the failure to listen to their warnings
about not going in directly as they did
and instead trying to arrest him outside
the compound maybe this would not have
happened
in addition one can say uh but for the
fact that david koresh was not arrested
and that but for the fact that they at
the atf abandoned the idea of arresting
him outside the compound uh and
separating him from those inside this
tragedy might not have happened
another but for
it comes with a question of the press
involvement i don't think there was any
stronger words yesterday than mr
hartnett condemning the cameraman and
the press for getting involved as
aggressively as they did and blowing the
cover i don't know to what degree atf's
involvement with the newspaper uh and
some of the other activities about the
press led to this hype or led to the
fact that cameron was on the road but
obviously the press was overly
aggressive and obviously the cameraman
blew the cover of this raid to the
postman who went in who was a member of
the davidians and told koresh about the
folks who were coming that morning so
one can say but for the cameraman but
for the overzealous press this tragedy
might not have occurred
and then one has to ask himself despite
mr nobles trying to find a way to excuse
it last night
if secretary benson when he first took
over as secretary of the treasury had
done what one would normally expect as
secretary to do in the first 30 days
he's in office and that's meet with the
heads of his law enforcement agencies
such as the atf
if secretary benson had just met with mr
higgins and had an ordinary conversation
which he asked him what are the
significant items on your plate right
now which i suspect he would have asked
well maybe just maybe then the facts
would have come out earlier about the
fact that this waco raid was going to
take place or something was going to
happen down there and the treasury
department would have investigated it uh
in a much more thorough manner instead
of learning about it 48 hours before
and maybe this entire tragedy would not
have happened
then we have the report the treasury
report i would suggest that we learn
that it is a reasonably good report or
it was a reasonably good report but it
was not the terrific all perfect report
that some would like to have you believe
we learned a lot of new information
and we did place some of the things in
the record that yesterday that clearly
were not in that report
what bothered me the most about all of
that though is the fact that it appears
that mr noble and some others down at
treasury did attempt to distance
themselves from the events of waco to
try to quickly assess the blame and
place it on the atf agents on the line
and make them the fall guys and yes
there was some blame there to be placed
and there's nothing necessarily wrong
with the placing of the blame but the
matter in which it was done and the
callousness with which it was done seems
to me to be somewhat striking at times
and one of the ways that i want to point
that out is to just point out this
element of surprise question
after i questioned mr noble yesterday
extensively and listening to all the
other witnesses leading up to this
question about what was it all about it
was very clear and he admitted it that
at no time did the treasury department
direct anybody at the atf
to abandon the raid if the element of
surprise was lost now they did think
they had assurances that this raid would
not take place if everything didn't go
right
and mr higgins was confident that it
wouldn't have occurred had
the agents in the field done what
normally you would expect them to do and
not go forward if surprise was lost and
they learned about it but nonetheless mr
noble went ahead and did things that
were not only in the report suggestive
of the fact that treasury directed this
to happen and it didn't happen and
therefore this was the real problem in
this raid
but also on 60 minutes on may 14 1995 he
said and i quote what was absolutely
clear in washington at treasury and in
washington at atf was that no raid
should proceed once the element of
surprise was lost
then the raid planners would have said
okay
we can't go forward with the raid that's
what should have happened that's what
the raid planners were trained to do
that's what they were directed to do and
they didn't do it
now that simply wasn't so and mr noble
stretched that point i wouldn't say
trying to tell a lie about it but i
would say it was all part of the mental
attitude down at treasury at that point
to distance themselves and make sure
they didn't take any of the blame for
this they were new in office they
attempted very hard to put distance
between themselves and those who were at
fault that's what i got out of
yesterday's hearings mr chairman i think
we now need to put that aside we'll come
back to it in our final report of the of
the committee at the end after we
finished all of this work and we are
today as you've indicated going to
proceed to focus on the second half of
this the 51 day siege and what happened
that led up to the final tragedy at waco
in april thank you
thank you mr mccall thank you mr
mccollum chair now recognizes the
ranking minority member of the crime
subcommittee chuck schumer from new york
thank you mr zellath and uh first let me
say i thought yesterday's hearing
represented both the best and the worst
of what could be and what could come out
of these types of hearings the best was
i think hearing mr rodriguez tell
what happened and hearing the rebuttal
from the other witnesses it came out
clearly there was a dispute as to what
happened but everyone could make their
own judgment and i think that that is
very very important because as i said
yesterday morning's opening statement
losing the element of surprise and then
going ahead with the raid was the
greatest greatest mistake that had that
occurred in the whole waco tragedy the
worst is sort of idle
throwing out of words with very little
proof
the word cover-up yesterday cover-up's a
serious word it implies a crime
and mr hartnett threw it out a few
members of the a few a few members of
this committee
latched on to it but there was not a
single bit of proof of cover-up
and that is the kind of thing in my
judgment that poisons these hearings
getting at the truth
great we should
even if the truth has already come out
but just throwing around words that
really have no basis in fact and that
are very serious words
that is a danger of this hearing it's
been a danger throughout we in the
minority have tried to limit that danger
and i hope it will be continued in this
regard i do want to praise my colleague
mr mccollum who last night most of you
were gone said that he agreed that there
was no real proof of cover-up and in
fact even today in the washington times
um hardly a fan of the government's
position they said that the
hearing produced quote no proof that
wojnatsky and sarabin's reinstatement
was inspired by a cover-up so i think
all of us have a responsibility to make
sure
that when we throw around these words
that there be some backing for the very
reason that there are a few in the
extreme
of america who want to believe the worst
and saying things to them our
international audience that are not
backed up play into what i would
consider paranoid fears um finally i
would say that again yesterday's hearing
was dramatic
it served a purpose
but let's not
let's not uh
forget and let's not get away from the
fact all the major
facts mr rodriguez's testimony mr
sarabin and mr hoynotsky's response were
already in the public record i stand by
my statement that nothing very
materially new came out even the thing
mentioned by mr mccollum that uh atf
gave up on the idea of serving koresh
he's right but it was criticized atf was
criticized in the very report for that
in the blue book which i think is a it's
not a hundred percent accurate document
but it's a darn good job
next point i would like to make is about
tuesday morning quarterbacking and this
relates to the next phase of the
hearings it's going to be very easy for
every one of us in hindsight to say
this was done wrong that was done wrong
and today for instance we're going to
hear from a lot of tuesday morning
quarterbacks we're going to hear from
critics volunteers amateurs who've had
no experience in negotiating with a
heavily armed cult
we're going to hear from those who bore
nor bore uh no responsibility then are
now forever taking action
and even we're going to hear from some
who have conflicts of interest lawyers
in lawsuits who benefit from positions
against the government
and we ought to be careful
just remember this ladies and gentlemen
we were dealing with someone who had an
apocalyptic vision
take the hypothetical that janet reno
waited more than the 51 days and on day
57 koresh through some
maddening view of his own
set fire to the compound while the fbi
agents had still surrounded it guess
what would be happening
everyone would be criticizing janet reno
for being indecisive and for not taking
action
monday morning or tuesday morning or any
morning quarterbacking is easy but we
must remember that we had what what that
it is difficult to do and furthermore
that we had an armed group of people led
by someone who was
a child molester led by someone who
violated
violated laws
another argument that will come up today
is about limits to tolerance
well
we're going to hear a lot of academic
lectures on how we should be tolerant of
new religious sex
i firmly believe in that
i believe in faith
i respect faith i have faith myself
i was the author of the religious
freedom restoration act which expanded
the bounds of what religions could
permissibly do
against uh in in america no matter what
the government said in fact myself and
chris cox uh joined in that uh
uh crusade with senator kennedy orrin
hatch and passed the law last year
but folks
there are limits to tolerance
sexual perversion the rape of small
children
the hoarding of large amounts of weapons
is not excused by any religion
and by any bible
finally um
[Music]
let's keep
up doing something i've detected a
change in the tone of these hearings
from my friends on the majority side
the first few days
there was much more bashing of law
enforcement than there is today
i believe
nervous let the record show nervous and
defensive laughter uh
not in your wildest dreams not your
wildest dreams in any case in any case
let us keep remembering
let us keep remembering
the brave men and women of law
enforcement who were under significant
significant strain and stress
they are not our enemies
the atf was not our enemy
the fbi is not our enemy if they made
mistakes
let's correct them
but
let us not weaken them let us not bash
them let us not pick apart every single
little immaterial decision that they
made in an effort to bring those proud
and brave agencies down thank you mr
chairman chairman
if i might i'd like to ask you now to
dissent that the interview transcript of
ron nobles of cbs on 60 minutes may 14
1995 be entered in the record without
objection so ordered
we have today
a special opportunity to
hear some new additional information
and i'd like to just introduce the
biographies of the panel dick garan
is a widely recognized defense attorney
in the state of texas he represented
david koresh and entered the compound
during the siege
i
would like to also introduce mr jack
zimmerman
also a well-known and respected attorney
happens to be a new grandfather within
the last few hours
we appreciate you being here you
represented steve snyder he also
gathered first-hand evidence upon
entering the compound during the siege
in addition to being a defense attorney
mr zimmerman is a colonel in the united
states marine corps reserve he practices
as a military judge two very credible
witnesses welcome
you uh would please stand take the oath
raise your right hand
do you swear and solemnly swear that the
testimony you're about to give these
subsequent subcommittees and the truth
the whole truth nothing but the truth
thank you please be seated
let the record show that uh both dancers
were the infirmary yes
and i'd simply like to greet
these two very fine attorneys and find
constituents and appreciate their public
service as well i know both gentlemen mr
guerin and mr zimmerman who have given
of their time to the less fortunate
uh who have been stellar members of the
texas bar association
and additional
bar associations throughout the nation
and i'm just very proud to have them
here and have them as americans i have
them as texans and to have them as
houstonians and i welcome you thank you
very much jackson lee i appreciate that
i also note that their families are
sitting behind them and we welcome all
of you
the
first question the chair would like to
recognize the chairman of the full
committee on government oversight mr
bill klinger from pennsylvania mr
chairman before i yield to the gentleman
in maryland i would just note that the
gentleman from new york indicated that
he sensed a change of tone
on this side of the aisle might i say
that i have recognized a similar change
of tone on the other side of the ally we
do recall at the beginning of these
hearings uh the gentleman from new york
indicated that he thought that the there
was no purpose these hearings they were
redundant perhaps politically motivated
i was pleased to hear him say this
morning he feels a useful purpose is
being served by these hearings which i
totally agree with at this point i would
then like to yield the rest of my time
to the gentleman from maryland mr early
thank you
welcome to washington thank you
in more ways than one right
uh mr zimmerman by way of introduction i
have a question for you but by way of
introduction
sitting here for the first four days
particularly with respect to yesterday's
testimony
i am
fairly satisfied that a lot of the
procedures a lot of the personnel a lot
of the mindset
that
atf had prior to waco it's no longer in
place and that's been a very positive
aspect of these hearings
to me one of the most disturbing
findings or pieces of evidence that
we've we've uncovered so far was a
series of memos that mr barr
brought forth i believe last friday
now sir you're certainly are not an
amateur when it comes to criminal law
are you oh sure in fact you are a
professor of law i am a board certified
in criminal law by the state and
national boards
and sir uh you are also i believe every
uh reserve marine colonel i just retired
yes sir as a colonel in the marine corps
reserve
and you have sat as a military judge sir
that's correct that was my last
assignment
sir uh
are you familiar with the material that
was produced last friday with respect to
a series of memos
emanating from the department of justice
to treasury
that the topic of which
generalizing
was a directive to treasury
to cease investigation into various
aspects of the waco
incident because brady type material
had or could be produced are you
familiar with his memo sir generally yes
sir
now sir
and i think mr noble's testimony
yesterday was quite illuminating because
we're not talking about the shooting
investigation that atf
had conducted we're talking about
directive simply from justice to
treasury and so my question to you is
uh and this goes far beyond these
hearings in my view
do you have a professional opinion sir
with respect to
the
appropriateness
of those memos and those
directives yes sir i do could you please
provide this committee and the american
public with your opinion
as i understood the rationale
yes
closer to you yes sir how's that great
if there's a specific part of any
particular memo it might make more sense
if i would have it in front of me but in
general as i understood what happened
was
the rationale given for those directives
was to work to prevent simultaneous
investigations
correct sir i i think that's what it was
that's been the testimony
uh
in general
if an investigation were going forward
and being done correctly it probably
would not be necessary to do two and one
might get in the way of the other
but that's not what i understood
the purpose stated in the memos was as i
understood it said
that the memos were revealing that the
evidence was not hanging together and
not fitting together and that it was
creating brady material that would have
to be turned over to the defense now sir
the uh the phrase brady material has
been thrown around these hearings would
you please give a definition that the
american public can understand yes sir
there is the supreme court the united
states has established a constitutional
rule that if there is evidence
that would either go to
excopate or show the innocence of an
accused person or would lessen the
punishment if convicted and the
prosecution has that evidence that must
be provided to the defense so that the
fact finder the jury or the judge would
be aware of it so in reality it creates
an affirmative duty
on the part of the government to
to produce
exculpatory material is that correct
that's correct but in state and federal
prosecutions
and my understanding was from those
memos is that the concern was not that
there not be two simultaneous
investigations that might be stepping on
each other
and going in different directions but
instead the purpose of stopping
the second investigation if you will was
because it was producing conflicting
exculpatory type material that under the
rules would have to be turned over to
the defense sir is it your testimony
that such memos directly contradict the
law
that brady dictates
if if as a result of those memos
exculpatory evidence was not turned over
to the defense i think that
whoever was on trial in the in that
particular case this or some other case
would probably if that could be proven
to have been material evidence that
would have affected the outcome of the
trial would probably result in new
trials for the people who were wrongly
convicted
thank you sir
mr zimmerman
mr zimmerman also uh let me direct you
to the events surrounding the incident i
know you certainly know you have a lot
of information
uh
could you describe the
that took 911 and and do you have an
opinion sir
as to why it took so long to secure a
cease-fire
let me tell you what i know about the
9-1-1 first and then move to the second
one if that's all right
when dick digen and i were in on april
the 1st and conducted a fact
investigation so that we could give
legal advice to our clients
wayne martin told us that he had called
9-1-1
as soon as the shooting started
and i remember distinctly interrupting
him and because he was a civil lawyer a
harvard law school graduate and i said
wayne
don't
lie to us
because 9-1-1 calls are recorded and
when we get out of here we're going to
go get those 9-1-1 calls and if your
voice is not hidden on them then we're
going to doubt whatever else you tell us
so we were aware on april the 1st that
that was that there was a 9-1-1 call and
they said it reflected
uh what had been passed on by the
postman that is that 75 armed men were
going to be making an attack
and you know there weren't 75 men as it
turned out but i think it's significant
when the 911 tapes were released there's
wayne martin using that exact figure
there's 75 armed men here they're
shooting we have women and children call
them tell them to stop it to hold off
uh when
we were in we were also told that the
firing started from the outside and that
they had been fired on by helicopters
if you listen to the 911 tapes that were
eventually released you hear my client
steve schneider in the background in
some other part of the room
maybe he didn't even know that that the
telephone call was being made and he's
saying here come the helicopters now
here come the choppers
with people on them
they're firing again
so that's recorded
and so the significance of those tapes i
think i'm to your second part of your
question to me and to dick was that we
were being told the truth by the people
on the inside
by independent evidence that has nothing
to do with the credibility of our
clients that is a recorded telephone
call
mr wise from west virginia five minutes
a gentlewoman from illinois miss collins
i thank the gentleman for yielding
uh before i begin my questions let me
make an observation
the 51-day standoff at the davidian
compound was according to the department
of justice unprecedented in the annuals
of american law enforcement over the
51-day period there were 25 trained fbi
negotiators maintaining daily contact
with people in the compound they
consulted with a vast range of religious
medical and scientific experts
those critics who will argue that the
fbi should have waited even longer have
a big burden
koresh was a known liar and a child sex
molester the physical conditions of the
compound were deteriorating every day
no one left a compound before march 23
almost a month before
the insertion of the cs gas
while we will never know for sure
whether an appeal to quresh on the basis
of religious dogma would have resulted
in his
surrender there are some things about
his religion that we do know
we do know that karesh used his religion
to justify sexually molesting young
children
we do know that karesh used his religion
to terrify children we do know that
korres used his religion to separate
children from their parents we do know
that korres used his religion to murder
atf agents
finally the words of young carrie jewell
continued to ring in my ears caress she
said was not coming out he wanted to die
under these circumstances it's difficult
to believe
that any other outcome was possible and
so mr de guerin uh i'll ask you did you
hear the testimony of 14 year old carrie
jewell who testified that she was
sexually modest by caress when she was
only 10 years old yes ma'am but i didn't
come here to defend
uh david korish and i don't intend to
what i did come here for is to give my
knowledge to this panel and you did not
answer my questions and so my next
question is was karesh concerned about
the public's perception of him as a
child molester yes he was
isn't it true that child molesters don't
live long in prison
if i see the
what you're leading to
no yes he was afraid of judging i don't
think you can read my mind you can get
to answer my question uh
there's there are efforts made to
segregate child molesters in jail from
the rest of the population and when
they're not segregated they're in danger
of being killed
well did you ever talk about his chances
of surviving in prison as a known child
molester yes he did and i've covered
that subject with sheriff harwell and
was assured that he would be segregated
in the jail
so then he did have some major concerns
well after you became his attorney did
any of the children women or any other
davidian uh come out of the compound i'm
sorry
after you became his attorney
did any of the children or the women or
any other davidians come out of the
compound no ma'am
why would you say that was
because they it was their home they
didn't want to leave their home they
didn't know why they had to leave their
home
uh they they were a religious community
that were
were very proud of their home they built
it by hand
they didn't want to leave
how long were you
his attorney
well from
march the 9th until april the 19th so
it's roughly four weeks
well it's a little longer than that four
weeks
uh did you do it on a pro bono basis or
were you going to charge some kind of
fee it turned out to be pro bono i was
hoping to be paid and i thought i
probably would be but it didn't turn out
that way
in order to talk with korres you went
into federal court and filed a petition
for a writ of habit corpus is that
correct yes ma'am
and um in our uh my understanding is
that federal district judge walter smith
jr ruled that koresh having been
involved in the killings of four atf
agents ruled that cult members do not
have legal rights to counsel while they
remain holed up in a heavily armed
compound is that the fact no ma'am
explain it to me uh he ruled
that
uh habeas corpus was not the proper
method for establishing contact with
i believe he was wrong
and uh intended to appeal that ruling
but the fbi mooted my appeal by putting
me in contact with him
so the fbi then allowed you not only to
talk with him but to meet with him after
he and his followers had killed already
killed four atf
agents is that right yes ma'am
had you ever been allowed to interview a
client prior to his arrest for the
murder of law enforcement agents after
being turned down by a court
i've i frequently have interviewed
clients before they've been arrested and
when they're either being sought by
the the law with a warrant or before
warrants been issued that's it's a
frequent practice of criminal lawyers to
do so
you spend a lot of hours with karesh is
that right yes ma'am i did about 32
hours
in person and on the telephone
now is it true to say that he felt that
atf raid on the compound and the killing
of four atf agents was the fulfillment
of his prophecy
no not exactly he thought that it had
been prophesized that uh they would be
attacked
and it was a debate that we went into uh
quite
at length
about what it all meant and what was
next to happen
there was
i was receiving
advice from two religious experts about
apocalyptic vision and the bible
i wasn't very well well versed in it
myself i'm just a methodist but uh i did
learn a lot
both from david and from
dr tabor and dr arnold who are the next
witnesses following me about his view
his view was a flexible view that is
he was able
to or
his view of what was prophesied was not
set in concrete they didn't have to die
and he didn't see
the end of this situation as necessarily
being his death in the death of his
followers
collins your time has expired
oh shoot i know you're having you're
having you're having a lot of fun
uh chair now recognizes mr boyer from
indiana five minutes
i think thank you mr chairman i just
have uh one
quick comment
uh that is uh i have to agree with my
good friend from new york about all of
us exercising the responsibility of our
words
and i think that's why
my laughter is that's why you see the
change in tone coming out of mr schumer
is that he does also i believe exactly
what he's saying is that we have to be
better exercise better responsibility in
our words and that's why some of us are
pretty upset with the president's press
secretary
uh being pretty loose with the with the
tongue and and saying things that i'm
sure he does not mean
and that's why you don't hear as much
about the nra and i agree with mr
schumer's assessment a couple days ago
that the water has dried up in that
river
and that's why you've seen the change in
tone coming from the other side and
that's why i had to share my laughter
when he accused us in the change of tone
so let me yield to my good friend uh mr
early for remaining balance of my time
mr simmons just as a
short follow-up to your previous
testimony i've been able to locate the
march 1 1993 memorandum wherein
it is noted mr bart went into this last
friday as you know
and i'm quoting from memorandum johnson
at this point advised hartnett to stop
the atf shooting review
because atf was creating brady material
that's what you're referring to correct
sir yes sir
insert your professional opinion as to
the
appropriateness
on the one hand
and on the other the legality
of such a policy
is what sir
well i think it's inappropriate any time
a prosecutor in an ongoing case and i'm
assuming the johnson you're talking
about is the assistant united states
attorney that planned or approved the
dynamic entry search warrant and
insisted on a dynamic entry and was very
much involved in the case and then later
prosecuted the survivors because they're
the same person
i i think it any prosecutor would say
it's inappropriate to try to discourage
brady material being turned over now
i don't know from this whether brady
material ever existed
and so that's what probably mr johnson
would have an out on if there were no
brady material
and none in fact was withheld then there
might not be cause for a new trial but
if grady material existed and it was not
turned over then somebody needs to have
a hearing and establish for a court that
brady material was in fact suppressed i
don't know whether it was or wasn't from
here thank you sir
a question for both of you and and quite
frankly i had hoped
not to get into this area because
i have found
the testimony with respect to the issue
of who shot first
quite compelling
from the atf agents who have testified
in front of this
joint panel
now
because you brought it up and because it
is a legitimate issue
in these hearings
let me ask an open-ended question to the
both of you what is your opinion on the
basis of the evidence that you've seen
with respect to the issue of who shot
first
part of what a lawyer does is to try to
gather facts
about the crime and so much of what i
did when i was inside was interview
witnesses and look at evidence
what i saw and what i was told
was very compelling that the atf fired
first
understanding that
uh those on the inside had a big stake
in this and and i might have been lied
to but what i saw confirmed
that they fired that the atf fired first
uh everyone who was in a position to
know from the inside told me that that
the firing came first from the outside
some people said that it was the dogs
that were being killed and there were
dogs
killed that is it was part of the atf
plan to kill the pet dogs when serving
this civilian
search warrant
i was told that firing came from the
helicopters and jack zimmerman and i saw
the bullet holes in the ceiling of the
highest room in the compound
i saw the bullet holes in the front door
now you this panel
can can
get that evidence what you need to find
is a videotape that was made of the raid
it disappeared what you need to get
is the photographs of the front
that are similar to the one that's being
displayed right now this is a photograph
that was taken with a long-range lens
from
the the
surveillance house
there's bound to be more photographs
this is early in the raid as you can see
and there are very few bullet holes in
the front of the building if you'll
remove to the next uh photograph you'll
see this is taken later and there are
many bullet holes that you can see in
this photograph
these bullet holes
are
and you can see from the from the news
video tape how they're made they're made
by officers that are firing blindly
uh just emptying their clips at the
front of the building
now if you'll notice the door i sat by
that door for several hours i went in
and out of that door
10 times
and i saw the bullet holes on the door
on the right side almost every bullet
hole was an incoming round
and what i mean by that it's a metal
door
you could easily tell that the bullets
were incoming rounds they were punched
in
i'm not the the marine expert that jack
zimmerman is but i've been hunting since
i was 10 years old and i know a bullet
hole when i see it and those were bullet
holes that were punched in now you have
the power to get that evidence and you
ought to get it
mr chairman i i know my time's up but i
also asked my question to mr zimmerman i
think it might be appropriate for him to
complete the answer you're correct
i agree with everything dick said we
tried to corroborate just like with the
9-1-1 tape corroborating that didn't
have anything to do with our clients
telling us and i think some testimony
you got yesterday from the atf agent
that has been who from new orleans
uh
was very telling
he said that
when they were getting out of the trucks
they were already drawing fire and it
was coming from almost every window on
the second floor recall that
and he said it was uh ak-47s and
50-caliber
machine guns were shooting at them well
if you put that first one back up there
when you go back and look at the
evidence that just doesn't hang together
okay to use a phrase that you've already
seen in one of your memos that does not
hang together because
uh there are no bullet holes up there in
the second floor and there's nobody's up
there shooting in the second floor
there's no windows open up there on the
second floor there's no guns out of the
second floor there's no ak-47s or 50
caliber machine guns yet the atf has
already dismounted and out there and
looks like they've already taken some
casualties yet no one is in those upper
windows nobody's in the lower windows
and let me tell you if you think
that the branch davidians had 48
automatic weapons
and 50 caliber machine guns
already arranged in a quote ambush
position
and they see you've got to visualize
this there's about a 500 yard
driveway coming up to this place in a
plane i mean
you can see it from a long way away they
had already been tipped off if the
branch davidians intended to ambush
those people with 48 machine guns and 50
caliber machine guns and they came up in
unprotected cattle cars with nothing but
tarps on them
they would have blown them away
so that convinced us
that they did not that is the davidians
did not fire first now you asked about
our personal opinion my personal opinion
is that it was an accidental discharge
uh by one of the atf agents as he was
dismounting
and
that that was a signal to open fire
which you haven't heard any testimony
about nobody asked him what was the
signal to open fire if you did open fire
who made that decision what command was
it
but i believe that what the evidence
from the trial the criminal trial was is
that somebody off to the side heard a
fire heard somebody fire and they
testified that it came from behind them
so that's uh why we believe
for those reasons that
the
branch civilians did not fire first and
i will point out to you from talking to
the foreman of the criminal trial jury
who had six weeks of testimony by the
government and two days of testimony
from the defense
they could not decide and told me the
former of the jury told me they did not
decide
because evidence was in such conflict as
to who fired first thank you thank you
very much
my point of order is this point yes in
terms of the structure of these hearings
yesterday we were focusing on what
happened at the raid if these witnesses
had statements to make on who fired
first it's only fair to allow those who
are in the line of fire agents like
buford and rodriguez to have some
rebuttal time and yet
excuse me except the way these hearings
were structured we they're gone they
made their point nobody controverted
them nobody brought up anything now we
have some lawyers who are not on the
scene saying they interviewed nameless
people i'm sure they can name them and
saying oh no it is not clear who fired
first that is not fair that is not a
proceeding that is right if we want to
go over the issue of who fired first
then we should wait a second i'd like to
finish my point it's not a point it is a
point it is not a point of order you are
i will just make
one comment to the witnesses uh relative
to uh the videotape and the front door
we have
consistently asked as a committee to get
a copy of a videotape which they now say
is blank
we have asked for
the door and the door is missing uh i'll
now move and chair recognize mrs taylor
from mississippi for five minutes
do you have any combat experience excuse
me sir do you have any combat experience
26 months sir commanded two artillery
batteries in vietnam in vietnam yes sir
mr zimmerman did you happen to hear the
testimony of a fellow vietnam veteran mr
buford who had served with the green
berets
who said that even as a green beret he
had been ambushed and he'd been on the
losing side of ambushes i recall
he said he was never outgunned
that
in vietnam the way he was against the
branch davidians do you have any reason
to doubt that
no sir i i don't doubt his testimony i i
don't know what ambushes he wear in
vietnam if he was green let me just ask
you and again mr
uh your colleague said well he's just a
methodist i'm just a dumb coast
guardsman okay thank goodness i've never
been shot at
but i can
look at what i have seen you know
ambushes and
i would think if you're ambushed you
don't have the time to pick your shots
i just have a gut feeling bullets are
flying all over me and there's one of me
that you don't really have time to pick
your shot that basically that yes you're
going to empty your clip and hope you
hit something and you don't get hit in
the meantime that could be tricia yes
that could be true so that could very
well explain
the very bad pattern of shots around
those windows good
it could
i'd like to come back to that in a
minute though i want to answer your
question it could okay let me take a
step further and you you talked about
the
911 and let me tell you this if you were
an atf agent i would be defending you
the same way and if you were a marine
being accused of
being out of line i'd probably defend
you the same way
but i do look at something when they say
the helicopters are shooting at us i
mean they've had plenty of time to alter
the looks of things didn't they by the
time you'd gotten there
we came in a month later we came in a
month later but we thought about that
and if i may
we asked the texas rangers because and
i've testified under oath at the
criminal trial to this i couldn't tell
you whether those rounds were fired from
the helicopter or not all i could tell
you is they came from the sky downward
if somebody were standing on top of the
roof shooting down into the ceiling it
would look exactly the same way thank
you very much you made one for me simon
and another point i want to make do you
have any i understand you're a marine
and i thank you for your service to your
country do you have any sons or
daughters in service now i certainly do
my daughter is a captain of moraine
she's a prosecutor at el toro marine
corps air station my son who just had
the baby last night at 5 15. actually
his wife 5 15
[Laughter]
is a uh he's a first lieutenant of
marines and he's a uh naval flight
officer will be flying in the fa-18
delta jet congratulations to both of
them and thank both of them for the
service
my point is that many people say why did
they come back with armored vehicles
towards the end i'm going to personalize
this mr zimmerman
you're your general you're at commandant
monday
and it's your two sons
and they've already been one firefight
and the good guys got outgunned
they just flat got out gun they were the
ones the good guys the ones asking for a
cease fire not the davidians
it is the atf agents asking for a
ceasefire to get their wounded out
because they're being so horribly
outgunned
if you send them in the second time the
exact same way you sent them in the
second time walking across an open field
a perfect ambush site
or do you try to protect them do you
would you send your son or your daughter
in the second time just walking across
an open field with a warrant saying gosh
david you're just a horribly
misunderstood nice guy who
okay so you like 11 year old girls and
maybe you've held a few people here
again she will or maybe you got a couple
of legal immigrants here and maybe over
50 to 100 illegal machine guns but
you're really a nice guy and i'm going
to say my son and my daughter out here
walking across this open field because i
trust you are you talking about when the
fbi went in and armored vehicles is that
your question yes or the second
i have no problem with that okay but let
me say something because we're on
national television you said general
monday the new commandant is a classmate
of mine from naval cavern named chuck
crulac he would be real mad at me if i
didn't point that out yes sir and i
i only say that because i don't know if
general crew like has some sons in the
service
you're right and there's nothing wrong
with them
as far as if that were what they were
doing just using it to protect their
people when we get to how they were used
later on the 19th of april i have a
different opinion but would you send
them in with no protection
okay i want to make that perfectly clear
and i would not want your children
treated that way who are serving our
country
i'm going to ask you since you were
defense lawyers for a davidian and what
has now become the division same
question i've asked everybody else
have you seen anything or heard anything
that would lead you to believe or read
anything that justifies the murder of
those four atf agents
the 20 more who were wounded by the
branch davidians by david koresh and his
followers on the morning of february
28th yes sir yes all right tell me what
it
the jury in san is
the jury in san antonio
found
that the killings of the four agents
were in self-defense
they were acquitted of murder sir
did you know that they were acquitted of
murder and acquitted of conspiracy to
commit murder every single uh defendant
all 11 were acquitted of murder so
that's why we're answering it that way
because obviously there's evidence that
didn't convince a jury weren't the
menendez brothers acquitted
is our judicial system perfect are you
going to tell me that every murder in
this country who's walked was really
innocent well you asked me did we know
of anything that would say that they
weren't guilty of murder and the answer
is yes
everything we just told you plus a
jury's verdict after a six-week trial
bring it closer mr zimmerman
those weren't atf agents those were your
two children who were sworn to protect
this country in a different branch of
the service yes
and they did what those atf agents did
yes was it justifiable for david cress
to kill your kids
i wasn't there but if the if the atf
accidentally or however opened fire on
people in their home and all they did
was defend themselves in their home then
under the law that's justifiable
homicide it's not murder
mr ehrlich is being is recognized for
five minutes
sir this is why i did not want to get
into this this is a very emotional issue
we have compelling testimony on both
sides
uh it's a very difficult issue that each
and every member of this of these panels
has to struggle with
and just
for the last minute here
let me make the record clear
sir is this your testimony as a result
of interviews with the jury foreman or
individual jurors
that
they came to a conclusion with respect
to who shot first and my follow-up is
was there a jury interrogatory with
respect to who shot first and what were
the uh instructions from the judge to
answer your second question there's just
a general verdict of guilty or not
guilty on each of the separate charges
there wasn't a question about who shot
first and yes sarah bain the foreman of
that jury said they were not able to
decide who shot first
may i make a comment though because yes
sir i'd like to keep us all focused i
think we have the hearings are going
right to what
congressman schumer had said should be
let's focus on
law enforcement so that we can increase
their statutes we don't want none of us
want the fbi or the atf to be
destroyed by this we want their in them
to be enhanced by it if who fired first
is really irrelevant because you need to
look at that atf plan i look at it if
just like
congressman taylor said if those were my
sons and by the way one of those four
who were killed was one of my marines he
was a reserve
marine
we ought to look at it and say is that a
faulty plan
was there something wrong with the way
the atf conducted that even if they were
ambushed which i don't think they were
but even if they were how silly is that
to
have an operation in an open area like
that with no cover when you suspect
people to have 50 caliber machine guns
and automatic weapons and then just
sacrifice those people like that
you know if that kind of operation order
were given by a marine second lieutenant
going through the basic school they
transferred the guy to the air force
mr chairman mr chairman
let me tell you sir i appreciate your
comments both of you because
the purpose of these hearings are
twofold and certainly not to denigrate
law enforcement is to find the facts as
best we can
arrive at our own individual opinions
and to make sure
as i prefaced my remarks along the same
lines that changes have been made so
that something like this could never
happen again and that's certainly the
twin purposes of these hearings
my time is running out and i have a
question for uh mr uh targaryen
sir de garin
this is the classic monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday morning
quarterback question
but let me ask it anyway
would you describe sir in your own mind
your opinion with respect to the issue
of how
what could have been done to get the
davidians out of that compound without
bloodshed
we were on the way to doing that
on april the 14th
there was a major breakthrough
and that breakthrough was david korsh's
letter to me which i promptly gave to
the fbi
that said that he'd received his mission
that he was working on writing his
interpretation of the seven seals and
that everyone inside was relieved that
they didn't have to die now that the
prophecies were not being fulfilled now
and that this would be resolved and i
talked with steve schneider
on the telephone about that
i talked with the survivors later and
the
the the mood on the inside had
definitely changed on the night of the
13th and the morning of the 14th of
april i had those letters
reviewed by dr tabor by dr arnold they
agreed that this was a major change
in what had gone on in in the in this uh
religious view that was so overpowering
all of those people in there they
believed
that they could not
do anything except what their religion
told them to do but sir let me ask you
how do you respond to what my view is a
very legitimate observation a rejoinder
to to your observation that you're
dealing with a con artist you're dealing
with a guy who was desperate you're
dealing with the guy who knew he was
looking a very long prison sentence if
he walked out of that compound uh
someone who was
a real bad character or had sex with
kids the whole nine yards who had lied
on a consistent basis
how does your opinion jive with those
facts
i'm not going to again try to defend
david korish but what he told me
about factual matters and about
religious matters all panned out what he
told me about what had happened his
ability to relate the facts to me and
for me to check those facts all panned
out
we were not dealing simply with
david korres but we were also dealing
with steve schneider a former teacher of
comparative religion with wayne martin a
harvard law graduate they were they were
rational they were reasonable and they
had this
this religious
uh compulsion
that was not understood by the
negotiators and
that was not appreciated
as being serious it was serious they
were sincere about that
i see my times about to run now i just
wanted to take this opportunity to
thank the both of you for your
appearance here today and for your
factual opinions
given to this
panel and this country an unemotional
way and i appreciate it very much thank
you
gentlemen's time has expired mr scott
from virginia has five minutes
thank you mr mr chairman i'd ask both
the attorneys if you were involved in
the trial of the um
aftermath
neither of us were lawyers i was called
as a witness uh mr congressman
uh you indicated that there were
did you indicate that there was a
finding of self-defense or desponding of
not guilty finding of not guilty uh
in the criminal trial usually there's
just a a general verdict and it was a
fine
the only defense to the murder and
conspiracy to murder was
self-defense
well you could have also had
a finding that these davidians weren't
responsible
for the killing of the officers
however others
had they been on trial would have been
guilty is that accurate
that that's possible but they were also
found
or some of them were found guilty of
voluntary manslaughter and that the
judge
well it was a it was a mixed finding but
self-defense
the judge only applied self-defense to
conspiracy to murder and murder and they
were acquitted
or everyone who was acquitted of those
offenses
uh mr scott or congressman scott i don't
know if this will help you understand
the context of that though but from the
let me tell you the context is in
response to mr taylor's question where
he said that they were justified that
there was justification for killing law
enforcement officers
and you used the verdict as uh your as
your rationale now sir his question was
to you have you known anything do you
have you read anything have you heard
anything that would provide
justification for murder and i said they
were not convicted of murder and what i
was going to add to you sir was that the
prosecution's theory from the opening
statement on was that everybody in the
place all of these people were all
responsible and they said we will put a
weapon in every person's hand well in
that trial let me get to some physical
evidence have you seen you did you
indicate that you'd seen the door that
um
the front door yeah
and you saw
uh
bullet holes all going one way is that
what i understood you to say i said most
of the bullet holes so there were
bullet holes going both ways there were
there were no bullet holes in the uh
that i noticed in the left-hand door
this was a double door and it opened
if you're facing the compound as these
photographs are the door on the right of
the double door is the only one that
operated it opened inward
but
are you sure that there are bullet holes
most of them going in is that your
testimony yes sir yes sir
in fact i didn't see any coming the
other way to be honest with you because
there was a barricade by the time i got
up there i didn't see any coming the
other direction
mr de guerin did so i think we may be
able to get the door so we can
sure if you can get that door
make sure that you get the correct door
the door that survived for the trial was
the door on the left
and the door on the right disappeared
it has to be the door on the right
that's where i saw the bullet holes the
door on the left was stationary and the
way that it happened as explained to me
by coerce we have a tape here that in
which he explains it was he stepped out
and onto the porch and was met by
gunfire from the agents and then went
back inside
and slammed the door and he pointed out
those bullet holes to me
those are the
that that's the door on the right hand
side is the door that had the the door
handle
and the the door that survived for the
trial was the wrong door
i'll yield uh one minute to the
gentleman from new york
let's just take this hypothetical
gentleman and that is that the atf
agents advance on the compound the
davidians shoot from the windows they're
not going to shoot through the door
the
and then in response the atf agent shoot
back of course the majority of bullet
holes would be through
would be going in that direction because
the davidians are not going to keep the
door closed and shoot through it oh they
wouldn't would they so all the bullet
holes of course should be going in one
direction
that's not the issue the issue is who's
fired out of the windows first and i
appreciate the gentleman reclaiming my
time let me let me change subjects a
minute do either one of you question the
validity of the search warrant or the
arrest warrant yes yes
and what is your
challenge of the validity uh vagueness
stale information uh there were
and let me make clear here that i think
the panel has been somewhat misled by by
thinking that there was no challenge to
the search warrant what the judge held
was that the challenge to the search
warrant was moot that is it didn't make
any difference because
the atf nor the fbi was not claiming to
want to introduce any evidence gained as
a result of the
serving of that search warrant so it
didn't matter
to the issues in the trial and thus it
wasn't litigated
if under the leon rule was it much to
litigate
even if it was illegal would it make any
difference
if it was deliberately
falsified under franks versus delaware
then leon would not apply if it were
just illegal but in good faith illegal
was there any point in uh litigating it
well you know i've got a philosophical
argument that you can't have a a good
faith illegal
but
you'll admit important the leon rule
there's not much point in litigating it
and i would ask you if you have a
situation where you want to challenge
police practices as being illegal
um
how do we protect innocent people we
can't have a viable exclusionary rule we
need a viable exclusionary rule and leon
is an abomination
uh in in our criminal jurisprudence
if you have access to that door could
you get it and also the missing tape of
the 28th
she said you thought we could get the
door
i understand that it was uh
in when was it not introduced in court
we're looking for the door that's
missing
if you can get it you know where it is
please bring it i'll do the best i can
mr chairman
chair now uh recognizes mr shabbat ohio
will the gentleman yield
if the reporters from the waco tribune
and the lady who said she was held
against her will
show up with the door
okay
admitted and are allowed to testify at
about the same time i chair thanks the
gentleman from mississippi for uh those
outstanding remarks uh mr chabot please
five minutes
thank you mr chairman um before i yield
i just like to comment that periodically
during these hearings
we've heard it insinuated that one side
or the other
is more pro or less pro law enforcement
than the other side
and i would just hope that everyone here
shares the goal that we should learn as
much as we can from the mistakes that
were made at waco so that we can protect
the lives of both law enforcement
personnel
and civilians
and with that i'd like to yield the
balance of my time to the gentleman from
north carolina mr howard kobo
i thank the gentleman from ohio for
yielding gentlemen good to have you all
with us mr zimmerman it may be because
of my advancing age but you don't look
old enough to be a grandpa thank you sir
good to have you here nonetheless mr
chairman i'm going to extend before i
put my questions to these gentlemen to
what the gentleman from ohio said i'm
trying my darndest to keep my composure
during these hearings but it is becoming
increasingly difficult
yesterday an associate stopped me on my
way from the floor
and he said i'm getting tired of you
republicans and one democrat trying to
bash law enforcement
well as my grandma used to say that made
my coffee taste real bad
i said to him i said what up on what do
you base this i said how much of the
hearings have you observed oh i've seen
none of it on television he replied
i only read it in the newspaper
i said to him i said friend for your
information as far as i can tell
no republicans nor democrats for that
matter are bashing law enforcement
and i am about to lose my composure now
but here's a man a well-informed citizen
already rushed to conclusion having not
watched one second of the hearings all
but he read it in the printed media well
he needs to either start reading other
newspapers i told him or find time in
his schedule to watch these hearings
mr zimmerman as you pointed out the word
is enhanced
i'm not bashing law enforcement and
neither are my colleagues
and last week
many of the questions were framed in
such a way to imply that those of us who
endorsed these hearings in some way were
sympathetic to koresh
and i resented that as well
mr de guard as you pointed out we're not
here to to defend koresh but having said
that
i want to pick up where the gentleman
from maryland
left off
we'll strike that let me say one more
thing while i got my temple boiling
someone
earlier talked about monday morning
quarterback as though it works folks
that's what hearings are all about
hearings provide us with the luxury of
applying 2020 hindsight
if no mistakes were ever committed there
would be no need for hearings sure we're
applying monday morning quarterbacking
sure we're applying 2020 hindsight
hoping
mr zimmerman as you pointed out to
enhance the reputation of these federal
agents i don't like the idea that the
atf and the fbi are blasted bash now
having said all that
back to koresh mr gerd de guerin
if i were hosting a hamburger cookout in
my neighborhood saturday night
i don't believe koresh would make the
cut on my guest list
i don't think i'd want him there
having said that
do you belie and you were talking to the
gentleman from maryland about this
apparently you believe that he was
sincere in his religious convictions
based upon your conversations with him
is that a valid conclusion yes sir
something that has bothered me
and this is the third time i've
mentioned it is the the non-arrest of
this fellow
he was the nerve center of the compound
it was always my belief if they could
have taken him
under custody and control of the atf or
whoever
got it out of there get the charismatic
leader away from the compound and then
conduct your search
the treasury report said on the one hand
oh he never left the compound so
therefore we couldn't arrest him well at
the criminal trial it became apparent
that he did in fact leave the compound
then the treasury's defense subsequently
was well it wouldn't have been a good
idea to have arrested him because if
we'd done that
mr noble himself said
evidence would likely have been
destroyed and other agents i think said
that that the davidians would have
resisted
is it your belief mr de guern that he
could have in fact been arrested
beyond the confines of the compound i i
do believe that he could have been and
and i've
investigated that
and talked to people who had seen him on
the outside
the the local service station that was
just a few miles away had seen him very
recently and frequently he jogged out in
the neighborhood almost on a daily basis
he went to a local
bar and pub in in waco called the
chelsea pub people there remembered
seeing him in the weeks uh immediately
before the raid he had been seen all
over the place the what the what the
treasury report
accurately says is
the the uh the undercover operation or
the excuse me the surveillance operation
didn't accurately
record whether he came or went they
abandoned the idea of arresting him
outside
i think because they wanted to arrest
him with a big show
mr de guerrero my time my time for this
segment has expired we'll pick up on
that subsequently thank you mr covel
chair now recognizes mrs slaughter from
new
york thank you mr chairman i'd like to
divide my time this morning two minutes
to mr taylor three minutes to mr greene
if we can find him
he's with the door gene
goes
okay
thank you miss laura mr zimmerman
in your capacity as a jag officer are
you normally on the prosecuting side of
the defense side i was the chief
prosecutor of the second marine division
for a period of time and the chief
defense council of force troops atlantic
sir so you've done both done both and
okay trial judge
as a defense attorney you're obviously
very good at it
and as is mr tagueran
would you be offended
or let me take it a step further would
you move for a mistrial or for the
sentence to be thrown out
if only the prosecution
was allowed to call witnesses
and you had evidence compelling evidence
in defense of your person
but you weren't allowed to submit it in
court
i would always ask permission to put on
whatever evidence i had sir
and there is compelling evidence in the
case of the reporters who wrote the
story
that appeared in the waco paper they
were so afraid for their lives that they
left town the paper changed the locks
they issued new security measures they
take the markings off their vehicles
so that the davidians won't be able to
identify their vehicles as being a part
of that paper
there's a woman who claims to have been
held against her will for three months
by caressing his followers there is
another who says quresh is compiling a
hit list of former members that he wants
to have and i'm using his word
eliminated
that's pretty compelling stuff
now on behalf of those four dead at atf
agents and the 20 who were wounded don't
you think in fairness as a defense
attorney
they ought to be allowed to submit that
evidence to this body that that would be
similar to the question the judge would
have to make as to whether it witnesses
a material and and i think that what
we'd have to do to answer your question
is what's the focus of this
investigation that you're doing now and
if it was material then you should have
those people if it's not material this
would be just like at court a judge
might say i'm going to deny your motion
for subpoena because these witnesses
aren't material i would try to show they
were material in my if you're asking me
what i would do but i don't always
persuade the judges to do the right
thing mr zimmerman let's get back
i don't know i didn't call these
hearings i'm here i think some good
things i'm yes ma'am
mr green
thank you i'd like to thank my colleague
for yielding time uh
mr gary and mrs zimmerman and i your
reputation obviously is well earned in
houston and the texas courts and and as
mr taylor said y'all are very good
defense attorneys and having seen you in
the halls once in a while when i used to
practice law your reputation is there
let me ask a little bit about um
mr zimmerman about the defending
themselves and and i have some problems
with
uh somebody breaking into my home you
know
and i have the right to defend myself
and your uh
response is mr taylor's question
um
on who fired the first shot but anyway
if someone is charging up to my house
and they're wearing
atf you know vest or or jackets or
whatever else they have
and do i have the right to you know to
respond to them and
whether they're in police uniform
whether they were in an atf jacket or
something like that and again as a
lawyer tell me because one of my
concerns and from my constituents is
that we have the right to defend
ourselves in our home and somebody's
breaking in how do we know that they are
police officers particularly in texas we
have so many different kinds of police
officer uniforms that's right and and
and i can't give you an answer that
would apply everywhere sir but the
answer bit is what was the conduct of
the police officers on the raid
uh my memory is from the videotapes that
the the that the atf was on the back
not on the front
and there's be it might be some question
whether they were at
a vest here that day that had i believe
atf on the front okay of the vest
the identity probably wouldn't be the
issue the issue is what they were doing
because this was daylight if somebody
comes in in a military military type
attack and fires first and lays down
automatic weapons fire like we believe
was done on that front door then i
believe the law in texas would allow you
to defend yourself if they just come up
and say we're here to search serve a
search warrant you have no right to
resist that with force
none
the
the best evidence we have so far the
live witnesses who were here of course
the atf agents said that you sit at
another table but at the same setting
that they did not uh fire first and it's
your testimony that the vidians in your
interview room and mr garren you said
you talked to them 10 times and of
course they're not here and the best
evidence we have is that
it's from the the atf agents who were
there
let me get one
more question in before my time actually
runs out on the bullet holes in the
ceiling again
there was no testimony even from one of
the uh
atf agents in the helicopters that there
were any um shots fired from the
choppers when you said there were shots
in the ceiling it could have been from
either someone on the roof or did you
look at them again mr garren you said
that
you've hunted all your life and you can
tell whether shots incoming or outgoing
if it's a wood roof
well let me let me correct that it was a
sheetrock ceiling
okay and you could tell from the way the
sheet was punched out down
that it was bullets that had come down
that it punched that out
now
i asked the davidians to take
photographs of that because i wanted to
preserve that as evidence and i asked
the rangers when they did their search
to please note that ceiling
because i expected it to to survive of
course it didn't but it was clear
to me and clear to jack that those were
incoming rounds now
there was no one on that roof
never was it's a flat roof it's uh you
can't see it in that uh photograph but
we see another photo it was the highest
structure in the neighborhood the only
way that those bullets could have been
made was from someone standing on a roof
shooting down or someone shooting from
the helicopter
gentlemen's time has expired
chair now recognizes the gentleman from
indiana mrs saturn
five minutes
i thank the gentleman from indiana
gentlemen as you all can tell by the the
format here we have to do this in
segments mr deguire and you were
wrapping up about about the lack of
arrest of quresh if you will continue
what you were saying i'm sorry someone
coughed and i didn't hear you i say you
were wrapping up in response to my
question concerning why quresh was never
taken into custody if you'll conclude
that well
frankly i i think it was because
some of the supervisors
wanted to continue and make a big show
that this went off i i think that
this is editorializing i think we need
to focus on
not why the raid went bad necessarily we
know why it went bad the surprise was
lost
but why it was planned that way in the
first place
excessive force
provocative force
provokes
as the word implies
a a violent response
i i might be able to get you to hit me
if i came up and was provocative enough
to you but whose fault is that is that
my fault or your fault for hitting me
when i provoke you
my point is that this dynamic entry
which really means a military style raid
was wrong from the beginning
asked the ask the fbi agents asked jeff
jamar who was an agent in charge if the
atf had asked him in advance
should we do a dynamic entry there he
would have said no if
you just don't do
a raid like this
on a building that had over 50 rooms 130
residents women and children because you
cannot get all those rooms and all those
people secure quick enough not only is
surprise important but speed is
important and if you can't get them
you've got a hostage situation i think
that's been changed we learned yesterday
let me put this to you and mr zimmerman
both
just prior to the to the big raid the
firestorm
i believe you were you all were in
negotiations with the fbi
uh
on a regular basis were you not
we were speaking with them we were not
negotiating on behalf of anybody we were
just serving as lawyers trying to get
them out and into the courthouse okay if
you will from either of you tell us how
that progressed whether or not
the fbi was cooperative with you whether
they were deceptive with you did they
mislead you were they above board let us
hear about that
let me say that that the fbi treated me
cordially with respect
throughout my discussions with them and
i think that it was a difficult decision
for jeff jamar to make to allow a
defense lawyer to go in to
you know defense lawyers aren't real
popular with fbi agents and i'm sure
there was some distinct dissension in
the ranks about allowing that to happen
but he saw it
as a possible solution we had parallel
interests i wanted a live client in
court and he wanted it to end without
violence and to get everybody in in
custody and we we really worked hard at
doing that i thought we were really on
the road to getting that done the fbi
was above board with me they didn't let
me in on any of their secrets but that
why should they
they they treated me with respect
when i came out and asked questions
about what would happen and what would
be the conditions not as a way to
negotiate
they were
very forthcoming with me and
for instance on the first uh first full
day that i went in i came back out asked
to see the sheriff to find out about the
jail conditions and within 10 minutes i
was put in a car
on a walmart parking lot with a sheriff
so i could talk to him
so to answer your question they were
very forthcoming and and uh straight up
with me mr zimmerman i i echo that i was
a few days behind mr de garan because
their theory was we're going to try at
the beginning to use our own negotiators
that lasted about three or four weeks
then the next step was we're going to
let mr koresha's lawyer come in and see
if he can do it and then dick had
requested my assistance because steve
schneider was doing most of the talking
if you know and he was my client his
ethical lawyer didn't want to be talking
to another lawyer's client they were
very professional to us and i'll say
this i i don't want to take up more of
your time but in my written statement i
make that statement i have publicly
stated i have great admiration for the
fbi
gentlemen how about the loud music the
playing of the loud music anybody want
to be heard on that that was the wrong
tactic
it was the wrong tactic when when you're
trying to create trust
between the fbi and the
and the uh davidians
then you don't
try to uh
punish them or torture them at the same
time
i'll never ask about about the
advisability of that it's it's not
advisable under that circumstance under
what we've had and going on in waco that
was the wrong tactic increasing that
pressure rather than driving away from
david korish had
the effect of bonding them closer
together shared sharing a terrible
experience like basic training for
instance
you bond together people from diverse
backgrounds no matter how different they
are will bond together with that kind of
experience and that's exactly what the
fbi was doing it was wrong and the
second reason it was wrong is because it
played right into this apocalyptic
vision that they had the end was coming
with with chariots of fire with
giant beasts
breathing fire and here are these tanks
going around there breathing fire it
just played right into this apocalyptic
vision that was the wrong tactic so so i
guess what what they had hoped to do
would be to separate quresh from his
followers in effect resulted in a
cohesive binding probably is that what
you're saying yes sir yes i agree the
red light illuminates again mr chairman
i'll conclude for the moment
thank you mr cobo uh chair now
recognizes mr watt from north carolina
thank you mr chairman um
and i want to express my thanks to the
witnesses for being here and
the candor with which they have
presented their
statements up to this point
i want to i think it was mr de guerin
who
has indicated that he thought the
dynamic entry was just a bad
mistake
and throughout the hearing
i've been periodically when i have a
chance to ask questions
trying to
to identify our legislative
nexus here uh what what it is we're
trying to accomplish
i take it that
there is nothing we could do
legislatively
that would directly bear on
whether
a dynamic entry in a situation of this
kind
would be appropriate or not
i did hear secretary benson or former
secretary benson
when he was here
say that
[Music]
as a result of what happened at waco
the
treasury implemented a series
of
one or more rule changes
um
having to do with
the level of supervision and
and uh
the level of reporting responsibility
uh between atf and folks further up in
the supervisory chain
i suppose we could have
as a congress ordered
a more direct level of supervision
but they have done
done that now before we got to these
sharings
can you identify
um
anything that you either of you thinks
that we ought to be doing
legislatively
in response to
uh the waco
incident uh and i would invite you
specifically to
to talk about uh
um
in terms of the
the level of supervision that was there
but also
to give me your thoughts legislatively
in in terms of
[Music]
what we can do
to assure individual rights uh against
uh
surges and seizures that
that are unreasonable
and uh i would ask you also to comment
uh
if you are aware of
the specifics of
the bill that we previously
passed out of the house
in this session of congress i think it
was house bill
666
i invite you to give me your comments on
whether that helps us
in protecting individual rights
or whether
we have done a disservice to the rights
of american citizens well
one thing i can
beg
that you not do is do away with the
exclusionary rule
i think that's
the only thing that that has been shown
to be effective in enforcing the fourth
amendment
i was i was
very encouraged to hear director mcgall
say yesterday that he's already
instituted
[Music]
within the treasury department the
requirement or within atf the
requirement that they
confer with other agencies
and secondly i was very happy to hear
him say that in the future dynamic entry
will be done only as a very last resort
uh
as legislatively what can you do
gee i don't know uh if you can re if you
can undo leon
uh that would be a giant step in the
right direction explain that for me
so that i make sure all of uh
particularly the members of the
judiciary committee understand that and
maybe
the the members of the american public
might understand it can you can you put
that just in yes sir in simple everyday
language that maybe the american people
can understand basically what leon says
is if you've got a search warrant uh and
you act on it then
you're acting in good faith and you
can't challenge the illegality of the
search warrant as practicing lawyers we
know that usually judges rubber stamp
the applications for search warrant and
the only thing the way we made progress
in uh the jurisprudence of this country
was requiring
search warrant applications to be
accurate and to have enough probable
cause in them to justify
a supposedly neutral and detached
magistrate into authorizing
a search
but if but leon wipes that out
if you've got some uh judge
that
is
doesn't
carefully read the search warrants and
and uh cynically i say that happens all
the time then he just rubber stamps it
and you go and that's the end of the
inquiry it shouldn't be what impact
would house bill 666 have on leon i'm
i'm not familiar with you you know
i believe in general i understand it
deals something with lessening the
the
requirements
for federal law enforcement officers
only as it relates to search and seizure
but that's about all the detail that i
know am i thinking of the right bill may
i answer your other question though mr
guerin has answered the second part
i don't i'm answering the question about
what can you legislate that might
prevent
atf repeat i don't think you can
legislate judgment
but i think that what you can do in your
oversight responsibility are two things
change the procedure
that led to waco
and change the leadership that led to
waco now they came in and told you
yesterday that they've already changed
the procedure
all right we have to give take their
word on that they're professional law
enforcement but i can tell you what the
american public does not buy that
they've changed the leadership because
nobody has been disciplined in a
meaningful way there's been no criminal
prosecutions and people have committed
felony offenses mr marvetti told you
yesterday the two of those agents in
charge of this raid committed federal
felony offenses there's been no
prosecution and there's been no
meaningful discipline and those people
are still atf agents they work for all
of us we pay their salary and i'm still
paying cereben's salary and waznowski's
salary and i don't like that those
people should be removed from their
positions now on the fbi we haven't had
a chance to address the fbi and we're
going to be gone pretty soon so i hope
we can get some questions about the fbi
pretty soon there has been no one
disciplined because of waco in the
entire united states department of
justice chain of command that's horrible
10 people died on february 28th
80 people died on april the 19th and no
one's been disciplined no policies have
been changed the only thing they've done
is they've asked for more money to
double the hostage rescue team size
that's ridiculous
so what you can do
change the policies change the
leadership it has not happened
gentlemen's time has expired
the gentleman from north carolina mr
colbert will resume questioning for five
minutes thank the gentleman
in the fall of 1993 treasury and justice
issued their respective reports about
waco
and i'm paraphrasing now but treasury in
effect said well atf blew it we were the
bad guys fb justice on the other hand uh
exonerates the fbi well folks when i
read when i got those two reports
i hate to admit it but i guess four or
five weeks in this town one if you don't
develop a severe case of paranoia you're
a rare bird indeed i thought this is all
too coincidental
one group conveniently assuming blame
the other group waltz waltzing away with
no blame i think as i told the attorney
general i said everybody who touched the
ball at waco fumbled it now having said
that
gentlemen one or both of you i believe
and i don't think this is an either
report to which i referred
you all were involved in a surrender
plan
with the
fbi we had one we had one already
arranged and agreed tell us i'd like to
hear about that about what the proposed
plan was yeah most of that was proposed
by the fbi and dick and i made only very
minor suggested changes which they
incorporated but the plan in general was
this the
people on the inside were going to tell
us tell the fbi the night before
dick and i were going to be there we're
going to start during daylight so this
is all done during the day
and dick degarin and david koresh were
going to exit first to show everybody
that they weren't going to get executed
the minute they stepped outside
and
there would be a metal detector set up
outside the front door and a bus 100 or
so yards away approximately when mr
daguerre and mr quresh went through that
metal detector then mr karesh would have
plastic
wrist restraints placed on him be patted
down
by a male fbi or atf agent
fbi was our request and then he would he
and dick would go to the to the bus and
then i was supposed to stay in there and
then see that the other adults came out
keeping a distance so that law
enforcement wouldn't get nervous about
people bunching up
it was going to be tape recorded by the
fbi and it was going to be a press
representative there taping it so that
there'd be no claims of police brutality
and there'd be no claims
uh that
the opposite in other words both sides
would be
protected and then as that went through
steve schneider would be the last brand
civilian out and i would bring up the
rear when they saw me coming through
there that was the signal to send into
hrt teams they'd come in make sure
nobody else was hiding anywhere once
they cleared that then that eod
explosive ordnance disposal team was
going to come in check for booby traps
make sure there wasn't that then the
feds were gone the texas rangers were
going to take over and the people who
were wounded or needed medical care go
to a hospital everybody else goes to the
command post where a united states
magistrate judge was going to be there
and they'd be warned taken into official
custody appointed a lawyer or released
if they weren't charged with anything
and the only suggestion that i can
remember and maybe dick can add to this
but the only suggestion i remember us
making was i said i'm uncomfortable
about those little kids walking out by
themselves can't we let the kids walk
out with their mothers and they agreed
to that so that was all worked out in my
judgment we had a deal we were going to
do it we told them on the 14th they were
coming out we told them it would take
another 10 12 days we asked them do you
have that much time they said we have
all the time in the world to resolve
this peacefully well what frustrated the
plan gentlemen some desk bound
bureaucrat in washington overrode those
people's judgment down there
mr dagar do you want to add to that i i
don't know exactly how the decision was
made
but
obviously they decided and someone
pushed for it and that's what you ought
to find out someone pushed for
a plan to send tear gas and not just
regular tear gas cs gas
which has been banned for use in
international warfare we can't use it
against our worst enemies but they used
it against those kids somebody
pushed for that plan
and it was too soon it would have ended
peacefully in my opinion
i don't know who made that decision
that's for you to find out and i hope
that you can find that out i don't know
whether it was done on full information
i don't think it was done on the
information that we had we tried to get
the information to them about
this religious aspect and the sincerity
of that coming to pass and them coming
out
what that's what frustrated it someone
wanted to end it
by forcing in the end rather than
letting it end
mr zimmerman i almost feel sick to my
stomach when i hear you say how close
that could have
almost within your grasp
and if that could have been
executed as you just laid it out
this hearing probably would never have
been called
we wouldn't be here if the fbi had
waited 10 more days i shouldn't say the
fbi if the department of justice
would have waited 10 more days and if
they didn't come out where what how much
farther down the line would have been
what would have been lost by waiting 10
days
i don't know if this is appropriate time
to tell you but
i heard mr noble talk about those
funerals and i believe he was sincere
about it but i got to tell you that this
has not been a pleasant experience for
dick degueran and me
because the branch davidians had
families
they had people that loved them one of
the worst things that i can remember
about this was a phone call from israel
from shulamet cohen
the mother of pablo cohen who had just
been there came over from israel and as
far as he was concerned was there from
one of those remember somebody described
the group as musicians and so forth and
so on he was in that group
when the press reported after the fire
that i had represented steve schneider
apparently on cnn everybody in israel
was watching this
i got a call from miss cohen
and between
her sobs to ask me if i had seen pablo
and i had dick and i had talked to him
on april the 4th
and there had been a tape from his
mother and one of the things that we
asked the fbi to do which they agreed to
do was bring that return tape out with
the legal documents and the letter that
was addressed to dick and i told her
about that
and then she described for me an israeli
jew talking to an american jewish lawyer
watching that gas
be inserted into that building watching
an american tank
knock down an american house and then it
burst into flames
and you imagine the images in an
israelis mind with the holocaust
survivors in israel
i couldn't answer
i think you can tell from today it's not
often that i'm without words
generally i could not explain to her how
that happened and her answer what her
question was
i thought he would be safe in america
gentlemen gentleman's time has expired
thank you i want to miss chairman i just
want to thank the gentleman for being
here thank you mr chairman i what i have
no time to yield back but thank you
you got pretty good for your five
minutes though
uh the chair now yields to the
gentlelady from texas uh sheila jackson
lee and i understand you have a piece of
audio visual
uh mr chairman i thank you very much and
i wish as the gentleman from north
carolina i might be so lucky as to have
those minutes yielded to me so gentlemen
i'm going to have to talk very quickly i
would like number 32 to be brought over
to me but as i begin let me um
say that
the compelling
statements are such from both of you
having been inside
is uh not in my
purview to try and overcome both the
emotion
uh and as well the overwhelming feeling
on the loss of life i will simply
acknowledge that we lost lives
i'd like to join however my colleague
chuck schumer say that i wish you were
here yesterday and i think you're right
mr zimmerman you need to either continue
with us and i know your time is limited
because much of what you have to say
deals with the fbi and department of
justice and we should get to that
let me um i'm not sure where it is as it
comes
um be able to
be able to uh just uh see if we can
concede on on a point of confusion
uh because that's why we are at these
hearings and i hope that maybe at the
end of these hearings we won't have
confusion but when those
atf officers testified yesterday they
were moving toward the door
to serve
a search warrant and as they moved
toward the door to serve that search
warrant they testified that shots came
out i know you have since indicated
that there may have been the possibility
of them shooting first meeting these atf
agents but it could have just as well
been the door closing
slamming the door and shots coming out
the door maybe you said something
differently so i need to understand that
because i don't think this picture gives
us any evidence of who shot first
and and what i'm going to tell you may
not tell you who shot first but i'm
telling you my experience it does the
testimony at the trial was is as the
agent and he didn't say this yesterday
and out of fairness to him he wasn't
asked this
but the testimony was that as he walked
up after david koresh closed the door
remember he did say david came out said
something the door closed the testimony
trial was is then
fire erupted from inside and it all came
out that front door the right hand side
that front door and that's what wounded
people
the the bullets came from the inside
through the closed door which is what i
was trying to convey to mr schumer
because he's absolutely right that makes
little sense to me
and i don't think the jury bought it
either because as dick said now one of
those pictures that picture right up
there you see that person sitting there
with his head about 18 inches far and i
want to keep us on this okay well
because this is the scene that we
referred to okay you see the the bullet
holes in the right hand side of the door
as you face it
the atf agent's theory was that the
bullets came through that door from the
inside
what dick and i saw were bullet holes in
that right side right where david koresh
had been standing as we were told by the
davidians but they weren't coming from
the inside they were going from the
outside in
that's why we believe that uh
that what the branch of idiots were
telling us was true so we have a point
of confusion and you were there after
the initial first day raid correct and i
guess uh my point is is that this still
photo does not confirm for us
where those shots came and i appreciate
your assumption and your analysis having
been inside and i do believe that the
point of us being here is to try and
resolve it but i wanted to make sure
this photo does not evidence the final
word on who shot first no uh and i wish
you were here yesterday and i'll i'll
just leave this for now let me move
quickly and if mr taylor can get that
right door it will solve working on the
door
uh and his witnesses i hope we can get
the emt uh dispatcher and the cameraman
but let me uh go on to say there were
not convictions on conspiracy and murder
my understanding that's correct but
there were convictions on gun violations
and some of the and some of the
defendants that's correct let me ask you
with respect to i hate using h.r 666 let
me just call it this new legislation on
the exclusionary rule
um what would be your position and i
think the american people need to
understand the layman's language that we
no longer had the necessity of a viable
paper search warrant that we could act
on good faith how would that have
further impacted this very tragic
situation
my main concern with anything that deals
with the exclusionary rule is not what
happens to do with a paper a piece of
paper is not what i'm after what i want
is to involve a neutral and impartial
non-law enforcement officer so if you
didn't have that anymore if you didn't
have that undercover agent as i said on
the municipal court bench reviewing in
other types of situation some
independent force bringing that
undercover agent who've been in the
field sweating tense to review it losing
that intervening action you think would
be detrimental yes absolutely i can't
believe a magistrate approved that
search warrant to be honest with you but
certainly if we remove that by law that
would be a problem it would be terrible
it would it would put the entire
discretion
over whether your fourth amendment
rights are
observed in the hands of an officer
who is often
as the as it goes often engaged in the
competitive enterprise
of ferreting out crime
someone with
his ox in the ditch so to speak someone
who wants that search warrant and and
you've got to interpose a judge in that
decision and i point out innocent people
then would be impacted negatively yeah
absolutely and if we're talking about
searching my time is almost running if
you do that so i can ask finish your
point let me so i can be able to ask my
last i don't know what 666 says and i
don't know if it's restricted to
non-home situations but a person no his
home is his or her castle and to allow a
search without a neutral and impartial
judge saying there's probable cause to
search a person's home i think lessens
all of our civil let me go on to say and
i thank you very much and i'm not
intending to cut you off let me say also
in dispute is there's a helicopter
shooting we have testimony that says
they retreated and of course there's
some question you indicated uh this is a
question mr chairman so i'd like to
finish it and be able to have these
gentlemen answer it you indicated that
that
it could have been when i say you i
think with mr degarin that uh shots
could have been through the ceiling but
i'm trying to isolate the disputed
issues this question follows for both of
you all to answer you were inside and
you made the points about
the setting the atmosphere
we are querying and trying to understand
so that we can ask intelligent questions
of the fbi
how the schroders
the
wayne martins of the world the engineers
the teachers or whoever went there were
mesmerized and so seemingly lacking in
the power in decisions to come out
and to save themselves the children and
the women if you would answer those
questions that question for me please
let me address that and i hope you asked
that same question of the two religious
experts that are coming next because
they can talk about it in terms that i
cannot but this was not
a bunch of people who'd had
uh who'd been hypnotized these people
that i saw and i met almost everybody in
there that died in that fire
these people believed they believed in
the bible
they were there because of the bible
most of them well i can't say that
many of them were there not because of
david korish
some people had been there as long as 40
years some people had been born and
raised there they were there because
they believed in a a vision
of the bible that was unusual i don't
understand it
and these scholars have a difficult time
understanding it but it was real
you can't legislate away that in fact
the first amendment says that we can't
do anything about that they believed
gentlelady's time has
the expired now recognizes the gentleman
from illinois the chairman of the full
judiciary committee mr henry hyde thank
you mr chairman i'd like to ask both of
you if you agree
with what i'm going to read to you
from an article by dean kelly of the
national council of churches that
appeared in the may 1995 a magazine
called first things
ironically just as the federal
government was abandoning hope for a
peaceful solution there opened up the
possibility of just such an outcome
early in the siege quresh had promised
to come out if his message could be
aired on national media he prepared an
hour-long audio tape that was broadcast
locally but not he claimed nationally
two scholars of apocalyptic religion
phil arnold of the reunion institute in
houston and james tabor of the
university of north carolina studied the
broadcast and believed koresh could be
reasoned with if approached within his
own frame of reference
after several futile efforts to persuade
the fbi to let them try
they arranged with ron engelman host of
a radio talk show on kgbs to which the
davidians listen
for a half hour's uninterrupted plea to
quresh to rethink his understanding of
the fifth seal revelation 6 9 11 which
he believed to be unfolding at mount
carmel in the text the souls of the
faithful who have been slain for the
word of god cry out to god how long
before thou wilt avenge our blood
they are given white robes and told to
rest for a little season until the
number of their fellow servants who have
been killed as they have been should be
complete the sixth seal that follows
brings about the destruction of
humankind arnold and tabor in their
radio colloquy sought to persuade koresh
that the term translated a little season
meant in the original greek a period of
as much as a year leaving time for
quresh to complete his work before the
sixth seal supervene
quresh apparently accepted this idea
from the day after passover he sent out
a letter via his lawyer
saying that god had permitted him to
explain in structured form the decoded
messages of the seven seals and that
upon completion of that task he would
surrender
the fbi saw this as just another in a
long series of delaying tactics and went
ahead with their plans to use tear gas
they did send in writing materials
however on sunday april 18th and quresh
worked most of that night dictating to
ruth riddle who typed his words on a
battery-powered word processor he
completed a five-page introduction to
the seven seals a poem of 13 quat trains
and a seven page exposition of the first
seal at that rate arnold and tabor
estimated he should have completed the
task in two or three weeks but he did
not get the chance the next morning the
fbi gas assault began and david koresh
must have concluded that his original
scenario of imminent destruction was
correct
do you agree with that i do
i can speak to that
if you'd like and
what we found
the fbi
uh ridiculed the idea that he would be
riding the seven seals and said
in fact after the fire said they had
evidence that he was not at work on that
we discovered
uh by talking to ruth riddle
that she had taken this computer disc
out with her when she escaped the fire
and we found that he he had been working
on it and it uh it was a real thing and
we also found that those on the inside
these believers
thought that this was a great uh
revelation to them
in that their death the end of the world
as prophesied by the bible was not
coming immediately but was some distant
time in the future that's what i was
trying to
with the help of tabor and arnold
talked to korish and the others about
that their interpretation that the
apocalypse was now was
that no it's a little bit later and
that's the history
of seventh-day adventism there have been
prophets time after time who have
prophesied the end of the world at a
certain date everybody gathers and they
wait for the end of the world it doesn't
come they dishonor that prophet and go
on
and that's the history of those people
the unfortunate thing is in the context
of jonestown and the james jones
experience there is such a cynical
uh approach towards religious fanaticism
there is an unwillingness to understand
or believe that there are people in the
world who are persons of belief and they
believe
strange things by our standards but had
had some underst had the understanding
then these weren't hostages
these were willing members of a
religious group and to get
to get in there and to dissipate them
would take persuasion
argumentation from in their frame of
reference not tear gas and not tanks
and that it seems to me was was the
judgment made somewhere along the line
that ended up costing a lot of life yes
i agree i agree and and if you and your
next few days will find out who made
those ridiculously dangerous decisions
and i think that would be exercising
your oversight responsibilities and
you're the only one the country can do
it
well i thank you for saying that and i
think that shows the utility of these
hearings we may not come up with any
legislation there doesn't always have to
be legislation but we ought to come up
with information
that will help guide us in the future
because i'm sure jonestown and waco
are not the end of this sort of
situation thank you gentleman's time has
expired chair now wish to recognize mr
brewster from oklahoma five minutes
sorry
beeper going off all kinds of problems
here vote going on
you gentlemen probably had more contact
with kresh than anyone that that i know
of
uh there's been a lot of discussion
about what would have happened had he
been arrested when he went to town on
the weapons charges or whatever was
there anyone else in that compound in
your opinion that could have pulled
everybody together in a violent manner
no sir
my client was steve schneider my partner
jim levine was
judy schneider's lawyer the two
schneiders were married and had a
two-year-old child
steve was labeled by the fbi as the
quote first lieutenant along with the
other military terms that were applied
like the compound which i've noticed
from these hearings y'all have all
accepted it was mount carmel center for
35 years and then when the fbi came in
it became mount carmel com compound
first lieutenant cultist etc
steve
was a
articulate decent peaceful
uh guy who was a college graduate and
had his degree in in theology uh
if the fbi considered him the second in
command i can tell you without any
reservation that steve schneider would
not have organized any kind of violent
resistance
uh to a search warrant in fact when i
had my comment my first meeting with him
i thought he was going to break into
tears when we were dick was asking the
standard lawyer question about
we've got to find out where the five
davidians that were killed are you know
where are their remains we need to make
sure they're preserved for autopsy so we
can see the angles and so forth put some
pretty tough stuff
and then
steve start talking about their loss of
life and he volunteered to me
how sad they felt at the loss of the atf
agent's life so in my judgment there
would not have been a a a violent
resistance
frankly i don't think it would be a
violent resistance
if the search warrant had been served in
a proper manner even if karesh was there
but to answer your question
if one of the many times he was away if
he had been arrested put in federal
custody for three days which they can
keep him for three days with no reason
at all
execute a search warrant the next day
i think this all could have been uh
resolved and avoided you would agree
with that mr good figure i i do agree
with that uh
and i think that it could have been uh
done in a number of other different ways
and history shows they had a good
relationship with the local sheriff
uh he'd surrendered peacefully before on
much more serious charges understand
that the charges
that the atf were bringing were
relatively minor federal felonies now
well you know going to prison that's not
real minor but in in the scheme of
things it the maximum punishment for
these crimes would have been about 10
years in in the penitentiary under the
federal guidelines probably the time in
the penitentiary would have been two or
three years so they're not really that
serious and he had he'd surrendered
peacefully
on charges that could have landed him in
jail for life
he had invited the atf he told us that
story about mcmahon that mcmahon told
here
he told me that inside and i found out
that to be true i telephoned mcmahon
talked to the girlfriend he had invited
the atf to come in and look at the guns
back in july of 1992
i think
one texas ranger could have walked up to
the front door and knocked on it and be
let in
that's my opinion that's my next
question is i've heard all kinds of
stories that the rangers wanted to be
involved in the negotiations that koresh
had
wanted to negotiate with them is there
any validity to that or is that only
rumor it's it's not exactly that way
it's not rumor
what i wanted to do
and what i proposed to david korish
after talking to captain maurice cook
was that david
the world's watching
let's have one texas ranger walk up to
the front door and you and i will walk
out and surrender to him that'll be
sending a message to the people of the
world that you don't trust the atf and
the fbi the feds that got you in this in
the first place but you do trust our
legal system and the texas rangers and
being from texas there's that story
about one riot one ranger and i thought
that that would be a real good thing to
do he agreed with it he thought it was a
good idea and he agreed to do it that
way but not immediately i went back
i assured got assurances from uh captain
cook that that was okay with him but he
said you've got to go through the fbi
it's just protocol and they're running
the show and you've got we're not going
to suggest it to him you do it i did
suggest it i
i can't say it was rejected
but it wasn't greeted with a lot of
enthusiasm
okay if uh
if they if after his letter april 14th
what would you have expected the time
frame to have occurred had the rate on
april 19th not occurred it would have
been at least a week
maybe a little bit longer
did this compound have uh toilet
facilities in it or i notice a in
referring to the treasury department uh
deal here they sent a guy to an outhouse
at one point
uh did they even have toilet facilities
in there they did but very few they were
building this place this was new
construction although it was used lumber
and they were doing it themselves and
they're very proud of it they didn't
have
a lack of
toilet facilities out of design just
they hadn't built them yet they were in
the process of building it i went into
almost every room in that compound and i
saw the building that was going on they
were doing it themselves there were
shower stalls there were toilets they
were
they just weren't operating yet they
were in the process of construction
future plans that they had inconsistent
with
the world's going to end now
and there were other things that showed
future plans
uh for instance i was to file a lawsuit
to perfect title to the property they
were worried about that i've
prepared an intervivo's trust
so that any
money that came to them
or to david as a result of book rights
or anything like that over and above
legal expenses would not go to him but
would go to a trust for all of his
children and i met 14 of his children
and
and there were other things that were
inconsistent with a suicide plan
gentleman's time has expired the chair
would like to announce that uh there
will be at least two votes uh which will
take us about a half an hour
uh we think that's in the best interest
of everybody if we recess and convene
at 12 45 p.m it's going to be a long day
and
i think we'll just
recess until 12 45.
we'll return for more of day five of the
waco investigation hearings but first
some programming notes
wednesday on c-span south korean
president kim young-san declarations of
independence
book notes sunday on c-span at 8 p.m
eastern and pacific time
we now return to further coverage of
today's joint hearing looking at the
1993 raid on the branch davidian
compound in waco texas
the oversight committal committees on
waco will come to order
chair now recognizes ms ross leighton
from florida five minutes thank you mr
chairman i would like to yield my time
to mr boyer
thank you gentlelady for uh for yielding
one thing i want to make a comment on
is the
one of you i think maybe it was you mr
zimmerman testified that we've had
changes in policy
but no really changes in the leadership
yeah sure that was that you yes sure one
thing that i have noticed is i've
last few days as i've listened whether
it was secretary benson or mr noble from
yesterday and
uh is that this it appears that the the
uh political appointees
uh in the whole waco so far it's it's
almost been uh see no evil hear no evil
speak no evil i either wasn't in charge
at the time but i sure am in charge now
uh and and uh
either i didn't have the authority or it
was outside my jurisdiction or or that
briefers didn't tell me enough
information because if they had given
information i probably would have made a
different decision at the time
so uh but it's good to know they're in
charge now
um
wow
let me uh
did you want me to answer a question no
i guess that was really political
editorializing
uh on my part and the change of
leadership perhaps will come later
um let me ask a question with regard to
uh um
an arthan an arson uh expert i'm gonna
go down here for a moment
did either of you have an opportunity
either you have an opportunity to uh to
meet with mr paul bray
the so-called independent arson expert
who reviewed the cause of the fire let
me tell you how that happened
i got a telephone call
within a couple of days of the fire
from paul gray who identified himself
as an independent arson investigator
with the houston fire department
saint paul grant who's a business
service here u.s department
yes he told me that
he told me that he was a houston fire
department arson investigator he'd been
appointed to an independent panel
to examine whether
the fire and whether it was set
deliberately or accidentally i said i'll
cooperate in any way you want i'll come
back up to waco i'll tell you what i saw
on the inside and how the place was a
tinderbox and so forth
and
agreed to do so and i called jack
zimmerman
to tell him that i'd been contacted
maybe jack ought to come up with me
because he was there also to be
interviewed jack said wait a minute this
guy paul gray
was with the atf i think i've got his
card
his wife
is his wife employed also by apf i
understand his wife is employed in the
houston office of the atf
um i called the texas rangers and told
them wait a minute i've been contacted
by this paul gray should i talk to him
they said we don't know anything about
him i'm familiar with texas
rangers independence
different texas i know you liked him no
no i think
it was clearly
misleading mr boy i have that card here
if you want to see the original of that
card
mr grade investigated the case that i
had been involved in during the 80s and
the name struck a bell and his card
which you really can't see on that blow
up there that shield
says special agent
uh the
u.s department of the treasury and uh
that's when i informed mr to garen that
not only
uh he had been
his office had been at the that address
up there and phone number is the atf
office
he officed there from 1982 to 1990
his wife was then at the time of the
raid and is currently when he did the
arson investigation of this fire on the
19th was still employed and he had been
in attendance at the funeral one of the
slain atf did either of you let him know
that you were on on to him that really
wasn't yes i did i called him back and
told him
that i'd talk with uh ranger captain
cook
and captain cook had advised me not to
talk to him without a ranger being
present and that i wouldn't do so and
that i knew that he had been assigned to
the atf for many years and i didn't feel
like
he could be
impartial and an independent
investigator and that i wouldn't meet
with him
he told me originally that his
report was due out the following
wednesday
and
as i understand it he then sped that up
and got the report out on monday before
we were able to reveal that it was
really not an independent arson review
right
at the mr zimmerman your testimony
describes some misinformation coming out
of the department of justice after the
fire can you summarize
i heard you say that could you please
tell me what you're referring to
there were a number of things that
bothered me because i knew that they
weren't true and yet they the uh public
statements continued to say them for
example
it started
uh
with the
10 30 in the morning briefing and it was
a combination at the beginning of both
the atf and the and the fbi
the
they said that the atf did not alert the
press before the february 28th attack
well you know now you've heard testimony
that there was in fact
contact by a spokeswoman for the atf
they said that they they publicly
announced that the atf did not lose the
element of surprise i think that that's
been well established in these hearings
and by their own report
they said the two cultists confessed to
starting the fire on april the 19th
and uh of course that made everybody
feel better because as the nation
watched all the children and and the
women and the old men burn up there if
they knew that the cultists had started
to fire themselves they'd feel better
about that and i yeah so they announced
that they uh they confessed when there
was never any confession to that you're
bringing out a lot of interesting
statements i want you to go to conclude
but
were either you guys interviewed by a
treasury or justice on these these
reports
no i was not interviewed by either of
those
uh independent organizations i mean to
interrupt your answer would you please
continue zimmerman
they kept putting out the word that the
april 19 operation was a non-aggressive
action
and after the public saw that tank
knocking into someone's door
i think that even they began to call it
an assault
they said that the justice department
couldn't wait even another day because
the children were being beaten during
the siege
of course stick to garen and i had been
in there two weeks before and we just
could not believe that somebody would
say that because we'd seen those
children we talked to them we saw how
they looked and of course the fbi
quickly corrected that that came out of
the justice main justice and the fbi
said look we just gave them the 1992
reports there had been investigations by
child protective services and found
insufficient evidence to go forward
they said it was a planned mass suicide
they kept putting that word out it was a
planned mass suicide and of course
uh dick and i had talked to those people
about a planned mass suicide and uh
every time we talked to them that we're
sure there wasn't i'm telling you what i
was supposed to be the last guy out on
the on the surrender plan and if there
had been even the slightest inkling
in our minds that that they were going
to burn up the building or blow it up
i wouldn't have agreed to be the last
guy out and also nine people did survive
that fire and they escaped that fire
if there was a mass suicide plan why did
those nine leave they're still very
devoted to david kresh
and they they escaped you know why they
escaped because they were near an
opening they were near a window and they
got out the other people were trapped
and couldn't get out
and when the bodies were found
david koresh and steve schneider and
another person were found totally
separated from everybody else not
exactly a mass suicide scenario
they were putting out the word that the
people murk they murdered branch
davidians murdered people to keep them
from escaping
of course there's no truth to that at
all there's no evidence to support that
and at the time that i wrote my written
opening statement that you have in front
of you i wrote that in may 1993 when
everything was really fresh
and my memory was really fresh i wrote
that back then and at that time the
autopsies had revealed
maybe a dozen or so gunshot wounds i
think when they got through it was up to
17 or 18.
well there were 80 semi people in there
and dick and i had talked to them we
knew that six of people had been killed
by the atf
on february 28th they better have
bullets in them on autopsy and then we
knew some other people had been wounded
inside that is france davidian so they
ought to have had bullets in them so
there may have been a couple of people
that
that rather than go through the fiery
death and the painful burning to death
may have if there was a weapon there
decided to put their their relative or
their friend or themselves out of misery
but it certainly wasn't a murder
situation
of course they
are you to finish the thought i have
about one more sir okay are you
answering the question i'm answering the
question about the misinformation
program that we were okay with you're
answering the question you can proceed
the next one was is that of course that
david koresh was not working on his
seven seals project that it was a sham
that they had like they actually held a
briefing
on the day of the fire if you look at
the tape it says
we know they were lying to their lawyers
well we know now dick has gone into that
you'll talk to the next witnesses and
they'll give you a copy of that seven
seals uh the first seal transcribed and
lastly
uh
you know they said that they the
government was had gone in on february
28th and april the 19th uh
because of the child abuses occurring
and i think that we can probably let
that go by saying that will probably
never be proven beyond
to anybody's satisfaction that that was
occurring on april before february 28th
before april the 19th and neither one
even if it were justifies federal law
enforcement launching military attacks
because they have no jurisdiction over
that matter anyway
thank you very much uh chair now
recognize the gentleman from michigan mr
conyers
thank you mr chairman
mr zimmerman
uh are you representing any of the
branch davidians in lawsuits against the
government no sure
mr de girvin no sir i'm not
right
uh one of you made the statement that uh
if we'd had ten more days you you felt
that uh
mr koresh would come out
uh what do you base that on
we were called
um we called the we were allowed to call
by the fba on april the 14th and they
told us that that waiting period in the
book of revelation had been answered and
that david koresh was to decode the
seven seals in writing that would be
ending that waiting period and they we
told him send it out to us he put it in
writing he signed it we gave it to the
fbi he told us it was taking one to two
days for seal he had finished the first
seal i was working on the second one so
that'd be about 10 days sir
well we there had been so many
disappointments uh
with mr karesh's uh agreements to
cooperate
that we had had a
a little bit of a problem there as far
as i'm concerned and as far as atf was
concerned
now mr zimmerman is it true that in 1987
david koresh and his mighty men
including stephen schneider who's been
described by one of you as a peaceful
man engaged in a gun battle
to settle
a dispute with george rhoden over who
would be the leader
of the branch davidians
i i don't believe that's an accurate
rendition sir
and can i back there was not a gun
battle
no the way you described it wait a
minute
engaged in a gun battle to settle a
dispute with george rhoden uh you don't
want to do that did that happen
no i don't need explanations yes or no
no i'm not aware steve schneider was
even he was in hawaii at that time what
about
david paresh was he in hawaii
no sir i see
okay
uh
isn't it also true after that incident
that mr quresh did not peacefully
surrender to the sheriff but was in fact
arrested at gunpoint
no that's wrong too sir i see
okay
now
we we have some
statements that
indicated that
there was uh
about the fires that that were begun and
i
i have
presented to you at the table the
electronic surveillance tapes or some of
the transcripts from them
the
[Music]
the the import
is that it uh
strongly supports the fact that
some of the davidians were themselves
uh starting the fire
these are electronic
surveillance tapes transcribed from
april 19th
and and the sort of establishes that
the davidians started the fire these are
excerpts
and shows that they were
pouring
fuel inside the compound during the tear
gas operation
the full transcripts revealed that the
davidians discussed
getting fuel ready and pouring it
needing more fuel
discussing
whether it was poured in the hallway
spreading the fuel where the fuel should
be spread
discussing whether to light the fire and
keep it going i
i bring to your attention selected
comments from
unidentified males
you want it poured
another
unidentified meal pablo have you poured
it yet
another voice things are poured right
another comment need to get the fuel out
another comment i need a gas mask
unidentified female unidentified male i
need a gas mask
another unidentified meal got any fuel
unidentified meal we need fuel
unidentified mail fuel over here
unidentified mail 6 10 am don't pour it
all out we might need some later
6 12 am
unidentified meal
you've got to get the fuel ready
another unidentified meal i already
poured it it's already poured
on
the page afterward
unidentified mail from the transcript
they got some fuel around in here
unidentified mail yeah they even poured
it already
unidentified mail poured it already
unidentified mail he's got it poured
already
619
side b of that
our side b there's no time indicated
uh
shall we light the package now yep okay
light it
now these are
these these are transcriptions that uh
are don't don't indicate that uh
anybody but the davidians
poured the oil the gas that set fire to
this compound
you nod your head mr de garan
yes sir i'm familiar with how it
concerned me
uh when i was being told by the fbi
that they thought that they had evidence
that the davidians started the fire and
i so i questioned
the survivors
that i
talked to in the jail the one ones that
got out they explained to me that they
were pouring fuel and that they were
making molotov cocktails to throw at the
tanks
if you'll notice that that pouring of
the fuel takes place
or the conversation about that takes
place about
in the early morning hours six and seven
o'clock in the morning
the fire didn't start until right around
noon it's questionable about whether it
started just before or just afternoon
but those
those uh conversations about pouring the
fuel i believe
had to do with preparing molotov
cocktails to throw at the tanks now they
never did throw molotov cocktails at the
tanks
secondly
as
all of the survivors
were unanimous in saying that they did
not
start the fire and knew of no plan to
burn the place down you know
well let's keep the fire going that
doesn't sound like pouring molotov
cocktails
i think the gentleman's time has expired
thank you mr micah from florida for five
minutes i can i can answer i can answer
that we we can get back to it
this thing can go on all afternoon if we
let it
thank you mr uh
thank you mr chairman i just have to
take 30 seconds here and say that ladies
and gentlemen on the panel and
the people that are are watching this
proceeding that i i'm absolutely
personally outraged at some of the
comments i've heard from the white house
and the administration i'm so glad mr
koble spoke to this earlier that
republican participation in these
hearings are some effort to discredit
law enforcement or attack law
enforcement or that i personally have
some hidden agenda in this
and and i'm just absolutely sick and
tired of it and and i i really resent
these people making those comments about
me personally
the other thing
uh is we have a responsibility and mr
zimmerman you talked about it a
responsibility
to to find out what happened here how 80
people that we don't count koresh
died in this and four atf agents and
many other wounded gentlemen can you
cite me any other instance in the
history of this country
where in a federal action there were
this many people killed by a federal
action i don't think there is one and i
don't think there's another one that
ever had american tank cities against
american citizens sponsored have you
ever heard of that you've never heard of
that and i've never heard of tanks being
used against american citizens in their
own country
and we've tried to look at each thing
and we've had two of the fairest
chairmen in the house of representative
these individuals have been over
backwards to try to bring this evidence
out and if anything the administration
and other people have tried to obstruct
these proceedings even from the very
beginning and you've cited that mr
zimmerman have you not you were never
you were never called to participate in
any of these is that correct that's
correct that's good reports
you know i wanted to get into personnel
questions i had about 12 minutes
yesterday to discuss the personnel turn
the the chart over and show the the
personnel uh responsibility here and mr
zimmerman you pointed it out and we
heard it for several days rod zeke
rodriguez blamed ceremony
talked about hart hartnett and hartnett
blame noble
and then we got up to uh noble and uh he
said he wasn't in charge that maybe it
was simpson and then we asked we heard
from altman and altman said that uh well
it wasn't his watch it was benson and
benson blame reno what did the american
people think when they see this
is this the chain of responsibility
nobody was i ended up being fired is
that correct that's my understanding
they were fired and rehired yes fired
and rehired but that's some of the
questions here that need to be raised
what kind of a message you think this
sends to the american people when i've
given speeches on this subject around
the thing that bothers the mainstream
kiwanis club
accountants groups breakfast groups i've
spoken to the thing that bothers them
the most is they're worried that this
will happen again because the same
people are still there you were on your
way and you told us to resolving this
issue and you said you're well on your
way to resolving this issue and you were
writing in north texas i read your
statement last night
uh and they had delayed these
proceedings for what passover was it
they were celebrating passover and
that's why when our federal officials
made the decision to to do this is that
correct i don't know exactly when the
decision was made i know there was a
process going on i know that from
reading the justice department or hear
of any reports of children being
molested while you were in the compound
i saw all of the children i saw the
parents i saw the rooms where they were
living i saw their living environment
and i didn't see any children that i
thought were being abused one of the
things that concerns me is again the
government's use and we have a whole a
bunch of scenarios of mistakes
everything in here in all these reports
everyone says the government screwed up
isn't that correct yes sir well not in
not in the justice department okay
that's a whitewash all right well but
they pointed fingers but nobody took
responsibility in the report the
department of justice report i read this
this report and it describes the
condition of the children there were
over there were 25 you can't tell
exactly how many children were because
they were incinerated beyond recognition
but we'll give or take a few there
somewhere in the neighborhood of 25
people incinerated audrey martinez was
buried alive inside the bunker she died
of suffocation she was identified from
dental records 13 years old
these mostly doe because they couldn't
do 67 seven to eight-year-old boy buried
alive suffocated in bunker doe a
six-year-old girl suffocated inside
bunker
they used cs geck gas what do you think
about the decision to use this and these
children that were incinerated or
suffocated by an action of the federal
government can i tell you my experience
with csgo tell me the answer question
sir all marine lieutenants go through
the cs gas chamber to teach you how to
use your gas mask and to gain confidence
that that gas mask will work
so i've been through that and the
process is you go into a enclosed area
you pop the cs gas grenade you have your
mask on you take it off and you count
the 10 or state your name enough so that
you can inhale a small amount
then you put your mask back on put your
hands over the filters clear your mask
by blowing outward blows the gas out and
then you are able to breathe and you now
have a report didn't their reports say
that gas masks don't fit on these babies
that's correct and didn't they know that
they should have known that let me
continue if i go ahead when you come out
of that gas chamber and only haven't
been exposed for a matter of seconds
your eyes burn your nose burns and your
your
all mucous membranes are affected
grown healthy
cream of the crop of united states youth
marine lieutenants
are hurting when they come out of that
gas chamber in 1980 i was taking a
battalion to norway on a reserve active
duty joint nato operation we had to go
through that chamber because the
norwegians were going to use gas as part
of our training
i was going to be you know lead from the
front i was going to be the first one
through a temporary gas chamber we set
up at ellington air force base in
houston texas to make a long story short
i take my mask off they pop two grenades
doubling the concentration that it
should have been and i was choking to
death i couldn't see i was disoriented i
didn't know where i was and i was a
major of the marine corps i barely got
out got out to the to the fresh air and
i'm sitting there my eyes are burning
i'm i'm
vomiting
i'm kneeling over i'm in extreme pain
and all my troops are lined up there and
i know they were resisting the urge to
laugh at the old man doing that and also
simultaneously thinking i ain't going in
there
well we got it fixed the point i'm
getting at is
it's terribly debilitating ces gas is
terrible and i know it's still that way
because both my grown children at the
time waco was going on where lieutenants
at quantico they had gone through the
gas chamber my daughter just went
through again under annual training last
week now you're going to have people
that testify on gas please if anybody
comes in here and tells you that cs gas
is not torturing children
ask them to do one thing
tell them ask them this
ma'am or sir will you get in a car with
me and drive 35 miles down to quantico
on the marine base of quantico we'll put
a video camera in the car with you
take you down to that marine gas chamber
put on your gas mask let us pop a couple
gas grenades in that chamber then you
take your mask off and let's videotape
you for just five minutes in that
chamber without a gas mask see if any of
them will take that challenge they won't
because you'll choke to death in that
period of time with the wrong
concentration
i believe that using cs gas against
infants against old people with
respiratory problems there was there
were 60 70 year old men in there and
there were young children that's torture
and i can just see those kids barfing
vomiting screaming because you can't
possibly have a gas mask to fit a little
kid
they at best i think one of the reports
said that our survivors said that they
had taken to try to help them they had
taken a a wash cloth and put water on it
try to put it over their face so it
won't burn time has expired in
unfairness uh
just in case i might have shut you off
from trying to finish up mr conyers uh
if you could just take 30 seconds and
try to wrap up
i think that the point i was trying to
get to mr conyers is that when the
discussion is of keep the fire going
must have had to do with either
the
coleman lanyards which they were using
for lighting or for the butane they were
using for heating but not to starting a
fire because it doesn't
coincide with the start of the fire
no sir
thank you
okay the chair now recognizes mr schumer
from new york for five minutes and then
immediately after his five minutes we
will break for a vote and come back here
i think it's one vote correct
five minute vote is your apartment
okay we'll come back five minutes after
the vote
mr schumer thank you mr chairman and
first i want to say to both mr zimmerman
mr degaran i admire your abilities as
defense lawyers you are doing an
excellent job doing what defense lawyers
do which is to defend the people they
represent uh to the best of their
abilities
but i have real problems with some of
these with many of the statements just
one mr zimmerman we'll have experts
later talking about gas and
there is no record of cs gas which is
simply the mildest form of tear gas mr
guerin said not tear gas but cs gas
we're going to talk about gas later what
i want to talk about is not your
impressions
of other things from talking to other
people who shot first what the gas is
that's really not what's material here
what's material here is your involvement
in the negotiations that's something you
were first-hand involved in your
testimony on that is uh what would be
admitted in a court of law whereas the
other stuff would not
and
my point i know you stated mr zimmerman
that he was just about ready to come out
and some i think he used the term
washington faceless washington
bureaucrat blew the deal only because i
don't know who made that terrible yeah
you don't know if he's in washington or
houston or on the field either do you
what can i explain that
because i had the greatest yes or no
well you asked me what makes me feel
that i'm just trying to use my time here
then you're going to give me extra time
did you ask him a question yeah and i
want him to answer it my way why don't
you answer it i don't want to answer it
the truth
i'm not going to answer it your way or
any other way except the truth okay you
want the truth now you knew it was from
washington i i because i let me tell you
why because those special agents in
charge in waco are honorable men jeff
jamar went way out on the limb to let
the two of us go in there bob ricks was
straight with us all the time
sir jeff jamar says he made the decision
himself that no one in washington made
it do you doubt his word he will tell us
that i think i think that you doubt his
word yes or no i would doubt that you
would okay even though he was an
honorable courteous individual let me
just say
you two gentlemen also it is true came
in on the negotiations 30
you two gentlemen came in on the new
bells bells bells sure
you two gentlemen came in on the
negotiations approximately a month after
they had begun that's correct isn't that
correct you too mr degaran yes sir and
in that 30 days koresh had lied
repeatedly to the agents
on april 2nd he states that it's a fact
he's coming out if a tape is played the
tape is played on local waco tv on cbn
and he doesn't come out
on march 7th he says he won't be that
long
then on april 2nd he says he's going to
come out right after passover
doesn't come out
finally on april 15th
mr schneider says they're going to come
out after the seven seals but admits
that koresh lied about coming out on
march 2nd those are his words on the
tape that mr koresh his associate his
chief lieutenant or you don't like the
term chief lieutenant mr schneider who
is his one of his devoted followers and
acolytes says that mr koresh lied so
what we have here is lie after lie after
lie by mr koresh a man who we know has
violated federal laws who has abused
children and all of a sudden on april 15
we know you'd somehow know that he is
telling the truth
well i have real problems with that i
think most people would have real
problems with that because his pattern
was not to tell the truth and in fact
further he said well he will come out
not within five minutes but after he
finished doing his writing on the
seventh seals
and when asked uh mrs schneider forgot
her first name with a j judy judy
schneider when judy schneider was asked
on the tape how long it would take
to transcribe his
um
interpretation of the seventh seal she
said about a year then she later said to
to a little bit later she said well if i
was given a laptop computer it would be
somewhat shorter than that never said
how much shorter so it is certainly
clear
mr zimmerman that even if the fbi had
said yes
that it would take some time for him to
do his work on the seventh seals is that
on the seven seals isn't that correct it
wasn't going to come out in five minutes
or that day or the next day no he was
going to come out at we told him in two
days per seal that one was finished so
it'd be about 12 days mr jamar said
that's fine that's good 12 days yes okay
he agreed to that wait
okay well we'll ask mr jamar that
because i think jamar's interpretations
who you call an honorable person we
won't see him is he on the b panel or c
panel you know we're not going to see
him until later this evening but mr
jamar's interpretations are quite a
variance with yours
as to what happened and i would simply
say
to you
that
someone like mr paresh
who lies and lies and lies and has three
times promised to come out and not come
out and if you have to make the decision
whether to say okay well let's give them
another 12 or 15 days
so he can write his seven seals
and let us say
that
in hindsight
we knows what has happened but just let
us say that they gave those 12 or 15
days
and the compound was burnt
internally by mr koresh and many many
children were killed
we would be and you would be as a good
defense lawyer
excoriating excoriating the fbi
and everybody else for waiting so long
you would make the argument you'd make
it much better than i ever could mr
zimmerman you'd say he lied on a on
march 2nd he lied on march 7. he lied on
april 2nd he lied on april 15th and all
of a sudden
they wanted to believe him on april 15th
and give him two more weeks that doesn't
make any sense i'd just like mr
zimmerman to respond because i feel that
he's entitled to if that's okay that's
mr chairman thank you mr congressman
first of all when the lawyers got
involved
uh approximately on the at the very end
of march in my judgment there was never
a promise of a specific date and there
never was a broken promise by mr quresh
that needs to be clarified once
dictaguerian became his lawyer mr karesh
never
gave a false promise to do anything that
he didn't do second
you asked me to tell your observation
sir the dates you gave are wrong okay
all the dates like he never said on
april the second that he was coming out
at any particular time because mr
daguerreon and i were involved by april
the second so i know that's wrong now
that the there were some other promises
before that but you have to put it in
context until there was somebody he
trusted he didn't trust those people out
there but once mr guerin became involved
that's when it happened now
in response to your other situation
that's a hypothetical that that i would
have to have a uh a uh crystal ball
that's more clear than mine is
time has expired we now will take a
recess until five minutes after this
vote coming up
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
we'll return for more of day five of the
waco investigation hearings but first
some programming notes
sunday on book notes abc's john
hockenberry
as a correspondent for npr he traveled
to the middle east to cover the persian
gulf war
in the mid 80s he volunteered to be the
first journalist in space
this weekend he talks about the
challenges he faces closer to home a lot
of times in
new york
you have to wait for taxis i mean in the
rain for instance
you have to wait for five taxis before
someone will pick you up if you're in a
wheelchair and you're by yourself if
you're in a wheelchair with somebody
it'll stop if you're in a wheelchair by
yourself you know you have to kind of
take your chances if it's nice out
you'll do a little better
if there's a 40 mile an hour wind and
it's christmas eve believe me you don't
do very well at all and one cat passed
me by a second cab passed me by i
remember thinking oh come on
santa you know
it's time
it's time for a break here let's just
get me downtown again i'm freezing and
the third one passing me by and then
somebody comes and sees me if cabbie
comes and sees me and
and starts to pull over but then changes
lanes goes over into the left lane but
he's caught by the
light so he's stuck there in the
intersection with his turn signal on
turning left pretending like he hasn't
seen me
this is ridiculous so i roll over open
the door and say can you take a fair he
says yes
i get out i get in the back seat i fold
up my chair and i say please put the
chair in the back in the trunk and i did
i absolutely said please this first time
and he goes
no it's too cold
emmy award-winning journalist john
hockenberry and his book moving
violations war zones wheelchairs and
declarations of independence sunday
night on book notes at eight eastern and
pacific time
we now return to further coverage of
today's joint hearing looking at the
1993 raid on the branch davidian
compound in waco texas
so
the uh joint uh oversight hearings waco
will now come to order
chair uh recognizes mr schiff from new
mexico for five minutes can i wait a
moment to the witnesses are
are back
okay
okay i think we have the button get them
settled in
okay uh gentlemen
i i've been very very critical of the
presentation earlier in this hearing of
the victimization
of kerry jewell
because as serious as child rape is of
course
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms was conducting a firearms law
investigation in search
and
the issue of mr korish's depravity is
not what they were investigating or
going to serve a search warrant for
and i think that that testimony was put
into this hearing to take newspaper
headlines and other media attention away
from a lot of the testimony about the
law enforcement participation in the
raid
but
i don't mean to imply by that that mr
korish had no involvement in this whole
situation obviously he did
and in all of this discussion of the
negotiations i have this question
after after the the raid failed let's
pick it up from there and the siege
began and the negotiations are going
we know that we have four dead bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms agents and
we we believe we had six dead members of
the branch davidian sect
wasn't it time for the people inside to
come out and at that point make their
case in court
in other words
how would they have any justification
for not coming out and and allowing this
man to go to the courts when a number of
people have died
in the raid situation i'll go to whoever
wants wants to respond first mr de gea
legal legal justification for waiting no
there was no justification for it
my
plan
what i wanted to do
was to walk out with david korish and
have all the rest of the people come out
my whole reason for going in there
was to go get my client and take him to
court where i knew how to work
and what we tried to do jack and i
together
was to get those on the inside not just
david courice but all of them
to reconcile
their beliefs
with the law
they believe that the their beliefs
their their religion was paramount and
superior to the law and as you know it's
not
let me interrupt because my time is is
uh
limited here very quickly did the fbi
impede anyone from leaving who wanted to
leave no no
all right quickly gentlemen because
we're going to get into this another
testimony mr zimmerman you talked about
cs gas
the uh you do know the fbi will say that
of all the written reports on the use of
cs gas there is no established lasting
effects to anyone from the use of cs gas
that's what they're going to say that's
why i asked you sir get somebody that
says that say look will you drive down
to quantico with me let me video you in
a gas chamber for five minutes without a
gas mask and he says he will take him up
do it and and finally for my question mr
de guerin you were asked about the fire
and what started the fire
do you have enough information at this
point to have have an estimation of what
did cause the fire i think it was
probably
started accidentally by the lanterns
being
crushed or turned over they were they
were using lanterns
coleman lanterns with liquid fuel for
lighting or it started from a spark or
it started in some
accidental fashion that's what i believe
because not because i want to believe
that or because i have anybody to
represent i don't have anybody to
represent here i'm telling you what i
saw on the inside and what the people
told me
and the survivors told me that they did
not
start that fire
thank you again let me interrupt because
time is short thank you gentlemen
chairman i'd like to yield any time i
have remaining to mr chabot thank you
as i've said consistently during these
hearings i think
the real purpose of these hearings what
should be the purpose is to find out all
the facts let the chips fall where they
may
and try to avoid future loss of life
whether it be law enforcement officials
or whether it be civilians and you two
gentlemen have studied this case in
depth and and were inside
uh the compound when others were not and
really i think you have some insight
that that everybody else really lacks
i would like to ask both you gentlemen
you can both answer
what are the lessons to be learned from
waco what should the united states
government learn
so that we can avoid a tragedy like this
from ever happening again
provocative force excessive force
breeds excessive violence
the use of excessive force by law
officers serving a warrant
is doomed to tragedy
now what we saw on february the 28th
was the use of far more force than was
justified or necessary under the
circumstances what this committee needs
to do is go back
and examine the decision
to use the excessive force then that
carries right through to april the 19
because this atmosphere of macho we've
got to do something we've got to bring
this to an end resulted in
tanks and tear gas being used against
some if you want to put it this way
religious nuts that were holed up in a
compound
there had been no one injured no one
threatened no one hurt for 51 days and
the fbi is to be congratulated
for bringing that about
but the force that was used
on april the 19th
again was excessive and so the real
lessons to be learned and how to prevent
it i don't know is
stopping the use of excessive force
that's my breathe thank you mr zimmerman
sir i hope that in addition to what
victor guerin has just said that what we
can learn from this is that we need to
re-establish faith in federal law
enforcement at one time as a defense
lawyer i can tell you the fbi was viewed
as the elite of federal law enforcement
it was the texas rangers of the federal
law enforcement community if you will
that is not the case today and we've got
to reestablish that and the only way i
think we can do it and i'm not sure
whether this oversight committee can or
not but i hope you can at least go down
the road a bit you have to establish
leadership accountability that's what
the american public is concerned about
there's been no leadership
accountability in my frame of reference
the commander in a military sense has
responsibility and authority he can
delegate the authority but he never
delegates the responsibility something
goes wrong on his watch he's responsible
let me give you an example that pales in
comparison there's no loss of life but a
terrible thing happened in tailhook
right that was not any loss of life
there was some illegality and that
responsibility went all the way to the
secretary of the navy and he resigned
over that
there's been no personal leadership
accountability in the department of
justice at all and in the treasury
department the people who were found by
their own investigators to have lied and
committed crimes are still working for
you and me
thank you i see that amount of time mr
chairman
thank you
and i know i'm out of water but i would
like to know what crime
those treasury people have been
convicted of sir convicted of
mr murletti testified yesterday an
answer to a question from somebody on
the committee or subcommittee and i
don't know who whether or not federal
law was violated and he said yes there
were federal felonies when those agents
uh
uh provided false statements as to their
activities
i think
time has expired i'd like to recognize
mr lantos from california for five
minutes
we have had a few minutes ago an
absolutely mind-boggling exchange
between a member of this committee on
the other side and the two of you
which i would like to return to
because it reveals either a degree of
unbelievable ignorance of recent
american history
or sophistry of the worst type let me
tell you what i have in mind
we had
not too many years ago
a criminally insane charismatic leader
by the name of jim jones
who caused the death
of about 900 american citizens
children and women
with no fbi
atf justice department
tanks or gas being involved
now you were asked the two of you
by mr micah 10 minutes ago
whether there is any incident in
american history where american citizens
were so killed and you both claimed not
to know of any such episode
he didn't seem to know of any such
episode
well let me give a new
approach to the two theories that have
been used so far
we have heard throughout these hearings
that we are either dealing with a degree
of
bureaucratic incompetence and stupidity
of incredible proportions or worse yet
a conspiracy on the part of the federal
government to kill american citizens
i reject both of these notions
because i think what we have here
is a pattern
on the part of
an insanely criminal
charismatic leader in charge of a sect
who has apocalyptic visions
who teaches children to commit suicide
who puts guns into the mouth of children
who is responsible
for this nightmare which has unfolded on
our television sets
but for the two of you to sit there
and claim either ignorance of
or forgetfulness concerning
the jonestown tragedy
where
planned mass suicide
of american citizens unfolded
involving
many times the number of tragedies that
we had in this
unfortunate
incident
and to have a member of this committee
claim no knowledge of this
stretches stretches
credibility
you're like
not yet when i'm finished
what i am suggesting to you
and i am resisting the temptation to
comment on the cheap political shots
about political appointees of an
administration which had been in office
just a few weeks when all these things
unfolded
what i am telling you is
that the most plausible single
explanation
for this nightmare
namely
the apocalyptic vision
of a criminally insane charismatic cult
leader
who was hell-bent
on bringing about
this
infernal nightmare
in
flames and
the extermination
of the children
and the women and the other innocents
is not an explanation that should be
cast aside
no one knows
what koresh had in mind you don't and i
don't
but if we have any intelligence
we go back to the only other example in
american history not that far back in
history
the jonestown nightmare
of 900 americans
killing themselves
finishing their lives
in many cases promising lives
because of the evil and criminal
approach
of a charismatic cult leader
now you are saying uh mr garen
i saw in david koresh
not a person who was insane
a person who was deeply committed
and sincere
about his religious beliefs
well i am sorry for you if that's what
you see in him
i see in him
a criminally insane
charismatic cult leader
who caused the death of all these
innocents and i would like both of you
to comment on my observation let me let
me let mr garen have the last word let
me comment with regard to your two
theories
gross incompetence or a conspiracy let
me agree with you congressman lantos
that i have seen no credible evidence of
a conspiracy on the part of either the
atf
or the fbi or the treasury department of
the justice department i haven't seen no
credible evidence of a conspiracy to
harm americans i'm glad to hear i agree
with you i have never said that
dictagarion has never said that we've
had many have implied it not us not
in fact you know that we we requested to
be on a panel separate so that there
would our credibility would not be
placed against some people who have
conspiracy theories i disagree though i
think that it is an example of gross
incompetence and we've already been
through that we may just agree to
disagree now with regard to the question
about the jonestown matter
maybe
because i was up all night you weren't
here
when i the chairman began by announcing
that i had a granddaughter born this
morning
at 4 15 in the morning i didn't get much
sleep it was our first grandchild
maybe i wasn't too sharp i congratulate
you
maybe i wasn't as sharp as i should be
but i thought the question said are you
aware of any american law enforcement
action in the united states that had
this greater loss of life and if that
was the question which i think it was i
stand by my answer jonestown was not an
american law enforcement action it
wasn't a law enforcement action at all
and it wasn't in america
will you will you allow the other
witness to answer mr chairman sure
if it hadn't been david korish it would
have been somebody else
i think the
reason i'm here is to try to offer some
insight into how to prevent this from
happening
not to defend
david korish or his actions
and as i see it
this ended in tragedy because there was
a failure to understand
that not only david korish but his
followers had this apocalyptic vision
and the actions of the fbi in
increasing
the pressure and violence played right
into that
apocalyptic vision
that's what i'm saying about his beliefs
his belief systems whether you believe
he was crazy or a child molester or
anything else
his belief systems
were in place and very sincere
he might have been crazy
but
the point is
the failure to understand that and then
to work within that belief system to try
to use that belief system as i was doing
as as arnold and taber and jack were
doing
to try to say well the bible does say
you should come out
the bible does say that the apocalypse
is not now it's later and therefore come
on out go in jail like there's been a
lot of good writing in jail i said to
david and not justin jest i said there's
some of the greatest
writing in them in the world has been
done by someone who was in jail and had
all the time to write and so what i'm
saying mr lantos and
members of the committee is that we've
got to understand law enforcement has
got to understand what they're working
with and not just
demonize
and re and ridicule
in order to justify their actions
mr chairman thank you yes unanimous
consent request i'd just like to add
into the record the tapes the
transcripts of the tapes each time that
david koresh promised he'd come out and
didn't including the date of april 2nd
which mr zimmerman said didn't exist
without objection
state your objection
what
well what will this be will this be
identified as mr sumer's impression of
the promises that were made because we
have conflict
sir let me let me let me state my
reservation mr schumer and then you
certainly are not not shy about
responding uh if if it's going into the
record mr uh uh mr chairman as fact then
i would object to it if this is simply a
document that mr schumer wants to put in
that is identified as his interpretation
of promises were made then i have no
objection okay i don't i don't need that
tom i just want to respond which is very
simply these are the transcripts
transcribed of the tapes they tape the
negotiations where koresh promised to
come out it has none of my
personal imprint in any way on it other
than
perhaps the fingerprints uh when i've
handed over the document
and i doubt that those would appear in
the copies that were made anyway if if
it's just documents that are not
identified as reaching a conclusion then
i would have no objection without
objection so ordered
chief heinemann from north carolina has
five minutes
mr daguerreon i'd like to go over again
that april the 14th
that you said there was a document
it's attached to my statement it's the
last document in my statement it's a
letter a handwritten letter signed by
korich can you summarize that please
well
what it says is that
he's been given the task
and i suppose this was the word from god
that he said he was waiting on
and
look i'm i'm not
trying to make a passive judgment on
that
some people
truly believe they get the word of god
some people truly believe they speak to
god billy graham's one of them so it's
not so unusual
but he said that he'd received
now the message
that what he had to do
was to
write his interpretation of the seven
seals it's not a long book and a long
manuscript
but to dictate it
and then he would come out and go into
the criminal justice system
and
the the reason that that was such a
revelation such a change in what had
happened before was he was giving the
religious arguments for doing that why
was he doing this
he gave that to you you say you passed
that on to
the fbi yes
and for what purpose you mean what was
his purpose in doing that i think it was
because
he believed it and
he said
and all the rest of the people in
mount carmel at the time said they were
overjoyed that now this message
had been received
now
it was fine with me i i didn't really
appreciate the the
religious significance of it but tabor
and arnold please ask him about that
they did and can tell you how
significant it was within the belief
systems he had written two letters the a
couple of days before that leading up to
it he
that is courage
used the religious arguments in this
letter
for why he had now
seen
that the scriptures
told him to come out they they based
their life on what the scripture said
at some point in this transaction
between him giving you the letter and
you passing it on did the texas rangers
fit into this at all yes can you tell us
about that
um i know you mentioned it before but
i'd like to be a little more clear on
that i wanted uh the texas rangers to be
doing the investigation i wish i could
say i was responsible for that
and at one point there was some dispute
over whether the atf would be involved
in the investigation once the surrender
occurred
i talked to several people about that
and i made it known that i thought that
would be a stumbling block and i wanted
the rangers to be there
what eventually was agreed to was that
the arrangers would conduct the
investigation
there would be a ranger present at the
surrender
and when was that surrender supposed to
take place we didn't have an exact date
was it supposed to happen that day no
you did mention at some point that you
and karesh were going to come out and
and mr zimmerman was going to bring up
the tail end of that that's correct was
that did that have anything to do with
that letter coming forth and the
people's jubilation
well
if i understand the question
no there was not a direct relationship
with that but the the letter was
the turning point in now korish said i'm
coming out here's when i'm coming out
it's not an exact date but it's as soon
as i complete this manuscript he was
working on the manuscript we know that
because we got it
uh after the fire
and and it was a a real turning point in
what he said
i
i thought it's so important that i i
immediately gave a copy of it this is
attorney-client privilege stuff
immediately gave a copy of it to the
fbi and told them what i thought about
it and even talked to tabor and arnold
in the in the following days and
called jamar and told him how
significant i thought it was and that
tabor and arnold were saying it was
significant so
i thought
once we received this letter i could
quit worrying about when he's going to
come out and start worrying about the
trial and getting prepared for trial
now let me just make reference to
to um that photo you see on the wall
there relative to
the atf arriving at the scene
and you made mention of that
and
they appear to me and
and i think there's no question that
they're in the defensive position at
this point
they are they appear to be in a in a
position where there's fire exchanging
with being exchanged
yes right now that would
there's nobody near the door
so apparently something happened from
the time they left the tent
the the canvas over the the trucks
to the point where they took up a
defensive position
has that gone um without an opinion
during the trial
no well i can give you the two
conflicting ones the government's
position was is when the two agents came
up to serve the warrant and mr koresh
closed the door gunfire erupted from the
inside through that right-hand side of
the door to the extent that it bolted
out backwards
and one man was was hitting in the hand
or finger or something and then they
returned then the atf returned fire
so then it came out in trial at the the
gunfire emanated from inside the
building that's the only testimony there
was because the defendants in that trial
didn't testify and of course i was not
allowed no
uh to give any
uh testimony about what someone else
said because of the rule against hearsay
so
so uh
uh
the information i have imported to you
today
yeah there
that came from inside the building
through the wall through the through the
door not through the wall through the
door
gunfire came from inside that building
through the walls
and i think we
probably all of us and tens of millions
of people across this country
had seen that
had seen that probably on the 6 30 news
on february 28th when one of the atf
agents yes backed away from that window
that surmised the window in the upper
left-hand corner right came around to
the side of that
that window and we saw shots coming from
the inside out and i believe actually
been shot absolutely because we were in
that room and we saw both entry and exit
holes in that in that wall up there i'm
sorry i thought you earlier were talking
about the initial flurry
[Music]
the but
i can finish that answer
please
what when we interviewed people and and
walked through that area up there it was
clear what you see on the video
where they
break and rake he knocks the glass out
throws in a
grenade a concussion grenade and then
they come inside and then he started
shooting by his own testimony he sprayed
the area and he
he hit somebody back behind one of those
walls we talked to that person's name
his name was scott sonoby and he said i
returned the fire there was an exchange
in there and then other agents came in
there and started shooting and one fella
was wounded and in the back corner we
could see the blood stains and there was
an exchange clearly rounds were coming
from the inside out on that exchange and
we don't know who
hit the man still out on the roof it
could have been the agent who was
shooting back it could have been mr
sonoby we just don't know we'll probably
never know
clarification thank mike it was not that
window it's a different side of the
building not that window that picture
doesn't show it i stand for that thank
you
okay uh mrs collins from illinois for
five minutes thank you mr chairman i
yield to ms slaughter of new york
i thank the general in my time thank you
very much uh miss cons for yielding to
me uh mr degan would you remind me for
just a moment the date at which david
corres told you that he was relieved and
everybody was happy that they didn't
have to go through armageddon april 14th
um
on april 13th
i think we mentioned you that the
negotiator talked about reading by
candlelight and mr zimmerman said that
every room had the coleman lantern is
that that about correct about the same
time
and um
it appears here in conversation
your client mr schneider mr zimmerman
believed
that he could live in fire walk through
it and come out surviving
i think he was quoting there a biblical
text ma'am
that he believed this
i can't get inside someone's head to say
whether they really physically you know
literally believe that like some people
believe that the red sea parted his wife
judy schneider said that the book of
daniel reports that god saved shadrach
meshach and abednego
from the flames of the fiery furnace and
that they were in no way either of them
afraid of dying by that fire
i believe that's true that they were not
afraid to die for their religious
beliefs
and this was on about april 13th how
does that coincide with the fact that
they were so relieved they didn't have
to do it
we
at the last day of passover was the 13th
mr gary and i came up there and the fbi
hooked us up with a telephone
conversation and steve schneider said
that we had to call back after sundown
because it was the last day of their
high holy week and when we called him
that night mr koresh did not come to the
phone frankly it irritated both mr
guerin and me then that was when we
found out the next day was when he was
working on the first seal do you know
james trim are you familiar with that
name who ma'am james trim
that's a researcher from dallas fort
worth who had the endorsement of
theologian philip arnold who i believe
will testify here later today
that they had a plausible theory about
the start of the fire
and this was after the passover on the
morning of april 19th mr trump
postulates
courage ignited the fatal fire at mount
carmel is a means of closing the fifth
seal and ushering in the sixth so he
believed that this fire was necessary in
order to get into the sixth seal
um and that koresh had talked to the fbi
before
about a wall of fire did you and your
client discuss this we did not discuss
fire now
uh now mr zimmerman i think that uh oh
let's see they're talking about being
taken up by the flames of fire that this
is what they were going to do
um
there's nothing in any of this and i
have you notice we don't have any
problems and frankly i haven't seen
either one of your testimony i know one
was probably laying here this morning so
i have no clue and i'm sort of trying to
go by this as we go along but from
everything that i have there's no
indication from anybody else that's
covered this including fbi negotiators
that at any point mr corace said
this is wonderful
i'm going to finish my work here today
and we're not going to have to die well
that's not correct
if you read the letter that's uh
attached to i don't know
so it's the last maybe you could share
that with me that's right
it's the last
exhibit are you are you uh familiar with
the fact that mr corrice had said to the
fbi that they would again have this wall
of fire
which he and his believers
thought that they would survive
no no
and i don't think that that was meant
the way you are implying ma'am and i
know you're just reading from somebody
else's book because see the fbi knew
about that if those are tapes from the
negotiations we know that they didn't
really think that that was a very
realistic prospect because they made no
preparations for the fire on april 19.
through the fire you don't think that's
realistic that they would live through
the fire do i personally no man i don't
well let's talk about that man because
you had said a while ago that
that you courage always told truth isn't
that correct i didn't say corey show
it's told the truth what i was
contesting was an allegation that once
the lawyers was in were involved that mr
karesh had promised to come out and had
broken that promise my my testimony is
that once dick the guerin started
represent representing david crush and i
started representing steve schneider
there was never a date certain given
about them coming out and the closest it
came to a promise to actually come out
is in that letter that's attached to his
written statement
schumer at least was implying that the
tapes that the fbi had
i have a few things you know i have not
seen that april 2nd tape so i don't know
what what's on there i'll be honest with
you i i'm
i think you'll agree with me that that
mr koresh was a very charismatic man
yes he was absolutely in order to get 80
people to believe first that the men
believed that they had to give their
wives and their daughters to quresh that
takes a great leap of faith doesn't it
wouldn't you say would either one of you
want to do that no i would neither one
was mr korres i have to go on record
saying no ma'am
yeah you know i say that on the right i
have to you didn't give me a chance to
go home i got to
oh is that your wife that's my wife
that's my new ground would you like me
to develop this further
um
if i were in court i'd say let the
record reflect that yes well i'm not a
lawyer so what do i know
uh but i the the thing that really
astonishes me here is that both of you
are so certain that this man was telling
you the truth i i think you know i i'm
absolutely flummoxed by that as to why
well you think that corey she told
people that they could walk through fire
and survive
and they should give them all of their
worldly goods and they should hand over
their wives and daughters and that he
was going to take them somewhere frankly
i've never been able to understand this
whole thing after they burned up in the
fire what next
i mean i i don't know to what end they
wanted to burn up but that but never
mind let me say i'm baffled because i
know you guys are great lawyers because
jean green told me you are and you know
and i know that's true but tell me
she never asked a question yes i did
please do it no what makes you so
certain
in the face of everything else you've
ever heard about this man
he was telling the two of you
the truth well
i i can answer that
what he told me that i was able to
confirm
that was capable of being confirmed i
confirmed and it turned out to be true
what was that well there's several
things and and i can give you several
examples i'd love to hear when robert
rodriguez just one question
when robert rodriguez
testified
here it was the first time i'd heard
robert rodriguez describe the
conversation that he had with courage
and he said he never tried to do exactly
the same way except for that
right when i heard how does that chime
though he said i will never be taken
again this is his truthful man they've
had me once they'll never take me again
and the two of you believe you talked
him into being taken
what's the question
that is that that's really what i'm
saying you believe that after you
negotiated with him he was willing to
give up
uh this thing that he had said to his
followers and in the presence of robert
rodriguez i will never be taken again
and you would talk him into being taken
again
first
i'm a little doubtful that he said it
that way to robert rodriguez everything
else
that robert said
everything
jived with exactly what corey said and i
talked to a number of people that were
in the room steve schneider was one of
them judy snyder was another one of them
it was in the room when that
conversation with david between david
korish and robert rodriguez took place
they all described it the same way as
robert rodriguez did except for that
statement i'll never be taken again
there were other statements that he
said to me that i found to be true the
one about henry mcmahon he told me
exactly about the statement with henry
mcmahon who testified that
he
had
given the phone
or tried to give the phone to davey
aguilera
for courage to say come on out and look
at the guns if you want to
it was described the same way
there were many other if you want me to
go into them i i will
am i supposed to answer that too sir
thank you very much uh if you can do it
in a fairly short period of time i don't
want to repeat anything because of the
shortness of the time but
you asked why i believed him given all
these
walk through fire and survived fire let
me
handle this very delicately but
truthfully it's the only way i know to
do it i'm of the jewish faith
there are a lot of tenets of religion in
the in other christian
sects sex other than
the branch davidians that frankly i find
hard sometimes
that other people believe and literally
believe
uh i mean
believed to be literally true
yet when those people who believe that
tell me something i still believe them
because
they are i find them to be truthful
people in other ways and i don't
i don't assess credibility on their
religious beliefs everybody's religious
belief is separately
okay
nonetheless it seems to me you you'd
have to say that that he had not told
your client's truth i think your time is
well expired mr blute
five minutes
now all right
thank you very much mr chairman i thank
the witnesses i think your testimony is
very important because of your
first-hand interaction with korres and
davidians during the siege period
i think one of the more
tragic parts of this whole episode were
the missed opportunities along the way
to avoid this tragedy we've already
heard testimony for example that the atf
were offered a chance to buy koresh
himself on the phone to come out and
inspect the weapons
they chose not to they said it was too
early in the investigation earlier mr
thibodeau a davidian testified that he
felt that koresh had such a
reasonable relationship with a local
sheriff that perhaps if the local
sheriff came out and brought the warrant
we might have had a different type of
situation
we also know that after the raid when
the siege started the initial negotiator
was getting through to koresh and they
had a kind of relationship
intellectually that allowed numerous
people to be released during that period
and that for some unknown reason and i
hope to find that out later with the fbi
that negotiator was taken off summarily
and replaced with someone else who did
not have that
relationship and no one else was ever
released
again
so i think there are a lot of missed
opportunities you have a unique
perspective in that you
had some negotiations with koresh and
with the davidians at this time i wonder
if you could just briefly discuss what
you think were the important uh missed
opportunities during that period
well
um
i i think that
you have to look at the tactics of the
fbi as creating missed opportunities
in the first place each time someone
would come out
i dispute the
the term release i i think the people
came out when they wanted to come out no
one was being held against their will
during the 51-day standoff that's all i
know about
each time someone came out the treatment
that they got
was calculated to discourage anyone else
coming out when the children were
released
or came out
they were put into custody of
the child protective services even when
they came out with their parents they
were separated from their parents
they were the their religious and
dietary
wishes were not responded to when adults
came out
every one of them went to jail and
were not allowed to make bond for
instance the first two ladies that came
out one of them was 77 years old and
practically brought blind
she was charged with a false affidavit
with having participated in the shooting
that occurred on february the 28th an
agent actually testified that she held a
gun and pointed it she's
she just couldn't have done it when the
those on the inside who were seeing the
news report saw
the treatment that
people were getting when they went
outside well it discouraged them from
going outside so there was this this
tension going on between
the the tactical men who were
uh trying to force a conclusion and
treating those who were released
in ways not to encourage release
as opposed to the negotiators who were
trying to establish trust and rapport
you know anything about this initial
negotiator on the phone that was
replaced
yes could you comment on that uh well
what i know
is what
partially i was told by david
and that is that initially there was a
man named james cavanaugh with the atf
who david said he
had a a relationship with
i don't know how you establish a
relationship over the phone but he said
that he trusted the man and that they
were able to talk and they talked kind
of the same language i've seen the tapes
of that and and kavanagh uses some
biblical terms and he uses some i love
you brother that sort of thing it just
you gotta question that coming from an
atf agent who's just seen four of his
friends killed and others wounded and
but
that beyond
beyond that
there was a trust that was established
there
and he was taken off i think that was
because the fbi came in and
and
they should have pushed the atf out of
the way
but i think there was also some trust
established with the fbi negotiators i
talked to several of them and they were
good
uh they're behavioral scientists
and they're they're
engaging men to talk to they're nice
they're not the kind of beat on your
chest
rambo types let me ask mr zimmerman what
you think were the greatest missed
opportunities during this period
i think you're going to talk to clint
vanzanthi he was the negotiator that i
had the most contact with and i thought
he had his head on straight in other
words when
when the
branch davidians
did something that we wanted all of us
want them to do like when somebody came
out or something like that instead of
rewarding that make making things better
so it would encourage that kind of
conduct they would do things like play
sound tapes of rabbits being slaughtered
or
nancy sinatra singing
songs and and then they would bring out
lights
at night and not not that nancy sinatra
always was that bad but the ones that
she had kept the point was this they
were trying to have sleep disturbance
and they were trying to take somebody
that they viewed to be unstable to start
with
and then they were trying to drive him
crazy and then they get mad because he
does something that they think is
irrational i mean that's i think was the
mistake made there they should have
backed the lights away stopped taking
stop the noise when they gave dick the
letter gave us the letter they should
have withdrawn all of that so could show
them hey this is what we want to do
thank you mr chairman
expired we're going to go two on our
side by previous agreement on the other
side mr bryant you have five minutes
thank you uh gentlemen if you could i
have a number of questions and if you
could keep your answers relatively short
i'd appreciate it did both of you go
into the compound at various times yes
sir yes where either of you searched as
you went in by the davidians by the
davidians
by the fbi the davidians treated us as
guests
so they didn't they weren't suspicious
of you enough to search you for weapons
or anything like that the brent the
davidians
no sure and you were searched
before you went in by the fbi and as i
came out and as you came out
now uh in reading some of the
correspondence mr gary i noticed that
you attempted to establish a
relationship with the local united
states attorney's office
in terms of negotiation and having been
involved in that type of experience
myself i know that oftentimes a defense
attorney will be more likely to deal
with the other attorneys the u.s
attorney in this case or assistance than
than you actually did with the law
enforcement
time either one of you did you have a
relationship were you asked to deal with
u.s attorneys or even more was a
specific special us attorney sent down
from washington no no in fact i couldn't
get the phone calls returned the fbi was
far more responsive to me than u.s
attorney's office i tried to serve
just take a courtesy copy of the rid of
habeas corpus up to the u.s attorney's
office and they wouldn't even let me
poke it through the glass window
also so we didn't know at the time
initially whether this could be a
federal prosecution or state prosecution
because texas law of capital murder
carries a death penalty and at that time
i don't believe
uh if the decision had been made whether
or not to proceed with the state
prosecution or federal prosecution at
the initial stages did you ever see a
again a a united states attorney from
d.c a doj attorney down at waco during
this time no i did not okay let me move
on to another question if i could
mr zimmerman you testified early today
that you felt that there were the
details of a voluntary surrender had
been worked out and in fact you detailed
specifically how that would occur let me
ask you to detail for the record as best
you can
who you made that deal with and when
that deal was made give me names of
people left the line that you negotiated
this deal with because i want to ask
these people what they saw
i i don't know if i would call it a deal
the the parameters were
get given to us by the fbi and i i'm
dick you can correct me i i think it was
jeff jamar it might have been uh what it
was just usually jeff jamar and bob
ricks were together every time they were
always there and one said something that
might be another i think it was jeff
jamar and uh you know they made a lot of
sense there wasn't a whole lot of
fine-tuning needed like i said the only
thing that we that i can remember asking
them to change was to let the little
children come out with their mothers and
they didn't have a problem with that so
the fbi gave you the the details you've
talked about you would uh mr gary would
come out first with mr kresh uh they
would put on plastic handcuffs and go
through metal detectors and mr zimmerman
you would come out last this is a
detailed plan the fbi had given you
it's all oral it was all oral in fact
between the date of april first when we
went in together for the first time on
april 4th
i put i started to write that out
so that we could get it typed up and get
it writing
which never never did occur because
i don't know i think it sort of got put
to the side we were more concerned with
getting them out
because they had already agreed to those
terms both both sides had agreed to
those terms the fbi and the branch
davidians i'll ask those people some
more about that when they testify mr
zimmerman you asked a question that
peaked my interest and you really didn't
get the chance to answer
or you didn't get a chance to answer the
question about you were alluding to the
fact that the fbi
did not you felt like they did not
anticipate that a fire would occur
because they had made no preparations to
fight fire to have right i was trying to
answer uh mr slaughter's question and i
was
saying that the
way i interpreted that transaction was
is that
the references to fire that steve
and the others they were talking to him
on the telephone was was
quoting biblical scriptures
and and clearly not some threat to have
a fire
and i think one indicia of that is or
one uh evidentiary thing you can look at
is that the fbi certainly didn't take it
seriously uh if they did would they have
well
and my judgment they didn't because if
they thought that there was going to be
a fire on april the 19th as a result of
them smashing the building with tanks
and inserting tier what they call tear
gas which i call cs gas not tear gas
they wouldn't have done it geez we'd
hoped they wouldn't have done it i mean
the innocent kids in there would get
burned up let me ask you another line of
questions real quickly uh and i have to
hold this back where i can read uh peter
smerrick are you familiar with him as
the fbi one of the psychological people
did you have any either one of you have
any dealings with mr smerrick i
understand he
he gave some opinions three or four
opinions to
basically counsel like you're doing to
hold back and wait but that the fifth
opinion he gave
was that uh let's go in and have the
confrontation all i know is
that i have read what he
had allegedly counseled and that he was
pressured to change that
and then he left the area i never met
him
just real quickly uh
well i'll tell you what i'll i'll be
generous and yield back the balance all
the all of my time there
okay mr uh
mr
mr
take take the balance of your time thank
you
very quickly
mr mr zimmerman
in response to my question about what
are the lessons of waco that we should
learn earlier
you mentioned leadership accountability
would you please expound upon what you
meant by that
i am you know i was trained and raised
on the theory that
as a military commander i'm responsible
for everything that happens in my unit
and then when i get assigned a mission
if i accomplish the mission the credit
goes to the troops but if i fail in the
mission it's my responsibility because
i'm supposed to make sure everybody's
trained and that we accomplish the
mission
i i think that unless
the oversight process that you're going
through here results in some leadership
changes we're going to have people still
in the position
that they were in before this waco
fiasco making the same kind of bad
judgment calls in other words once we
have a commander who has demonstrated
that he cannot react under stress and
and respond appropriately we relieve him
of command and we put somebody else in
there that can we owe it to our troops
and and i i have the same feeling for
those young atf agents and if you read
my written opening statement i i don't
know that i would concur with calling
them heroes in the sense that they were
just carrying out orders they probably
don't think they're heroes but i'll take
rodriguez in a minute as a troop he'll
do what he's supposed to do and and
he is entitled to and people like him
are entitled to leaders that plan better
and when those plans go awry like they
did they need to be relieved of their
command and not just put somewhere else
and kept on the payroll the justice
department didn't even do as much as the
treasury department did there's been no
accountability i tried to use an example
from the military let me tell you one of
the irons of this case
on april the 19th 1993 the day of this
fire
the united states court of military
appeals a civilian court that's the
highest court in military justice system
affirmed the conviction
of a marine officer for their election
of duty because
he left a training exercise and left one
of his men in the desert and that man
expired he died
and that man was charged with their
election of duty for the loss of one
life through a pure mistake but he was
responsible
and on that same day
80 people
died in waco texas because
improper decisions bad judgment was made
no conspiracy no intentional killing but
incompetence and there has not been even
a disciplinary administrative
disciplinary action taken by anybody in
the justice department and that's wrong
gentleman's time is inspired
mrs thurman for five minutes
mr zimmerman let me ask you a question
have you ever been involved with the
federal employees negotiations at all
ever
federal employees negotiation because
you're talking an awful lot about what
happened with atf or what you would have
done in firing those or getting rid of
some of those people so have you been
involved in any of the personnel
federal employee acts at all you mean as
a civilian yes no ma'am okay well let me
let me just it's harder than what i said
i know and it is and and i think you
ought to run for congress because you
use it
but let me just suggest to you that mr
mcgah did in fact and and one of the
reasons that he was very concerned
basically very similar to what you're
saying he felt they were they were not
right either but when they did put them
back into office that they put them back
into a non-supervisor he couldn't wear
their guns couldn't do anything because
they were concerned that if in fact
they were put back on through trial that
they would be able to be reinstated back
at the level that they were now that and
i and i am not an attorney nor i'm a
federal employee negotiator so i'm just
giving you the example of what they said
i don't disagree with you but i will say
mr hartnett is gone um has resigned and
cereben and koznoski were the two that
had sued and filed suit so and we don't
know what happened there okay so i i so
i think we need to be very careful that
that they haven't tried to take
disciplinary action okay one of your one
of your fellow committee members though
asked is there any legislation action
that you can take
jeez if that's the law ladies and
gentlemen change the law no question
let me
um mr garren you actually were mr
koresha's attorney correct
how many total hours did you spend with
him do you think in the period of time
that you represented him about 32 hours
about 32 hours
okay based on those hours you've come to
some conclusions that that he would have
come out um after he completed the seven
seals is that correct no ma'am
no it's based on a lot more than that 32
hours okay that's just exactly what it
was based on then oh sure it was based
on the
month
approximately a month or so that i spent
as his attorney
and
trying to learn all the issues and the
facts consulting with the religious
experts talking to the fbi going to the
scene seeing all the things i did not
just the 32 hours that i spent in some
kind of direction did you also speak to
any other members of the davidians who
had since left yes i did could you tell
me who they were rita riddle for one i
spoke to her during the standoff
not directly to catherine schroeder to
her lawyer
to brad branch who was
who had uh come out early
to livingston fagan
uh who was probably the most
knowledgeable about the religion about
mark throw or
miss buns or any of those that had been
interviewed at all who had suggested
just one of the things that has
concerned me in in listening to some of
this
is that we've heard
different testimony over the last
several days
that the consensus among the
psychiatrists on the scene experts from
the fbi whom you talked with as well
that quresh potentially was suicidal
joyce sparks who spent more time i think
about two and a half months i mean
talking to him
back and forth on his religious beliefs
testified that it would have been
contradictory to his teachings to
surrender uh you know miss jewell who
lived most of her life uh testified and
and said the details would change what
you said earlier in your testimony that
he kept you know coming back with other
excuses or reasons why but she said in
her testimony that the details would
change as david received more messages
from god but there was never a time when
he didn't expect to be killed by the
feds you need to know that the same
thing that mrs bunz had said
she was she was
not happy with uh obviously with mr
koresh but she basically said uh in the
articles that we have the sinful messiah
that he would use the law when it backs
up something he wanted to say but when
it didn't he'd just explain it away
um
she went on to say um mrs jewell miss
jewel we didn't expect to be killed by
the feds who david said were babylon or
that we would be expected based on this
information okay and based on all of
this testimony that we've had
a reasonable conclusion for the
negotiators was that koresh would never
come out
i'm based on what you've said today what
i've heard in the past i'm having a hard
time reconciling reconciling your
suggestions and what i've heard over on
the other side i mean could we agree
maybe that there is a possibility here
that what you believe is one thing what
other beliefs are out there too i mean
that maybe mr karesh
did have and had other ways of believing
than what we're seeing here today sure
okay
i mean i think that's important um the
set one of the other things i need to
bring up here is that you all had
mentioned paul gray
and i guess we had this thing up here it
um it is my understanding just so you'll
know maybe you all can clarify this but
this is what we've been told that he
actually never worked for atf that he
actually worked for
um
the city of houston as an arson
investigator and even during the time
that he was the arson investigator he
worked for the houston fire department
but he may have his phone number may
have been there but never was he paid by
does that say special agent on there yes
it does it does say that though he was
paid my understanding was he still was
on the houston
fire department payroll he was assigned
to the to an atf task force to a task
force correct but his office was in the
atf he carried that this car he was
there for the purpose of the houston
fire department to carry out the arson
investigation because he had had 25
years in this area is that correct
i don't know about that i know for eight
years he gave out this card saying he's
an atf agent we're trying to get
somebody impartial we could have gone to
miami or philadelphia or los angeles but
if you but not that but mr garren could
i respond to that briefly
i know a lot of people in the
houston fire department arson division
i've got some friends there
and i learned more about it as time went
on just through my friends there's at
least 10
other very qualified
arson experts at the houston fire
department that could have that did not
have that connection to the atf and why
why houston
even then there are arson investigators
all around the country that don't have
the ties what i'm saying is that doesn't
pass a smell test i don't know
about mr gray's motives but what i do is
about the appearance and we'll be
hearing from them so that we can clarify
this thank you thank you
uh chair now wishes to recognize mr barr
for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to uh direct
the attention of both mr zimmerman and
uh mr daguerreon to
uh three documents i'm not sure whether
whether you all have these if not mr
bush if you could distribute these
these relate gentlemen to
a discussion that has come up virtually
every day because it concerns at best a
spin control that began in the immediate
aftermath of the
february 28th rate and continues even
today with as as reflected in some of
the complaints by some of my colleagues
here concerning statements by the white
house
and our efforts to to get the facts out
in in these hearings
the first one and i'm going to uh go
down here uh and draw your attention to
the charts which uh have some blow-ups
of these uh
documents and the relative languages
to look at all is very quickly and then
ask you uh in your opinion and both of
you have i think
is um in the first one we have there
which is dated march 1 1993
and it indicates that immediately upon
initiating the uh the shooting review by
etf the stories that did not matter by
the agents and they were instructions
from mr johnston the assistant united
states attorney
at least initially
of the uh the investigation from the
prosecution standpoint uh directed that
the uh that the interview stopped uh
because they may want to create heaven
forbid brave material that might be a
sculpture party we certainly don't want
to do that
and then when notified that there was an
interview that had before that this
documentation johnson johnson authorized
it
but no notes were in the creation
the second document which is also
blown up here
uh concerns the the second one the
relevant language here uh indicates very
clearly that the treasury department was
reflecting doj department of justice's
request
that no interviews or discussions with
any of the participants who may be
potential witnesses uh be conducted here
again the furious heaven submits
information that might be mitigating or
exalted
a prosecution foreign to be turned over
to the defense and pursuing the
constitutional uh needings of uh to
process the protection and the third
document here
this continues on the second one there
the third one is some handwritten notes
we have not yet been able to determine
who we belong
uh indicates that mr ray young who i
think you're both familiar with who was
the assistant u.s attorney that
eventually took over the prosecution of
the action case does not want
these individuals reinterviewed because
they do not want to uh
produce any more exculpatory statements
it is my impression as a former united
states attorney some members of this
panel were alerted to this panel
indicated
that this is not standard department
understanding operating procedures uh
other members on the other side that is
this standard operating procedure that
immediately upon initiating a suiting
review designed as we've elicited from
mr johnston himself designed to search
for the truth and uncover evidence to
determine whether or not something went
wrong
they feel that it is standard operating
procedure for the department of justice
to come in and shut that investigation
down
in your experiences uh mr zimmerman and
mr guerin does this compared either with
the search for the truth or with
standard department of justice
procedures no sir no
uh any uh would you care to expand on
that one and let me also tell you uh by
way of uh background on that particular
question your colleague mr tim evans who
is here uh the other day he went over
the tumbling because he had been sitting
in the audience on wednesday and
thursday when we initially discussed
these documents
and on his own
uh had he grown up because he was so
flabbergasted to hear testimony
that or or efforts to
put into the record that these reflect
standard department of justice
procedures to close down a search for
the truth uh that he uh he stated and we
went into some detail on friday that
this was certainly not his impression
yet then again we came back yesterday mr
uh mr noble uh ron noble uh who's a very
forceful individual some would say
intimidating individual uh said this is
absolutely a standard procedure and he
could state that from his background
being with not only the department of
justice the department of treasury and
so on and so forth
but
there certainly are
times are there not when it's important
for a prosecutor to step in and make
sure for example that public statements
are not made that might impinge or
infringe or prejudice a an investigation
or prosecution is that correct i see a
distinction between
a prosecutor asking the investigators
not to make public statements
and
telling an investigator not to do
something that might develop evidence
that could be
favorable to the defense
if
the first thing is not wrong that is
telling an investigator not to talk to
the press
the second thing is clearly wrong if an
investigation is impeded
by a prosecutor telling an investigator
don't go interview somebody or don't
take notes if you do i asked this
because the light just went on so you
can reflect this in your continuing
answer
with this reflection in your mind these
documents
an effort to impede an investigation or
possible obstruction of justice
well it could be and i'm
i'm qualifying my answer because
it's it's shocking to see this in the
first place as a defense lawyer
sometimes we suspect that there's stuff
like that going on
but there is an absolute duty that a
prosecutor has to turn over to the
defense
any evidence that is arguably favorable
to the defendant it's just a matter of
fair play
because the investigators that
investigate a case usually are on the
prosecution side and they develop most
of the evidence
but when you tell
when a prosecutor tells an investigator
don't develop evidence or don't take
notes if you do because it might be
helpful to the defense
that ain't right
gentleman's time is expired
i'll be quick mr chairman two quick
observations one
i've never seen anything like this in
writing i'm shocked
that they put it in writing right and
left a trail
second i note if this always seems to be
on the receiving end of somebody else's
instructions
in other words this seems to be
each of these three documents seems to
be recording what the what the
department of justice wants the treasury
or the atf to do
as opposed to initiating itself
so if i were the defense lawyer in this
situation i would ask for a hearing and
i'd get people in under oath and find
out who was it that said this who gave
you these directions what did they tell
you to do
because these all look like they are
recording what instructions somebody
gave from johnson
from yon
and from the department of justice these
aren't department of justice documents
these are somebody else's documents is
the point i'm getting at
so we'd want to make sure that that's
what was really said
and it sure looks like what they said
i mean i don't know why somebody would
not record this accurately but
it doesn't pass a smell test either
thank you mrs lofkin from california
you're recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman i am
i appreciate being here now the science
committee also had the markup of the
nasa authorization this morning so as
with some members i have been running
back and forth
at this time i would like to yield four
of my five minutes to
mr schumer and the remaining minute to
miss jackson lee
okay sure thank you i want to thank the
gentlelady from california i just found
it a little ironic mr zimmerman you
complained that they uh had gotten
someone who wasn't part who was partial
because he was part of the atf and here
we have two very fine admittedly defense
lawyers who job is not to be partial
taking our whole six hours here and uh
i find that a little bit ironic
i would first like to ask you mr
zimmerman you mentioned that mr
schneider was a peaceful man
and the whole impression that both you
and mr degaran are giving is that david
koresh
was a rational reasonable person mr
degaran said well let's assume he had
kooky religious views
but i think from everything we've heard
mr korish was not simply somebody with
different religious views
would you admit that mr koresh was a
criminal
mr zimmerman
you can answer that yes or no
i don't think it's been proved but i
think there's evidence of that
how about you that's a good defense
lawyer answer mr zimmerman how about you
mr the guarantee i'd agree with that i
think that if if true what's been said
about him he was
um
guilty of a lot of crimes and do you
consider somebody who is part of a group
that stockpiles 48 illegal weapons
hundreds of hand grenades peaceful
no i certainly don't i don't think steve
schneider was involved in that i see but
you wouldn't consider mr koresh peaceful
that's the first time i've heard there's
been stockpiles of hundreds of well
let's just say he had 48 illegal weapons
and some
illegal hand grenades would you consider
that peaceful
i think it's a violation of laws
but you didn't answer my question you
made the comment you brought the word up
peaceful that mr schneider who's one of
his chief people i don't want to use
lieutenant because you didn't like that
word what would you like me what word
would you like me to use
he described mr keresh as a teacher of
teachers and he was one of his students
his pupils right uh one of his main
pupils as peaceful i'm asking you about
mr koresh on his on the and we won't
even call it a compound on mount carmel
where they had
48 illegal machine guns and at least a
quantity of illegal hand grenades would
you consider mr koresh peaceful
yes or no
the way you say that probably no no what
do you mean the way i say it well
because i'd like to ask you this mr
zimmerman it's my time do you dispute
those facts
do you say it's not been proven that
there were 48 illegal machine guns and a
bunch of illegal hand grenades on his
compound i believe there were 48 illegal
automatic weapons on april the 19th i
don't know that that's the case on
february 28th sir right but we're
talking about april 19th right april
okay no question okay and didn't you you
know about the trial didn't many or at
least several branch davidians
testify that there were these weapons
there and that on the morning of
february 28 there was preparation to
give those weapons out and to shoot
let's strike and to shoot there were
those weapons there and there was all
sorts of preparation the names of the
people who testified as i believe
one was schroeder i don't have my notes
here in front of me
isn't that correct
so i believe there was testimony that
weapons were there and that they were
distributed i don't request any
testimony about anything but illegal
weapons so i see but there were weapons
there how about hand grenades was there
testimony about that
right or would they just i don't know i
don't recall that do you recall mr
degaran no i don't know even though you
know every other detail about the trial
that's not fair mr schumer well let me
ask you you don't recall that do you
believe so in other words you have no
you doubt that there were 48 illegal
weapons i never said i knew all the
details of the trial
i'm asking
sir what is your question my question is
do you doubt do you have doubts that mr
koresh had on his compound
illegal weapons
and illegal hand grenades do you have
any doubts about that no he told me he
had illegal weapons you have to not tell
me that he had hand grenades there i see
and i saw no hand grenades i did see
some grenades that the atf had thrown in
and i brought one out what do you mean
thrown in the atf threw in grenades in
their dynamic
they were flashbacks have you ever seen
what a flashbang can do to somebody it
can tear your arm off okay sir they were
not grenades would you say
you believe they were great they were
grenades i brought one out to the fbi
and turned it over to him right okay mr
daguerre and i think that would hamper
your credibility because you're the
first person who would say that those
were grenades let me ask you uh
this man
do you have any i'd like to ask the
question simply because i have five
minutes today i'm the lawyer you said
something about my credibility today
okay let me ask you this do you have any
doubts
that david koresh had illegal sexual
relationships with some of the people at
the commonwealth no you don't know
you have no knowledge of that i didn't
say i had no knowledge i i haven't i
don't know and i'm not your testimony
do you doubt the testimony of kerry
jewell who was here did you hear about
that yes i do yes you doubt that yes you
doubt that yes sir
okay do you know why
yeah you can tell me why
that that we didn't learn of that the
first time when that she testified for
this hearing she she's made uh that that
kind of claim has been made for some
time her own mother didn't believe that
her own grandmother didn't believe that
right
uh there's been uh doubts about
prior
contradictory statements that she's made
in the past now it may be a hundred
percent true it may be my time because
my time is up in my judgment
in many ways these witnesses are trying
to simply deny things that just about
everybody else accepts as fact about
david corres and i'd like to respond
your time has expired yeah respond to
that uh you can respond relative to the
personal comment uh yes briefly
regarding your comment about my
credibility mr schumer
when i went into the compound
i was searched
and when i came back out i brought to
the fbi agents and showed them
a spent grenade
that's what sometimes euphemistically
called
a flashbang it's a grenade it has an
explosive charge in it it's very
dangerous it can blow your hand off it
can blow your face off it can kill
i would have brought out some of the
unexpended
grenades that the atf threw in
but i was worried about bringing out a
live grenade so i left them there there
were a number of grenades
wait a second that is not fair
okay and so is to my credibility about
that mr schumer ask jeff jamar or byron
sage about the grenade
they will say that they were flash packs
not grenades
mr shattuck for five minutes
i yielded a minute of my
five two minutes your time your time was
expired you had the full five minutes
it was one four minutes and one minute
mr schumer took all of it plus a little
bit
thank you mr chairman i appreciate this
opportunity to question the witnesses
let me say just as an introductory
comment that
much has been made here of the issue of
whether or not these hearings are
intended to criticize law enforcement or
to attack law enforcement indeed the
white house says we are trashing law
enforcement undermining the morale of
law enforcement officers and and and is
very very critical of these hearings let
me tell you i spent eight years in law
enforcement as i've said before my
father was a deputy sheriff i do not
know a law enforcement officer who
believes that when there is a legitimate
inquiry into mistakes or in the
wrongdoing that that is trashing law
enforcement having said that let me say
that while
one of my colleagues on the my on the
opposite side might say that you are our
witnesses
i
uh begged you quite strongly with you on
a couple of points
i did i think the most telling point on
the issue of who shot first and i think
that is an unfortunate issue that's come
up in these hearings was
mr zimmerman's remark that that question
is irrelevant as i heard mr de guerin
remark he said there were holes going
down and holes coming in the door
unless you have a time clock and a
photograph every minute
which direction the holes come from
cannot possibly tell you in my mind who
shot first no you're right beyond that
the notion that there are in fact holes
coming down shots from the helicopters i
will tell you if i've been in the
helicopter and i don't know what went on
but if i'd been a nail helicopter and a
firefighter started out on my ground and
i was an atf agent i'd have started
firing um because my guys are under fire
by gosh they're coming under fire
having said that the third point i want
to make mr zimmerman you said there was
no ambush because if they had wanted to
kill them in the trailers they could
have well i was shocked to see the
trailers are just canvas covered not
metal and it is clear to me that if
koresh had wanted to just blow them away
and had known that they were the agents
he could have animated them but then you
went on to say that it was your theory
that it was an accidental discharge by
an agent coming out of the trailer
i'll tell you the agents i've known in
my life are trained not to have
accidental discharges and it is just as
plausible a theory in my mind that it
was an accidental discharge by a nervous
davidian who was not as well trained to
use that firearm
the reason i say that sir is that that
was information that was given to us by
by someone in the press who had a
confidential source within the atf who
indicated that someone said that as he
was coming out of the back of that he
tripped his weapon wasn't unsafe and it
discharged and and if you look
supposedly if you looked at trajectory
the round went into the front of the of
the pickup trucks
engine compartment and it was coming
horizontal and there were no dividings
horizontal and the only people in front
was the other agents i have no
verification of that well with that
additional information that helps also
with regard to the shots down uh mr
uh
de guerin de garan you indicated that
the roof was the highest point in the
area there's been discussion of a tower
was there not also a tower the same same
thing the
it was called the tower or the
observation tower it's a fourth floor
it's not shown in this picture but in in
the diagrams that i've brought it is
shown it was the fourth floor actually
it was a bedroom of david korish and it
had almost a flat roof
i want to go into one other document
mr barr went over two documents with you
which were
have been brought into these hearings
the essence of which is instructions
from the justice department to atf
agents to stop their shooting review
because it was creating brady review
material the department of justice upon
hearing that evidence come into this
hearing issued a press release and i
have this press release here we're
putting it up there and you have copies
of it that press release issued within
minutes of the testimony coming into
this hearing says uh that during the
past two days the congressional hearings
on the tragedy at waco a long standing
just department practice has been madly
this has been badly mischaracterized
is in fact it a long-standing justice
department practice to your knowledge or
have you ever heard of it that anytime
brady material is being created you
instruct people to stop asking questions
no sir not at all would that be an
outrage
well it is outrageous that that there
was an instruction to stop because you
might create brady material now this is
a little bit different this tries to say
that it's such standard procedure that
it's prosecution 101. well i've never
been in the justice department i've only
been a state prosecutor and i don't know
of any such requirement i can understand
that there might be
an effort to stop a congressional
investigation that's going on at the
same time as a criminal investigation
but two different criminal agencies
investigating at the same time
let them at it let them have it
do it develop the facts in any way you
can one more quick point in the second
paragraph it says uh something about the
often request the federal government to
temporarily refrain from pursuing an
investigation there's nothing in these
documents that suggest the request was
done just to temporarily refrain but
rather to refrain because they were
developing conflicting information isn't
that right that's right i read those
memos i'm running out of time i'd like
you at the last moment i'd like to ask
each of you to summarize if you would
your views of why you believe and and mr
zimmerman you touched on this already
why you believe
it was somebody in washington
or somebody other than the people you
were dealing with day-to-day
that made
what appears to be
the illogical decision to pull out the
agent who was successfully or appeared
to be successfully negotiating
and the decision to go in
at the time they went in those two seem
to me to be
inconsistent with an effort by the fbi
to try to resolve this peacefully i
would desperately like to believe that
that was their goal you had to have met
a number of fbi agents you had to have
known what they were like you knew the
agents in the field to some degree
why did they pull out in your view the
agent who was having success in
negotiating and then why did they make
that final decision to go in gentlemen
each of you would i don't know why they
pulled you told me i missed special
agent cavanaugh yes i am i don't know
that happened before we got there i
don't know the answer sir and i don't
want to guess
uh with the other one
again i
i guess i i also have come to have some
faith in my own ability to look at a man
face to face
have him tell me something
have that happen over a period of time
and know whether i can believe him or
not
and
and like i told congressman schumer
i wish he were here to hear this but i i
told him that i had a lot of respect for
jeff jamar bob ricks
uh byron sage clint vanzant those were
the people we dealt with i thought they
shot straight with us they gave us
they respected the attorney-client
privilege they didn't pump us for
information
they tried to facilitate this joint goal
they told us that we had all the time in
the world
if if mr schumer is right if jamar's
going to come in here and change his
position and say
i made that decision
and if all i've read is true is that
that decision had already been put into
effect before april the 14th when we he
told us we had all the time in the world
because as i understand it the attorney
general approved it on the 17th
and it had already worked its way up
that many would have had to lift waco if
jamar was involved before the 14th he
just flat lied to us
i refuse to believe that jeff jamar just
flat lied to us
i may be wrong mr de guerin well
on the two subjects as far as the
negotiator pulling kavanagh out
my read on that
no one's told me no one consulted me but
my read on that is because he was atf
and
atf had been so
emotionally involved in losing agents
um and rightly so that his
neutrality or his ability to negotiate
may have been compromised by that plus
the fact that the fbi
moved in and took over
and they should have
the atf shouldn't have been involved
from the from the time of the tragedy
until
everything was secure
they should have been moved out and
rightly so
that's on the negotiator as far as
where the decision was made for the tear
gas or
i don't know
we're going to have to break there
we've got four minutes for a vote we're
going to come back five minutes after
the vote okay
committee stands recess
wow
we'll return for more of day five of the
waco investigation hearings but first
some programming notes
wednesday on c-span south korean
president kim young-sam addresses a
joint meeting of congress he'll discuss
the importance of south korea's
relationship with the united states the
situation on the korean peninsula and
his country's evolution into a democracy
see live coverage of his remarks at 11
a.m eastern time wednesday on c-span
sunday on book notes abc's john
hockenberry
as a correspondent for npr he traveled
to the middle east to cover the persian
gulf war in the mid 80s he volunteered
to be the first journalist in space
this weekend he talks about the
challenges he faces closer to home a lot
of times in
new york
you have to wait for taxis i mean in the
rain for instance
you have to wait for five taxis before
someone will pick you up if you're in a
wheelchair and you're by yourself if
you're in a wheelchair with somebody
it'll stop if you're in a wheelchair by
yourself you know you have to kind of
take your chances if it's nice out
you'll do a little better
if there's a 40 mile an hour wind and
it's christmas eve believe me you don't
do very well at all and one cat passed
me by a second cab passed me by i
remember thinking oh come on
santa you know
it's time
it's time for a break here let's just
get me downtown again i'm freezing and
the third one passing me by and then
somebody comes and sees me if cabbie
comes and sees me and
and starts to pull over but then changes
lanes goes over into the left lane but
he's caught by the light so he's stuck
there in the intersection with his turn
signal on turning left pretending like
he hasn't seen me
this is ridiculous so i roll over open
the door and say can you take a fair he
says yes
i get out i get in the back seat i fold
up my chair and i said please put the
chair in the back in the trunk and i did
i absolutely said please this first time
and he goes
no it's too cold
emmy award-winning journalist john
hockenberry in his book moving
violations war zones wheelchairs and
declarations of independence sunday
night on book notes at eight eastern and
pacific time
c-span welcomes your comments and
thoughts about our programming
if you'd like to call us the number here
in washington is area code 202-626-7963
it's a voicemail system so follow the
instructions using a touch-tone phone
call the same number if you are
interested in video tapes of c-span
programming they are available at a cost
of thirty five dollars per hour
you can also write us
send electronic messages on the internet
to lower case viewer at cspan.org
our fax number is two zero two
seven three seven three three two three
and if you'd like to send a card or a
letter our mailing address is 400 north
capitol street northwest
suite 650
washington d.c
the zip code 2001.
we now return to further coverage of
today's joint hearing looking at the
1993 raid on the branch davidian
compound in waco texas
that's fine
[Music]
okay
will the witnesses uh
please be seated at the witness table
[Music]
the
joint oversight subcommittee hearings on
waco will now come to order
chair yields to mr condit in california
for five minutes
mr chairman first of all let me
apologize to you and the witnesses once
again um i have a conflict and schedule
and i have not been here um and uh i
have to leave at this moment to go back
to another hearing where we're
having a hearing in the agricultural
committee which is an extremely
important one for for me in my district
i do want to yield my time to my
colleague from mississippi in doing that
i want to
state that that should not bias me
against any of the testimony of the
witnesses i understand they did a good
job this morning but i do want to give
him my time give him the opportunity to
ask whatever questions he feels
necessary to ask right would you like me
to answer that last one i didn't sir
that i thought you asked a good question
we ran out of time i promised i would
get back to you should i do it now or do
you want me to wait let me ask you
something else but but you can talk as
long as you want as you understand i
can't so
mr zimmer and you uh
interestingly enough you and your
colleague are the first two to say that
the deaths of the f
aft agents was justifiable
now i'm going to turn the tables on you
for a second i'm going to guess that
when you were arguing on behalf of the
davidians that you said sanch since you
can't prove that my client individually
pulled the trigger
in the deaths of those agents therefore
is not murder
so i'm going to turn the tables on you
and ask you to tell me which one
was it conway lebloo todd mckeehan
robert williams or stephen willis that
deserved to die that day i didn't say at
least i don't think i said
that
those deaths were justified all i did
was answer no sir i answered your
question your question was have you read
or heard or seen anything that would
cause you to believe that the murder of
those four agents was justified all i
did was answer your question as honestly
as i could and i said yes sir i have one
is the jury verdict they were charged
with murder of those four agents the
jury acquitted them of that that's the
answer that i gave you and i and i and i
think that's the truthful answer but sir
having turned it around
i'm sure that the defense said that
since you cannot prove which one of
these davidians fired
and then you can't convict them
individually i'm saying which of these
guys deserve to die you using that same
line of testimony that that kept the
davidians probably from getting the
elected chair number one nobody said
that the uh that murder occurred but you
just can't show which of these did it
that whole defense there's four dead
guys on the ground mr zimmerman we're
talking about the difference between
murder though and self-defense uh
congressman taylor and all i'm saying is
the defense was that
that all of the any of the davidians
that fired were firing in self-defense
not just that somebody committed murder
but it wasn't these 11.
if that had been the defense frankly i
think the jury would have would have
convicted them all right but they didn't
now
uh
none of those people deserve to die none
of them weren't some of the davidians
convicted of manslaughter yes they were
they were yes sir voluntary manslaughter
which is
lesser included defense of murder it
takes out the intent that the deliberate
intent to kill it's a reaction i don't
want to get into lengthy thing but
basically if you're provoked
and you kill somebody that's voluntary
manslaughter also for a clarification
you were asked by mr schumer
mr schumer had asked you
if there was reason to take young miss
jewel away from david koresh you said
you didn't know of anything
you are an agent of the law let me tell
you that the michigan court ruled that
there was plenty of reason to keep miss
jewel away from david koresh and
prohibited her mother from taking her
anywhere near david kresh based on the
testimony they received i'm aware of
that yes sir and now in fairness i would
like you to to answer the question that
you have requested
you had at one earlier point you had
made a statement that
or asked a question
or pointed out that in answer to another
congressman's question i stated that no
administrator or criminal disciplinary
action had been taken against anybody
and that based on
uh special agent or
uh merletti's testimony yesterday
that in his report he reported in answer
to a question by somebody else that in
his opinion that a felony offense had
been committed by the two special agents
who had lied
to a federal investigator that they had
violated federal law and all i said was
that that that hasn't there's been no
administrative action based on that
felony no no criminal proceeding and you
said well aren't they assumed innocent
and i think you are out are you who
failed to get the message from rodriguez
and proceeded with the raid
i don't know what mr moletti was talking
about precisely but all i was pointing
out is that their own investigation
indicated a felony offense had been
committed and then you correctly
pointed out they have been convicted of
nothing and i wholeheartedly agree with
that they're entitled to the presumption
of innocence to a trial and so forth
just like
the point i want to make about the way
things are supposed to happen in this
country is when someone suspected of a
crime even if it's child abuse even if
it's capital murder
we give them a trial the jury finds them
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt before
they go to sentencing then a jury or a
judge sentences them and an appeals
court makes sure the trial was conducted
with due process and then and only then
did we kill them
we don't kill them first
like happened in waco on april the 19th
and it's a shame the davidians didn't
get that message sir
i have made a promise to miss lee that i
would yield her one minute of mr
condensed time i do so now
you're very times kayla thank you very
much very quickly let me as i was uh
finishing my question mr tagueran we're
asking uh what would make individuals uh
follow an individual like mr koresh
i was saying that to acknowledge
that you had the followers and people
who deeply believed and then you had
certainly mr karesh and i know you're a
defense attorney i'm not asking you to
uh negatively assess uh what would have
been your client may still be his family
members
but my question would be in the time
that you had with him did he tell you
how he came to power i just need a yes
or no on the answer did he tell you how
he came to power yes and no
sorry
explanation did he explain the 1987
uh
incident and let me just repeat and that
will be the wind-up of my question and
that is that in 1987
despite the facts that may be in
surrounding it he came on to the
compound
in camouflage and there was a 45-minute
gun battle and i think that is
distinguishable from seven-day
adventists who are in fact pacifists and
so it may have been a spin-off of a
denomination but i think if we separate
out mr koresh and those passionate
followers
um his uh
direction
uh led in a more violent turn than won
the adventist church and as well
possibly the followers who were there
with him uh by way of his entry as the
leader into that compound
to respond to that that was not the way
that he
came to be
the spiritual leader of
the branch davidians that was
a dispute between
david corrich and his followers
and a man named george rhoden
who was
well who's been found by a jury to be
criminally insane
i do understand the facts but there was
a gun battle there was a gun battle
uh in and
aft following that gun battle david
correct surrendered to
the sheriff of mclennan county and
surrendered all their guns and he was
tried
on a charge of attempted murder
all the persons that were tried were
found not guilty except for david coerce
who was
there was a hung jury and the district
attorney then dismissed the case
and i understand that he just engaged in
the gun battle even though the
determination was different legally but
there was a gun battle that david koresh
participated in all right thank you mr
guerin thank you
and now chair now yields to mr mccollum
in florida for five minutes
in this testimony today one of you and i
believe it was mr zimmerman indicated
you thought that a bureaucrat in
washington was responsible for ending
the negotiations that indeed the field
officers the fbi wanted to continue what
progress you were making what you
thought was being made
is did anyone with the fbi say anything
to either of you and i'll start with you
mr zimmerman at any time which indicated
that there was pressure coming from
washington to go with this cs gas
assault as opposed to the negotiations
sir my first knowledge of a
cs and tank attack
uh occurred at 6
15 in the morning on april the 19th when
my answering service called and said the
phone's ringing off the hook with the
press
and i turned on the television and
that's the first notice i had of that
attack they did not tell us in advance
of course but did they give you any
indication they were getting pressure
not to negotiate
no sir as a matter of fact my
i have a recollection and i understand
now that there's some dispute about it
by the fbi but i have a distinct
recollection
as does mr de guerin that after we
talked gave them this
information about the april 14th letter
that they'd be out within two weeks they
said they had all the time
why do you have the feeling that the
bureaucrat in washington was pressuring
them or making this decision instead of
somebody in the field to go with the
assault recommending it back up the
other way
based on i guess my earlier answer is
that jeff jamar as far as i know had
never been anything but straight with us
bob ricks had never been anything but
straight with us byron say there's been
nothing but straight with us why why
would they tell us we have all the time
in the world same question you mr garren
let me say that i had an early
conversation with with uh jeff jamar in
which he mentioned that some people
had discussed or said something about
uh
dismantling the building and putting
tear gas in but that that they weren't
seriously considering that and it was an
offhand conversation
it was very early in my relationship
with him i never got the idea that he
was under any pressure to do anything
i disagree a little bit with jack on
that i just never got that idea well for
this work department in the treasury or
in the justice department report on page
270 it says that byron sage
in an ensuing two-hour conversation on
april 15th apparently
that he had i guess with the attorney
general said further negotiations with
the subject the compound would be
fruitless uh further advised
of webb hubble in this case that corey
had been disingenuous in his discussions
with sage about the seven seals the fbi
had not succeeded in getting anyone
released from the compound through
negotiation there was a total impasse
nothing more he or the negotiators could
do to persuade korich to release anyone
else
would do any good and law enforcement
personnel waco were getting tired
and their tempers were fraying and in
essence this is all in support of what
appears from this report to have been a
decision that sage at least was involved
with making as early as the 12th of
april now we haven't heard from them yet
but i'm reading from the report did you
say 12th or 15th well the 15th is when
this phone call
was discussion was made but the
paperwork here through pages that
preceded show that the fbi apparently
originated this plan and took it up with
potts and clark
or that pots and clark took it up i
should say from the field as early as
the 12th with somebody in the attorney
general's office so it was around for
quite a while but it was being embraced
as early as the 12th and this phone
conversation took place on the 15th so
is any of that surprising to you well
not i guess i can't say i'm surprised
now because i've read those reports and
and i see that that was going on at the
time what what disturbs me though is
that there was not
apparently was not any input
about this
this breakthrough that we had on april
the 14th and and advice from and nobody
apparently passed that on to the
attorney general and it doesn't look
like he passed on the president either
because there's a notation we have with
us from fbi files of interviews of bruce
lindsay at the white house
uh indicating that a meeting on april
15th took place in which uh he was
briefed and presumably briefly a
president on this very same thing that
the negotiations were absolutely
impassed and weren't going to go
anywhere and it was just over the hill
now having said all that i want to
direct your attention somewhere else the
uh treasury department's been putting
out more stuff here in the last hour or
two they say that uh with regard to this
videotape that supposedly is missing in
a press release today
that their atf originally planned to
make a videotape of the warrant
execution of from the undercover house
the camera was set up in the window and
connected to a vcr recorder however in
the period before arrival of the cattle
trailers the agents found that whenever
they key their radio microphone the tape
entered from the vcr for this reason uh
rejected from the vcr for this reason
the vcr was never turned on the
videotape operation had been made it
would have confirmed the evidence
presented the trial by the atf evidence
in the media that the davidians fired
first now does that enlighten you in any
way about what happened to this tape or
is there another tape we're looking for
aside from the one they're referring to
that doesn't enlighten me no
i i just can't imagine with the amount
of money and preparation and planning
that went into this massive raid
that
the videotape didn't make it courage
told me that he saw
a video camera
there's a tape that i have here of
course talking to the negotiators in
which he discusses what happened at the
front door and how you guys have the
tape
i saw the the camera he this this tape
was made on
april the 13th uh jack and i both filed
i think we both filed motions with with
the court to preserve this tape i'd like
to have the opportunity to complete my
answer and and play the tape but i don't
want to take away from my time i
understand and maybe mr chairman will
give you that i want to ask you one
other question uh you had indicated
earlier in testimony that there were
several times when mr corey had had
promised to go out or had said he was
going to come out or whatever and he
didn't and mr schumer in asking you
questions seemed to imply that he got a
bunch of data he wanted to have
paperwork introduced that would go over
those cases
on early occasions presumably leading
one to the conclusion that why should he
now
on the 14th of april
live up to this commitment could you run
over mr degarin for us
how you analyze the reasons why coraish
did not
come out on the earlier occasions and
what was different about this one
i had difficulty understanding why he
would not walk out with me and surrender
to a texas ranger
and get into the criminal justice system
he saw the logic
of that and the advisability of that and
so i was having difficulty understanding
why it was that he he wouldn't say yes
i'll go right now
and i tried to understand that by
understanding his religious
doctrine
and i asked for
advice from arnold and tabor
and
what i learned was
that
more important to him more overriding to
him was this religious
doctrine
and when
he could interpret
the religious doctrine to say that it
was consistent with him coming out and
going into the criminal justice system
rather than dying on the spot
he would
and so
my
my talks with him began to to
go more to that
to understanding
that perhaps the doctrine didn't say
you're going to die now
the apocalypse is coming much later
years or or much later than that and and
that's why i think there was a
breakthrough but why didn't he come out
earlier
that was the question i'd ask yes that's
that's the answer because
of this overriding religious concern i
didn't agree with it i'm not trying to
justify it and i don't think it was
justified i wanted him out i mean this
was
i wanted a live client in court we had a
defensible case and i was trying to get
him to come out and trying to make him
understand that he needed to but he
wouldn't he wouldn't he said because
it wasn't written for him to come out
yet he was waiting to get that word when
he did get the word that's why i say it
was such a great breakthrough on april
the 13th and 14th thank you very much mr
chairman i can ask you in adamson that
the piece of a paper that has this press
release on about the video tape from the
treasury department be admitted into the
record without objection so order thank
you and in order to complete my answer
on that question may i play that tape
it's about two minutes and it's a tape
that was made by the fbi it's in the
evidence here as i understand it it'll
just take about two minutes and do that
yeah
deserving the right group jack
state your objection we've had we've had
a rule against these kinds of things the
first little program was admitted the
rest are not right if we want to take
change the rules
we can but we ought to go over did you
okay yes
he said that that was not going to
happen again you did yours we did ours
etc would you be willing to submit your
tape or evidence okay i would just say
that if we do this tape we have other
tapes that we'd like inserted into the
record and as long as
it will be allowed to and so we will be
allowed to insert our tapes i have no
problem with mr de garan's tape
it's not the question of the tape this
tape or not it's a question of basic
fairness thank you for your concerns i
think the chair will just say this if
you'll submit the tape for evidence
we will all those of us that are
interested listen to the tape is that a
fair process
we don't want to get into a battle
question uh i'd just like to know what
is that tape really mr de gary it's a
tape that was made by the fbi during the
negotiations on the 13th of april the
day before we got the letter
in which he guaranteed that he was
coming out and it discusses
what happened on
march the 28th at the door and discusses
that he saw a video camera that was
filming what happened at the original
raid i would think that anybody that
wants to get it the truth would be
interested would you like to i think we
ought to hear the tape no i would simply
say i will object unless i get the
majority's consent we have a bunch of
tapes both about related to today and
later that are dispositive and as long
as we can do our tapes i think it's no
objection to you doing your schumer
it'll be based on the particular tape at
the time oh then i will object because
it's your chairman uh like a uh
have a parliament for inquiry
thank you inquiry the uh when we had our
discussion at the beginning of these
proceedings and we decided because of
objections by mr schumer's side to
proceed under normal
normal order regular order
there was a discussion there at that
point i think the chairman will recall
this about the rule under which uh
tapes and other documentary evidence
should be submitted and my parliament
for inquiry isn't uh isn't it in the
normal course of business regular border
uh to uh to allow that to be submitted
or played or presented by a witness and
i'm wondering on what grounds uh that
would be objectionable continuing mr
the parliamentary inquiry is to the
chairman
okay uh as far as i uh the way i see it
that we should submit the evidence and
allow it to be played and as as long as
it's pertinent to what the discussion is
at the time i think at the same time if
mr schumer has a tape at a later on in
another panel and and and a witness is
presenting a piece of evidence and it's
pertinent then we ought to continuing my
reservation and that seems fair to me
and i'll be willing to do that it seems
but
i just want the
uh the audience and everybody else
everyone on the majority and minority
today
certain members of the fbi
wanted to bring tapes to the later to
the second uh
second or third panel i'm not sure which
we had discussions with the majority
staff
and we were told that all tapes would be
off limits and hence they didn't bring
them now there are plenty there are lots
of other tapes believe me we that we
would like to play and i just want to
make sure before
no uh
the chair the chair i'm trying regular
[Music]
continuing my reservation please we
heard your reservation well i'd like to
just say chairs prepare them mr chairman
okay please and well what yes
i'd like to to respond to mr schumer's
uh
uh
reservation
please please proceed well then wait
then if just if the gentleman would
forebear i was cut off by the gentleman
from georgia because he wanted a ruler
he's not cutting you off he's cutting me
off let me just finish my i thought the
chair had ruled no the chair is not
ruled the chair was about to finish the
ruling but
okay let me just finish my point and
that is this that the majority staff had
said no tapes
and therefore those tapes none
henceforth and we went along with that
the rules keep changing i don't mind i
mean we need notice and fairness my
understanding of what happened is
yesterday i believe it was yesterday you
wanted to introduce a tape my side
didn't want to do it we had introduced
the cnn tape in the beginning i said
it's only fair to allow yours now we
have the third tape i do not want to get
into a tape war or a video war or any of
the other kinds so i think at this point
the chair will rule that
the tape can be submitted for evidence
those of us that want to listen to it
we'll listen to it uh if if that's a
prayer room okay then we will do the
same without without objections we will
do the same mr chairman
so is the ruling of the chair that the
the playing of the tape is out of order
is that the chair's ruling the playing
of the tape is out of order we will
accept it as evidence
the ruling of the chair okay well it
requires unanimous
mr chairman okay
it requires unanimous consent to play
the tape and objection has been heard
from who
i thought mr mr schumer objected i
thought i thought i thought and again i
i'm not trying to butt in but but i
thought that mr schumer said as long as
he qualified by saying that he could
also introduce and i got a feeling just
knowing on past actions around here not
not pointing any fingers that we're
gonna have reams and reams of tapes and
we're gonna have video parades and
everything else we're gonna be here long
long hours tonight well after midnight
the rate we're going and this is just
another charade to slow things down i
just think at this point it just makes
good common sense to just accept it as
evidence and move on
mr chairman
mr chairman
i i know i'm i'm going to feel your
wrath but doing this but i'll be very
not you mr copeland i'll be very brief
about this
i i would be uneasy about uh
admitting this tape
with an agreement that we would open the
floodgates for everybody and his brother
who had a tape from here on in
i i do think however the chair might
want to consider hearing this tape and
then
subsequent tapes that may surface
consider each tape on its own bottom
rather than having a blanket endorsement
that everybody who has a tape will come
forward well we appreciate your comments
chairs rule
okay
on your time has expired
under uh
i would just like to uh ask a couple
questions that um
on on accountability mr zimmerman you
talked about the marine corps i have a
son that's in the marine corps and
i can understand what you're talking
about i've also been in small business
and large corporate entities and uh you
know accountability is is the name of
the game somewhere along the line
somebody's got to be responsible who do
you think is responsible for this
tragedy that happened on april 19th
on april the 19th
the general is responsible
for everything that happens in his or
her command
the general is responsible anybody above
the general
in my view the general is about as high
as you go i would
i was talking about military contact
you're referring okay that's in the
military yes who was the general then in
at wake up
whoever made that decision the final
decision to go in on april 19th with
that military attack who do you think
did that i really don't know sir i mean
there's been
mr the guarantee there has been i may i
said
go ahead we can't
someone jumped up and said i'm
responsible the buck stops here
and uh gained a lot of the public
admiration for that stance but has never
been held accountable
never been held accountable
and and
mr altman's letter to mr benson dated
april 15th
saying something tragic is going to
occur on the 19th and it just kind of
got discarded is that cause your problem
where we have people in government that
you know they find out about these
things and do nothing about them
that bothers me that something didn't
get transmitted across but it does not
affect my earlier opinion that
it was not the secretary of the treasury
that was responsible it was the attorney
general of the united states it was on
april 14th did jeff jamar tell you that
you have all the time necessary to end
this peacefully
yes sir
and
what happened what happened to that i
mean is did something just get yanked
out of his hands
the truth will answer that is i don't
know what happened my my assumption was
is that
that decision was overridden at higher
headquarters
and if i could answer that someone said
something earlier about byron sage
making a recommendation at an earlier
point in time byron sage was an
assistant special agent in charge in
austin he was junior to
both jeff jamar who was a special agent
in charge out of san antonio and special
agent in charge bob ricks out of the
oklahoma city office both of them were
senior to byron sage i find it
incredible that that a junior
special agent like sage would be able to
make a decision
of that significance
mr adjourn
i thought a lot about that because
byron sage excuse me jeff jamar said to
me when i was
frustrated a little bit and told him
that i wish i could say he's coming out
today but it's going to be a while until
these
seals get written
he said don't worry we've got all the
time it takes
and then
the fbi would have allowed uh
korres to surrender to to anybody other
than the fbi
well
was that discussed texas rangers it was
discussed
it was never rejected
uh i thought it would be a good idea and
i wanted to see it happen but uh
i don't think that that's what caused
there not to be a surrender
describe
your feelings after you
heard that the raid had moved forward
the gas was putting in both of you just
described how you felt and
were you helpless is there anything you
could do
your emotions i was shocked i was in
north texas getting ready to start a
trial i was certain that we had some
time
and when i got the phone call to look at
the screen and see what's going on i
immediately called the fbi i wasn't able
to reach jamar the only message that i
got
and i can't remember the name of the
agent i talked to was we don't need you
i said i'd come back down i'll go back
in just hold off
let me see if i can tell them that
you're out of patience
and i rushed from there
to waco by the time i drove from denton
to waco everyone was dead the fire was
over how did you feel about that this i
mean did you just pull over the side of
the road or what what went through your
mr zelda i met
most of the people in there
i met the children
i wanted to be part of helping to save
their lives
and i've um
it had to be rough i feel that if i had
been a little bit more persuasive
i could have gotten david korsh out of
there quicker
and so i feel that i failed
but i also feel like it was a great
mistake
to start the tanks and tear gas
whether you accept
that david cory started the fire and
committed suicide with all of those
people or whether it was accidental or
not there's one thing certain
those people would be alive today if
those tanks and tear gas hadn't started
rolling on april the 19th
mrs zimmerman
same question mr chairman i was in
houston texas at the time that the
operation began i
waited for the i i called
reached henry garcia with a negotiation
team who had been sort of
friendly with us when we were there he
answered the phone
i said what's going on he said
have you seen the television i said yes
are we still going to be part of the of
the surrender plan because i thought at
that time
like everybody else did that people
might come out after that
he said i'm not at liberty to discuss
the tactical plan but go ahead and come
on up
so i reached dick and he started down
from denton and i started up from the
other direction both three-hour drives
and uh the fire broke out when i was
still about two hours from waco well how
did you feel and then and maybe each of
you then also tell me how
how did you feel the fbi must have
thought
how did you feel how did i
i felt betrayed i i
was hopeful
uh i was clearing my schedule i thought
they'd be out within another 10 days
and i could not believe
that the fbi or the justice department
or whoever it was would undertake such a
dangerous operation
knowing that there were old men and
pregnant women and children in there i
just couldn't believe that they would do
that and then there was a ktrh radio a
lot a talk show had a live report from
it
and
so i was on the road actually driving
while that building was burning
and i i have to tell you
uh you won't hear this very often from
defense lawyers but
i echo mr daguerre and i had a sense of
failure
unlike any i'd ever had before
not that i've never failed before but
not where people who put their lives in
my hands
died the question was asked before the
red light how do you think the fbi felt
my view was that you know i've had
cynical remarks made to me after
speeches because bob ricks was up in and
and it seemed to be
almost with tears in his eyes and people
were saying you know all he was worried
about is losing his job and his career i
don't believe that i think he really did
feel bad i think he's a good what i call
a good cop
good cops
don't really care too much about what
happens to bad people or guilty people
but they sure do
care about things like
children and innocent people and they
don't like something like this to happen
my view was that was a genuine remorse
being displayed by mr ricks i think jeff
jamar had genuine remorse after all he
was in charge this was his operation he
was the scene commander his career was
over and 80 people were dead because of
something that was technically under his
control because he was the on-scene
commander i think the fbi felt terrible
i hope that when they come here they
don't tell you
that they didn't feel terrible
my response mr zelif
i saw
bob rex at the press conference that
followed the fire and he did have a
break in his voice a frog in his throat
if you will
i think it was sincere and i called him
after that we we had a good relationship
i said
uh mr rex
i think i called him bob
um my heart goes out to you i know that
you didn't intend for it to end this way
i'm going to be critical of you i'm
going to be critical of the decision but
it's not personal and i'm i'm sorry
that it ended this way it may not have
been his decision this uh concludes this
panel we thank you both very very much
uh we will resume
um at five minutes after the next vote
and uh
again i think we're going to go aways
but
we will uh
adjourn for until uh five minutes after
the next vote
[Music]
we'll return for more of day five of the
waco investigation hearings but first
some programming notes
c-span's
all on washington journal live weekday
mornings at 7 eastern time
we now return to further coverage of
today's joint hearing looking at the
1993 raid on the branch davidian
compound in waco texas
okay
okay
the
subcommittee on the waco affair
will now come to order
all the members of the panel please step
forward and be seated
i'll introduce dr philip arnold
religious scholar from rice university
holds a phd in religious studies with a
focus on a
apocalyptism
in jewish and christian history
professor james tabor
professor of religious studies at the
university of north carolina recently
authored y waco
cults in the battle for religious
freedom in america
maurice cook is a captain in the texas
rangers david burns is a captain of the
texas rangers
and glenn hilburn is professor from
baylor university which is a democratic
with democrats witness
everybody
here and present
okay the other members will will be
sworn in
mr mcclure isn't it
okay
please raise your right hand
the testimony you're about to give these
substantive subcommittees the truth the
whole truth nothing convert the truth
yes
thank you very much appreciated
let the record reflect that the answers
were in the affirmative
okay
chair will now recognize uh john micah
for five minutes
uh thank you mr chairman
um i'd like to start if i may with the
two witnesses that are
texas rangers i guess we've actually
we've got three here the senior ranger
mr cook or captain cook captain burns
mr foster
um
how did you get here um
gentlemen
well we flew american airlines
who paid for the tickets uh the state of
texas
state of texas we asked congress to pay
for it incidentally and congress said
that we need to fly on our own and
you how long have you been here you've
been here for
i understand four days prior to the
hearing
no sir we arrived here sunday night
uh we got in uh about 9 30 and i think
it was 11 30 before we found the hotel
uh and that's for all three of you well
brantley foster is not here he's a
retired texas ranger and
so we don't know uh where he is he's not
under our command yeah during the
interim have you spent time with
mr
ron noble or mr battle or other
treasury
officials or justice officials
discussing
the hearings or what took place at wacom
yes sir
did you request those meetings
well i think captain burns may can
address that better than i can uh
because i think he might have got a call
on that
who requested the meetings uh mr mike if
i could let me back up to last week
possibly is this what you're talking
about when we're up last week
uh i understand you were up last week
too and had meetings
so you've been meeting sort of uh on on
several occasions with uh
treasury and officials other federal
officials to discuss
your testimony and and what took place
at waco to yes to discuss the facts of
waco we met with
both the
republican staff people and the
democratic staff people and we met with
the treasury majority staff people
uh yes or twice you did uh did you have
lunches
or any uh meals with ron noble yes sir
you did
yes
so you basically have been whined and
bind and and met with
the treasury officials prior to uh your
testimony and participation here today
we ate with mr noble a couple times just
i might add that we spent more time
probably with congressional people than
we did with mr nobles
but you did spend time and discuss your
your testimony you didn't feel like you
were under any pressure though did you
no absolutely not um
just a quick question
why
what what are any of you familiar with
the missing door that was testified
about just before that's supposed to be
in the possession i guess of the texas
rangers anybody know where the missing
front door is
i think i i think i know where it is
where it went i don't know where it is
where did it go
[Music]
i believe what happened that door
was that
if you recall the videotape when they
were inserting the gas
and the tank made the insertion there at
the front door
the
when they pulled out there was a lot of
debris came with that the left door was
found outside the
burned area the
right door i believe was pushed inside
there and burned
and there was when we got into that
crime scene there was quite a bit of
just sheet metal there were metal
cabinets and uh
metal frames of like dining chairs and
this this type of thing and i believe
that when we had to clear that debris to
start the uh
crime scene that uh this stuff appeared
to have no evidential value but they're
not sure of exactly no that door was not
recognized i believe for what it was and
it was captain hook you don't know where
the door is and you the other gentleman
doesn't know where the door is either do
you no sir do not thank you uh just a
second to dr arnold and dr tabor are you
familiar with the this report the
recommendations of experts for
improvements in the waco law uh in
federal law enforcement after waco yes
yes i've seen and uh didn't the
administration uh retain a number of
people like the head of the harvard
school of uh sullivan nancy
uh
several individuals
it's kind of interesting that they uh
they said ask questions like is the
federal assault on this religious
community near waco texas together with
its
ensuing standoff and fire and emblematic
of the trivialization of religion in
official america
uh though the branch
davidians may not in everyone's view
typify religious
life in many american communities the
response of public officials and law
enforcement agencies may in fact reflect
marginal value assigned to
religion as a public matter and the and
the reduction of public religious con uh
convictions and actions
et cetera
this this is their response they also
said that
they felt that
uh
that we needed to retain
a friendly a consultant that is not
a consultant that is friendly is not
sufficient
in the future in instances because of uh
again their recommendations that there
wasn't proper
uh
knowledge about
uh this group this religious group could
you describe this group and the
recommendations uh and their beliefs uh
as as it relates again to what's what's
in this report
which one would you like uh either one
doctor arnold and you can take turns
when you say this group uh
branch the branch of divinity right what
is your specific question about again
this recommend that these
recommendations say that we didn't
we didn't understand their values uh we
didn't know how to deal with them it was
a
uh sort of a bizarre cult or religious
group right i follow what you're asking
now the after the um the tragedy of
april 19 1993
uh throughout the next year many
scholars began to communicate one with
the other
scholars who are experts in religion
and
we felt like it would be very important
to form a task force
we did called the religion crisis task
force which would be available to help
law enforcement media
government
gain accurate information about
religious groups if ever such a
situation would ever occur again why do
you believe it was so important that the
religious aspect of this group be
understood
right and as uh dr amerman and some of
dr sullivan and others in that
particular report
wrote
without a correct understanding of the
branch davidian religious faith
law enforcement was operating in a
vacuum
they were not able to perceive
the
meaning of the religious language the
branch davidians were using they were
not able to understand the actions that
the branch davidians took
they were not able to know which precise
course of action would be of more value
than another course of action and they
were unable to know
which particular steps could precipitate
disaster
had they had knowledge of the religious
faith of the branch davidians
this story could have ended in a much
better and happier way
so i think dr amberman and dr sullivan
and others of us
want to communicate
to the american people the law
enforcement to our to our country to our
government
that it is crucial
to understand
the world view the ideological world
view
of a religious group
if you're going to deal with them in the
act of law enforcement
not that they are in any way or exempt
from existing laws no they are
responsible to those laws like all of us
but if you're going to deal with someone
from a different culture or someone who
has a different religious language or
even a different language linguistically
speaking you want a good translator
present to help you to understand the
culture of those people you're dealing
with
gentleman's time has expired did i make
a 30-second response since you asked
both of us okay i would just like to say
that the fbi reports they had literally
a fax meltdown and so i think both
arnold and i come with the degree of
sympathy where do you turn you had
everybody from the nuts
to the bolts calling in and saying i can
solve it you know i know about the book
of revelation
and so there's also a procedural thing
here
and it has to do with setting up
something that we can explore later but
i think we want to register that
sympathy
they're trained in hostage barricade
rescue not the book of revelation so who
do you call
and they went to certain people at
baylor and so forth
but they they had a tough time in other
words trying to figure out who to listen
to
thank you very much
gentlemen from michigan michigan mr
conyers for five minutes
thank you very much mr chairman
i'm
gentlemen and mr cook in particular uh
welcome to the
house of representatives in these two
committees
may i ask you sir
in your opinion is it a good idea
to let outside people
talk to a
suspect or person that you're
negotiating with and the kinds of
circumstances that
bring us here today
i think in all our training that it
would probably not be a good idea
according to our training methods
however
when all other fails you resort to
whatever it means that will resolve the
issue and
in hostage negotiation i think you can
get too formalized i think you got to do
what works
you you've had a
chance to
interview special agents sarah ben and
the hornotsky
and
based on those interviews can i
find out what you've learned and
how you viewed their credibility
and whether you
think that they knew the raid had been
compromised let me pass that question to
captain burns and and for the panels uh
he was the site commander he was the
only commander so you were closer to
that
mr behrens
yeah yes congressman i was the task
force commander down there
to answer your question
in my view from the
overwhelming evidence that we uncovered
in
interviewing the
agents some 60 or 61 of those agents
uh and in what uh our agents
their perception was and what was said
when they interviewed uh mr sarah and mr
wondowski i do not believe that they're
credible in this in this instance and i
do believe that
that they knew that the raid was
compromised
and you know that's a
large issue that
been going back and forward in these
hearings over the last several days
yeah so that's been an issue from almost
from day one down there
right there's a lot of problems
it has indeed
mr mcclure
what what is your view with respect to
uh
trying to let outside people intervene
and talk with a
a suspect
that that is being negotiated with that
you're negotiating with
is that
is that
have any uh basis in
in in good law enforcement work
well in all our training uh
we try to use that only as a very last
resort
in our basic negotiations 101 when we
teach and train other law enforcement
personnel
we advise against using what we call
third-party negotiators
especially those that sort of come in
out of nowhere
where where you don't really know that
much about them wasn't didn't i
understand right there were people
trying to intervene in almost
on a voluntary basis
it's my understanding that the
negotiators out there got calls from
literally all over all over the world
from offers for help
and uh it's been my experience that
unless you're trained in crisis
negotiations
and like you said mr conyers if you
hadn't been there and you don't know
what has taken place
then how can you come in and
legitimately negotiate with the person
on the inside
thank you mr mcclure tell me in in your
opinion is there anything different that
the fbi could have done
to guarantee a different outcome in the
wake of standoff
i think that you had some of the best
negotiators in the country that were out
there i think some mistakes were made
that in hindsight that they had to do
over they may have done a little bit
differently
no question about that but
i think that all the efforts were
and the ultimate outcome uh in my humble
opinion was up to mr david koresh he
could have came out at any time they
gave him the opportunity
uh they presented the vehicle for him
and the followers to come out at any
time that they wanted to
and uh they chose not to
it was uh more or less inevitable uh
from the things i've been hearing uh
and and uh
you know these hearings in in a congress
are
people have their different views and
different feelings and different
opinions
and may have actually legitimately seen
things differently
the defense law you're sure is heck
come here with a with a
point of view that doesn't have to be
elaborated on
so
we we hear a lot of things from one end
of the spectrum to the other but in the
end
we've got to settle
all of these myriad conflicting
testimony down
and try to find out what kind of person
mr koresh is and that there's been a
great attempted rehabilitation
here today that's the most amazing feat
i've i've witnessed in quite a while
and uh
uh last question
mr mcclure the dynamics and the
negotiation process between the tactical
team
and the negotiators do you have any
feelings about
how that went down or what what kind of
pressures were at play
well on any operation any hostage
barricade situation
you're going to have communication and
you're going to have differences
between negotiators and tactical
commanders that's healthy
it's ultimately left up to the on-scene
commander to make the ultimate decision
based on recommendations of your
negotiation team commander
and your tactical commander they present
all options to the on-scene commander
and he has to make the ultimate decision
naturally
uh tactical people think in tactical
terms negotiators think in negotiation
terms
and sometimes they are not going to
always mesh
i'm a trained negotiator that's the
terms that i think in
and i would like to think that
if some things had
recommendations by some of the
negotiators had taken place it may be
some things would have been different
i don't know you're in the timing you
did an excellent job and i
thank you very much for coming here this
evening thank you mr kanye appreciate
that
and
chair now recognizes mr chef from ohio
um
i can't let the gentleman from
michigan's comment about the attempted
rehabilitation of uh this afternoon go
unchallenged uh because i heard no one
trying to rehabilitate
particularly if the gentleman is
referring to mr koresh
i heard an attempt here
at least on this side of that and i
think on the other side as well to get
all the facts out get opinions about
what happened in this event and to learn
from this terrible tragedy both the
tragedy that happened on february 28th
when four law enforcement officers brave
law enforcement officers lost their
lives uh and and
then on april 19th
when
20 some innocent children
perished and and other women who who i
believe were were also killed within
that facility i have no sympathy for
crash i have no sympathy for any of the
other gunmen in that facility but i have
tremendous sympathy for the innocent
children that were in that facility
there was no attempt to rehabilitate
anybody today but getting getting on
with with my questions uh to the texas
rangers uh gentlemen could could you
briefly uh describe what the texas
rangers involvement
was uh in in either
uh in either of the two incidents either
the february 28th or the april 19
incidents
let me just go ahead and i'm glad
somebody asked that question because the
texas rangers first of all let me just
say that there's only 103 texas rangers
in texas we've got 254 counties and
we're part of the texas department of
public safety which is about three
thousand commissioned people strong
all of our rangers have eight years law
enforcement or more so we have seasoned
veteran
peace officers as texas rangers our role
was the united states attorney's office
and atf had called and asked us to
handle the murder investigation of the
four atf people that was that was killed
and that was basically our role we we
did the crime scene we gathered the
evidence and we worked a criminal
investigation dealing with murder right
but you weren't responsible as the atf
was for the first rate or the as the fbi
was for the second raid no sir we were
not thank you um
now
did you have occasion to have dealings
with uh the fbi gentleman i believe that
was uh
one of the commanders down there mr
jamar
yes sir i did and and
we had some information that that uh
that
one of you gentlemen or or some texas
rangers felt that he was out of control
could you comment on that
yes i had
quite a few disagreements with mr jamar
could you pull the mic a little closer
please thank you
first of all to be fair uh as mr mcclure
said there are there were tactical
considerations down there which was the
safety of
concerns of the hrt and the people
inside the compound
we had competing concerns which was for
that crime scene which we had to
try to work at some point in time once
they had terminated that standoff
when those
competing
interests if you will
it was a matter of tactical or the crime
scene those were all in favor of
tackling i have no no argument with that
at all i think the safety of all those
people was utmost
the big problem i had was
that i think all of us had including the
u.s attorney down there was that there
was no communication
it got to the point we couldn't even
talk to them on the phone
they
were destroying the outside of the
compound the
especially moving the vehicles which we
thought was critical
evidence for trajectory we were hopeful
we could put people shooting out of
those windows
and from that window maybe do some
trajectory
things with ballistics and
absolutely you know charge someone
specifically with murdering one of those
or some of those four agents
we we talked about that we were told
that we would
you know be able to urge our concerns
before that happened that was not done
that was done
just we found out about it on cnn as a
matter of fact uh it it got so bad that
finally mr johnson
wrote the attorney general a letter uh
and detailing our our complaints and
concerns
which resulted in the main justice and
uh the upper echelon of the fbi becoming
involved in that
they came down we had uh i had a meeting
first with uh mr mark richards from
justice and i believe mr potts from the
fbi who was in i think in the number
three level
uh i voiced
my concerns to them and
my criticisms
the
about a week later we had another
meeting
they came back down
and
we got
pretty much on an even footing uh in the
meantime i had met with uh
jeff jamar and byron sage and
also voiced these uh concerns them in
person and told them that i i was very
concerned
about the crime scene destruction uh the
uh
i was upset because they let two defense
attorneys in on the crime scene that's
the first time in any criminal
investigation i believe that's ever been
done
let me stop you there if i can because
i'm
getting short on time here there's one
question i i wanted to get from uh the
two doctors here and also the rangers um
i've had i know many members on both
sides of the aisle have have tremendous
we're very disturbed about the fact that
the cs gas was used particularly when
there were innocent children in that
facility i'd like to ask the doctors
first
what do you think about that particular
decision
um and and uh
well that's the question basically what
do you think about the decision to use
gas when there were children in that
facility
tear gas
i don't know if we all want to hear my
answer to that particular question
because if when the story really becomes
known to you
as to what happened to the people inside
when the cs gas came in and how it
eventually leads to
tanks coming in the front to insert more
cs gas
when you begin to actually understand
the religious dynamics that went on
within the community and that's what i
want to talk about later as we proceed
through tonight
you will begin to see a very very sad
sad sad story
because as that cs gas was delivered
you can listen to the surveillance tapes
made by the bugs put there by law
enforcement
and those bugs will tell you many things
we've already heard some of the more
disturbing things
but there are also places in the bugs
where you read where you hear where you
can hear or read
the branch davidians knowing the gas was
coming in you hear them say
let's pray
you hear them reading psalms
something like the 23rd psalm
yea though i'll walk to the valley of
the shadow of death i will fear no evil
those kinds of psalms
they gathered together to pray
they began to recite these biblical
passages
and what were they doing
they were calling upon their god to
protect them from the cs gas
that's a sad story and i don't want to
go on with it in too much melodramatic
tones
because it can become very very
depressing as you think about what
happened especially later as lives are
lost
and prayers are unanswered
and people die
was not a good idea
i'll explain later but in a sentence it
delivered to david koresh
the apocalyptic situation
that he had predicted and expected for
10 years
as it came on the 19th
the rangers
well i i would believe that it had to be
very uh
uh devastating those people in there uh
let me say that that i was advised on
the 18th of what that operation is going
to be on the afternoon of the 18th uh
uh
i did not have a
at that time a a problem with it per se
uh i was not asked it was not not a
confrontation thing i was just merely
advised it was going to go forward
uh
the uh you know gas is something that's
used in barricaded subject situations
and from that context i didn't see a
problem with it i think that that
obviously the subject it was used on
especially small children uh was uh
quite
unpleasant to think about it it's
unpleasant for me to think about it and
i think about it a lot and i had nothing
to do with it but i do think about it a
lot it is unpleasant
it's difficult to
second-guess without having all the
tactical information
gas is one of the the less lethal
ways of extracting barricaded
individuals i mean you know it's less
than firearms it's less than deadly
force even though some will argue that
tear gas or cs gas could be deadly on
some subjects but you know the intent
was to extract the people from the
compound i'm sure
even though we were not part of that
program i'm sure the intent was to
extract as many people from that without
injury
discomfort maybe but not injury
gentlemen's time has expired mr schumer
for five minutes
thank you uh mr chairman first i guess
i'd say it's nice to see this whole
panel here
because the previous panel was the most
unbalanced we've had so far and to have
two defense lawyers for six and a half
hours with nobody else on the panel
clearly they were doing their job i
don't hold that against them but
that is not a semblance of fairness or
lack of bias and when i heard each of
them refused to
really believe that kyrie jewell was
suffering suffering the way she did it
really raised my eyebrows about the
whole worth of the entire testimony so i
just want to go over a few questions
with a far less biased source and i
don't know what your answers are going
to be but
certainly i will have more faith in them
than the answers i had from defense
lawyers
the first one is
as a well-respected law enforcement
agency and you conducted an extensive
investigation awake i want to ask these
questions
earlier today we heard these defense
lawyers who are not on the scene at all
make the argument that uh the
atf fired first
what's your judgment
as to who fired first
uh i believe that the uh evidence was uh
to me overwhelming in the trial
that uh the davidians fired first
the cameraman
uh and the uh
reporter mr mclemore although
uh very reluctantly finally uh
i believe conceded that uh of course he
had broadcast that several times he was
more or less a hostile witness but i in
my mind there's no doubt who fired for
again you have no doubt at all that no
sir no doubt so the defense lawyer's
testimony there is at clear odds with
yours i certainly have a different
opinion than they do yes sir okay thank
you second i want to ask you about the
cover-up we've heard about cover-ups
here you've heard about mistakes made
but then a few people have brought up
the term cover-up now you were in charge
of this investigation
afterwards have you found that any of
the from your knowledge
probably you're the people on the scene
with the most extensive knowledge who
are not part of the federal government
and in fact it's well known that you had
some tension with some of the people in
the federal government uh not your fault
i might add um
in my judgment from what i've heard uh
do you have any notion that either atf
fbi or anyone else in the federal
government tried to cover up the facts
here
i don't believe that it was a
as far as the federal government uh any
kind of conspiracy i think that that uh
certainly on the uh level of the uh raid
commander and probably above them an atf
there was some uh
uh you mean sarah ben and yeah
there was some misinformation that's
still been put out to this day about
whether or not the raid was compromised
right uh we we played cover-ups a
general you know we've heard about
justice coming in and telling the atf
not to look at it that's a favorite
theory of one of our colleagues and
other things uh any cover-up in that
extent not the fact that sarah ben and
boynotsky might not have been telling
the truth but a cover-up from higher-ups
saying don't do it i've seen no evidence
of that no evidence and have you mr cook
oh in fact that was the reason that we
were called in was to
not that the
atf or fbi were not credible sources but
we were an independent credible source
correct that's reason we were called in
okay and again
texas right the youtube folks feel the
text from the texas ranger point of view
no cover-up is that absolutely correct
absolutely no doubt in your mind first
of all we would not have stood for a
cover-up thank you and i i agree with
you there knowing a little bit of the
history of the texas rangers
um
next question is about the door now then
we've heard this right door is missing
although the left door is available and
i think you testified to an earlier
question that you thought it was
on fire and somebody may have walked off
with her it had vanished because it was
on fire we we do have the left door
first
isn't it true that there are bullet
holes going in both directions on the
left door is that correct that is
correct okay and so you cannot determine
from that door who fired first
no sir okay is there any reason to
believe that the right door would be any
different in terms of the way the bullet
holes would be
they're right next to each other we used
to have pictures i don't believe so uh
you haven't seen it i'm just asking for
your advice as a law enforcement uh
officer with a great deal of experience
i've seen the same pictures you have and
and the the best picture i've seen
though there appears to be bullet holes
in it uh i i could not say
uh which way they appear to be coming
but uh i wouldn't think the
one door would be any different from the
other except we've got one we don't have
the other okay i want to thank you
gentlemen because you shed for the first
time this evening you've shed some
objectivity on uh these hearings today i
now have a question for mr um
tabor
and my question is this mr tabor uh
i've read some i haven't read all of
your book but i've read little bits of
it and you were nice enough to give me
another copy today um
you seem to imply that uh
the
people of waco in the in waiko the
people of waco people of america all the
rest of us are sort of intolerant
because we weren't sensitive enough to
the complexity of david koresh's
particular teachings um on page 42 of
your book
you write that in
khoresh announced his quote non-legal
marriage to 14 year old karen doyle
later the same year he secretly married
a 12 year old you say on page 67 that
koresha reigns sham marriages among
davidians to conceal his behavior
and last week of course we heard kerry
jewell's testimony uh which i hope you
don't have doubts about the way the
defense lawyers did but i'm not even
going to ask you that because i have a
different question given your expertise
i just want to ask you
isn't there some line you cross
over
between tolerance of somebody whose
religious practices are different
and and
practices that in any society would be
regarded as wrong immoral illegal
um
both the weapons and the sexual charges
of mr koresh seemed to me to cross that
line and as you know dr tabor i'm the
author of along with chris cox of the
rift the religious freedom restoration
act which said which pushed back the
government from imposing its will on
religions that have somewhat different
practices than the norm but i would like
both of you
uh you know david koresh said that the
bible commanded him to do some of these
very strange abhorrent types of behavior
it seems to me
that at some point
what it because some person says the
bible commanded him to do things like
marry 14 year olds and sleep with 10
year olds and in fact
congress have an aggregate of illegal
weapons that were crossing the line and
they no longer deserve our tolerance
they deserve our condemnation and our
probation and i would like you and dr
arnold and maybe mr mcclure although
it's a little off his field to just
just uh answer that
what the book attempts to do is as
clearly as possible explain all the
areas i had no involvement in any of the
charges dealing with the sexual
immorality
stockpiling of arms whatever
my only contribution it was very minimal
was to try to interpret the apocalyptic
system however in writing the book
and trying to explain how
a harvard law school graduate wayne
martin or steve snyder with an m.a in
comparative religion
who some have charged even you know gave
his wife to coerce although that's
denied in the negotiation tapes but
certainly the other other uh
married men did
was to try to also i mean it's a
comprehensive book why waco not
i'm an academic and so i try to tread
the line between saying
isn't this horrible i assume anyone who
reads it would be able to judge that uh
certain acts are horrible the question
is how did rational people become
persuaded
that these things were biblical in other
words his attempt to shed light if you
read that chapter i think you see you'll
see it's very objectively presented
and i basically give quote the best case
and i mean that in quotes meaning the
case david gave
it's an attempt to understand that
aspect actually had nothing to do
directly
with the involvement at the end of april
and what happened on the 19th but it's a
good you know it's an important point
obviously
your time has expired but go ahead and
finish up yes
i think you're absolutely correct there
are limits
when a religious group and individuals
in it break certain existing laws
then those laws have to be enforced
we have no quarrel with that i certainly
don't what i have a quarrel with
is not
factoring in
the religious understanding of the group
you see this was a
a religious ecosystem
and when law enforcement broke into that
ecosystem
it violated certain traditions and
customs it caused a certain chain
reaction to take place now my point is
isn't that law enforcement should not
enforce the laws that have to be
enforced but my point is that when
law enforcement
has to deal with these religious groups
who have a different worldview and
different customs and they have to the
law enforcement has to factor into their
actions an understanding of the
religious group
in order to avoid catastrophe which
takes the lives
of law enforcement agents
or innocent people within
we don't want to event
that's designed to accomplish good
boomerang on us and cause
gross catastrophe as we have seen waco
the way to do that is to bring in
religious translators that can translate
the language of the group you're dealing
with
and atf did not do that
neither i'm afraid did the fbi
earnestly
contact
and consult religious experts it's one
thing to talk to them and to interview
them but we received no data
we received no information no
transcripts of negotiation tapes
we were left in a void
and we could not therefore
give the information that would have
helped them now we didn't i know
congressman connors
made the point and i agree with it we
didn't want to be on the telephone day
in and day out with david koresh we're
not qualified negotiators as the rangers
and jamar and some of the other experts
are
but we believe that we should have been
given transcripts of those negotiations
so that we could evaluate them and
explain the religious language
if we had done that we humbly believe
that we could have helped resolve the
crises without further loss of life
okay your time has expired we're going
to recess for approximately 15 minutes
for this boat
and
try to get back as quickly as you can
and we'll resume questioning with uh
this is ileana ross laden
[Music]
we'll return for more of day five of the
waco investigation hearings but first
some programming notes
the c-span school bus is in washington
d.c this month see the bus each morning
on c-span's washington journal also this
summer we look back at the
1994-95 nationwide tour
many of the prisoners at first went to
camps in england where they were
processed places like southampton
later they were taken on troop transport
ships across
the atlantic ocean
to ports like boston virginia and in new
york
there they were processed given
identity cards photographs taken and
then sent by train to arizona
it was usually a four to five day trip
they disembarked very near here about
100 feet
from here the train tracks run to the
southern part of the camp they were then
marched down the highway here and then
brought into the front section of the
camp
once the prisoners came in and were
being processed here
they had the option whether or not to
sign a document that stated that they
would not try to escape from the camp
and would
help the american administration by not
causing any trouble
if they signed the document they were
put into a special section of the camp
called the democratic camp and this was
a special section of the camp where the
guardian was a little less strict they
had a little more freedoms and they were
allowed to work at various points inside
the pow camp
prisoners that refused to sign the
document
they were sent to what was called the
nazi compound and it was a compound
where they were guarded much stricter
they were behind three rows of barbed
wire instead of one
their clothes were dyed black with the
letters pw painted in large letters all
over their their clothes
and the heels of their shoes were
notched in a special way that if they
ever escaped their footprints would be
easily identifiable from the 50 or 60
prisoners former prisoners i've
interviewed i have not heard one single
negative aspect of their their life here
they were very well treated they felt
the american
guards in the american administration
was was very fair they were well fed
they had all sorts of recreational
activities they could see american
movies subtitled in german they had many
different types of german sports
german football what we call soccer
faust ball which is a form of volleyball
they were
the democratic prisoners at least were
allowed to work inside the camp and also
outside picking cotton which they were
paid for they were paid 80 cents a day
for 100 pounds of cotton picked or 80
cents a day if they worked in any of the
various facilities inside of the
florence camp
the money was in the form of small
coupons which they could
exchange at the camp canteen for various
miscellaneous articles cokes
writing paper toilet articles things of
that nature
so their memories here were very very
pleasant they were even brought here on
very plush pullman trains which
surprised many of them
and
i think that's the reason why so many of
them have been wanting to come back to
visit the former campsite because they
don't see it as really imprisonment they
see how a lot of their relatives fared
back in germany during the war and also
compared to the many thousands of
germans that were imprisoned by the
soviets and died under severe
mistreatment so they are very grateful
indeed that they were held
in the united states specifically in
arizona because they felt they were
treated very well
the c-span school bus has been in
washington d.c this month and each
morning on c-span's washington journal
the school bus has visited landmark
sites around the nation's capitol
wednesday on our last day in washington
the bus visits the supreme court
we now return to further coverage of
today's joint hearing looking at the
1993 raid on the branch davidian
compound in waco texas
okay
[Music]
the oversight committees
on waco will now come to order
i do believe that was our last vote uh
we had these every time these bells go
off we have to do these strange things
about getting up and running we don't
really control the institution it kind
of controls us but we apologize i think
we're here for the duration at this
point
and we thank you for your patience
um eliana ross layton from florida you
have five minutes thank you mr chairman
i'd like to yield my time to mr micah
also florida
mr chairman please proceed thank you mr
chairman and thank you miss ross
leighton
uh the gentleman of the texas rangers uh
i have a definite i'm not an attorney
and i try to sort through this
some of this but
i have the
definition of self-defense i guess under
the texas law the texas penal code and
it says
the use of force to resist an arrest or
search is justified if one
if before the actor offers any
resistance the peace officer uses or
attempts to use greater force than
necessary to make the arrest
or search and two
when and to the degree the actor
reasonably believes the force is
immediately necessary to protect himself
against the peace officer's use
of or attempted use of greater force
than necessary is that basically the law
in texas as you're familiar with it that
is the law yes sir
yes sir
and
i want to ask the gentleman
dr
tabor and doctors arnold
again i have to keep going back to this
report because this is the report that
the department of justice uh asked uh
various religious experts uh
to
look at what happened there and make
recommendations
and they made some conclusions they said
the branch davidians had an apocalyptic
worldview in which they expected attack
from the outside world the reason for
arming themselves was to protect
themselves from an expected attack is is
that a correct issue understand it part
of it was uh business
uh they actually turned several thousand
dollars a year by trading guns and the
other part i guess we could say was at
least claimed to be theological
that was to provide self-defense and so
part of you believe the answer is yes do
you believe dr earl that they believe
this that that
uh and this is also dr
uh
can't uh cancerous i think it is who's
the head of uh nyu medical center the
the head
doctor a psychiatrist there
uh but this was his observation
is that something you'd agree with
dr earl definitely uh they had uh not
only the economic reasons for doing what
they did but but also they definitely
had religious reasons uh in order to
protect themselves when the prophecy
would one day be fulfilled they would be
attacked it was not an attempt to
go on the offensive and go to war
against people but all the prophecies
that they quoted and i have listened to
51 days of the negotiation tapes
almost all of them by now
and uh they were not intending to have
those weapons in order to go to war but
to defend themselves
when they were attacked they did believe
it would happen well
uh this same doctor who's dealt with
probably in new york i imagine every
kind of
strange case you could imagine he said
certainly an armed assault by a hundred
agents had to be seen as an attack
independent of who fired the first shot
and then he goes on and said if in our
if an armed individual enters uh your
home by force and you have reason to
believe that the person
represents a mortal threat you are
allowed to fire a weapon in self-defense
in most states as as
you know i cited the law
uh do you think that this is also a
correct assumption they viewed a hundred
and this is in the first assault with a
hundred you know the cattle cars coming
up etc
the earliest statement we have from
david korish on that is made at
about
two in the morning on krld radio
just after the 28th so you're now to
march first
and the announcer says
david what do you what do you feel about
those four agents that were killed
and david says
my friend it was
unnecessary
he says you don't know us we don't know
you
you came in here
you we have women and children and so he
essentially expressed that self-defense
uh we have the tape and the transcript
if you want it in the record so that was
his view and then he went on to give the
religious side
which is a little more bizarre but it
had to do that at the end of time
you take up a sword rather than lay down
a sword that jesus has told to disciples
my kingdoms not of this world or my
servants would fight that's pacifist but
now my kingdom is not from here now
meaning later it would be so that was
their understanding that you weren't
responding doctor arnold i want to cite
also this report at this report also and
one of the recommendations of the doctor
uh
who was retained for this says it's
important that the training of law
enforcement officials make clear there
are individuals who have deeply held
beliefs that are sincere and not a
screen for criminal activity is
do you believe do you concur with this
uh finding here uh and is is that the
was that the case with uh this situation
that's right the the branch davidians
had religious beliefs that they
sincerely held
they really believed that their
religious beliefs were based upon the
bible
now i don't agree with that you don't
agree with that but that was their
religious faith
and it wasn't just a sort of a vague
ethereal faith
they thought that the bible predicted in
his prophecies all the way from genesis
to revelation
that
the church community there at mount
carmel was to do specific things like
fly the flag that it flew outside build
its uh place the way they were building
it every detail was worked out and so in
on april 13th and negotiation tape
number 217 that dick de garan wanted to
play earlier today david koresh
expresses this idea
that
the last days had come he says in this
tape that he went out on his porch he
said stop there's women and children in
here
and a shot rang out and hit the door on
into the to the right that door he says
kicked
and then he says
if you don't believe me look at the
videotape i know you have that tape he
says i saw you making it across the road
so from the branch davidians point of
view they had been attacked i don't know
i'm just a simple teacher of religion i
don't know what really happened that day
but he says there's a videotape that
will prove it
and he says the door would prove it
of course we hear today that that
videotape is no longer available or
didn't work but david koresh did not
know that he on april 13th
mr chairman i asked unanimous consent
that the tape that he's referring there
to their uh be submitted for the without
objection so order
we now turn to the general lady from
houston texas mrs jackson lee five
minutes
thank you very much mr chairman and
first of all in minding my manners i
want to welcome the texas rangers here
and thank them for their courtesies
and let me uh please allow me to briefly
question you because i have issues
dealing with
uh the religious ocity if you will of
this group and i want to ask some
questions of dr arnold and dr tabor and
um is it taboo
um i want to get you in louisiana and so
um i'm going to
focus some very pointed questions on mr
burns mr cook and i thank you for being
here
there was some questioning at the very
beginning about whining and dining are
you bought and paid for is your
testimony here bought and paid for and
i'm not sure whether you're eating at
mcdonald's or what but you gentlemen
look like you're well endowed strong and
could miss a meal and so food is not an
enticer but are you bought and paid for
your testimony here bought and paid for
by anyone no
i think
i hate to answer that with just to know
i would like to be a little stronger
buddy go right ahead well out of respect
for this panel i i think that i'll just
say no and that's absolutely absurd
peaceful absolutely not and i thank you
for being here
um there are many suggestions of
cover-up and a variety of suggestions
about the texas rangers involvement i
know you from the state of texas as the
state of texas viable law enforcement
entity
um and my concern or would like you to
respond to your ability during this very
tense situation when the hrt team was
around to do a full investigation and
your
very strong effort to do so did that
occur both of you may answer if you do
it briefly for me please did you make
every effort to do a full investigation
even during this very uh difficult time
period
yes we did and of course early on we
were hampered with the
standoff and the considerations we had
to have for the uh tactical
consideration safety of both the hrt and
the people in inside mount carmel we
proceeded
with all due speed as
fast as we could on that once the
standoff had been terminated by the
fire
then we began to
go ahead at a faster speed and
was able to conclude that the initial
part of the investigation by about
may 15 which was the crime scene search
and and the gathering of of all the
physical evidence out there
that investigation went on
right up to the time of the trial on the
10th day of january of 1994 but we did
conduct what i believe is a very
exhaustive and thorough investigation
the investigation has not been
challenged by anybody that i'm aware of
as a matter of fact most of the 17
defense attorneys after the trial uh
publicly said that we've done an
outstanding job on an investigation and
you had limited resources my
understanding to even do this is that my
understanding uh yes we did have limited
resources were you familiar with uh mr
karesh and his followers before this
whole incident occurred
i had never heard of mount carmel or
david corrections before march or
february 28th all right uh mr cook would
you answer the fullness of the
investigation with limited resources yes
ma'am and something probably hadn't been
made clear is that i as the senior
ranger captain is in the commander of
all the texas rangers in texas and with
that my responsibility was to ensure
that captain burns is a site commander
followed the proper procedures and done
what was necessary i had no doubt that
he would do that however i spent a many
a night in waco visiting with him
supporting him
ensuring going to the scene myself and
making sure that everything was followed
and as criminal investigators i think
being from texas you'd agree that the
texas rangers are
well known for their investigative
abilities then i know and i thank you
for that and maybe if my colleagues if
we last here long enough and someone
might have some additional time i'd like
to pursue another line of questioning
but i wanted to make sure
that we were aware of the fact limited
resources got right to the point and
evidenced and preserved evidence that
might not have been preserved without
your presence there and i thank you for
that let me just simply say uh to uh the
two theologians who are experts and i am
not
uh frankly i raise issues at the very
beginning of this hearing that i hope in
the corrective measures we will have
more insight on religions
on sex sect i have to always say that to
make it
clear
frankly i wish this had not happened but
let me probe you to clarify what i think
has been a continued misrepresentation
maybe a branch but not a seventh-day
adventist a hundred and thirty-five
that's all david koresh i think had in
that compound
1844
yes they gathered in the hills of seven
day in venice believing something else
would occur but it was not a violent
setting when nothing occurred they went
back to where they came from
they are pacifists and have been
pacifists for many many years this
gentleman was gathering a whole compound
of arm now what i am trying to separate
is the ability of david koresh and his
musical talent and his charm to convince
people who had been in there for 35
years and he was a johnny come lately
with a mismatch of religious beliefs
that were not even the purity of branch
civilians one the worldwide churches of
millions of people 750 000 in this
country alone
it is a church that gives that
volunteers it has missionaries not david
correct did not give they were confined
in this area and not doing any kind of
charitable effort whatsoever ellen g
white is what the seventh adventist
church believes and they did not they
would not accept her as a prophet
also
the seminary adventist church would not
in the least have a gentleman who was
having sexual contact with children
and so this association with the seventh
adventist church was broken many many
years ago and we should make that very
clear
and this massing of arms is not the
seventh-day adventist church
this was a splinter group and we
recognize that as you understand
religion and i hope you share this with
me as you give me the answer
churches and religions will also tell
you that there are false prophets that
they don't believe in and this may have
been i don't know mr quresh one way or
the other but he may have been this
category this was a distinct and
separate group of individuals
that were mesmerized by mr karash who
was involved in illegal activities do
you have a response to that
although all but
six i believe of the
davidians came from a seventh-day
adventist background i agree with almost
all of your comments
and uh you're correct it was a one-way
relationship that is these people had
exited the seventh-day adventist church
that's their background and gone on to
either branch branch davidian or
koreshian
views
they would claim as all break off groups
i think traditionally do to be
representing the parent body
he quoted sister white constantly as he
called her
and believed he was her successor now to
it did not fully accept to the seven
million seventh-day adventists
uh of course that's an absurdity and
it's like many groups as you know the
mormons have the reorganized as well as
the main parent body
uh it's typical for the break off group
to claim it was first and more original
than the parent group it was this kind
of a fight
so uh from the adventist point of view
the seventh-day adventist point of view
it was a one-way relationship they went
out but were not of us anymore david
would say you went the wrong way you
should have come with us we got 130
uh so it uh
i think the violent end i would like to
expire dr
refer that the violent end was
completely contrast
uh to the teachings of the seventh
adventist church i consider it a
complete separation now maybe cult
training or sex training i don't want to
use the terminology because i know
you've disputed that
certainly is needed but you have to
distinguish what you're working with
time is expired doing so thank you well
if he can ask
no i i think you slipped in an extra
question there i i think
i didn't answer the first question okay
we'll just do it reasonably good time
like yes i also agree as dr tabor does
there's a there's a great difference
between the two and i think the issue of
fighting and not fighting uh is an
important distinction you're making the
one thing i wanted to say let us not
assume though that the members of the
branch davidian uh religious community
were in some way simply
mesmerized or hypnotized
no these people were very educated
intelligent people
who were very very well versed in many
many religious traditions and doctrines
they had studied these things they had
become persuaded because of their study
of history their study of theology their
study of the bible that david koresh was
interpreting the bible correctly
i don't think he was you don't think he
was but they came to that conclusion
based upon their own study of his
teachings they studied and studied and
studied these things and came to the
conclusions they did thank you mr
chairman i know that um we'll also look
into the issue of the question of power
over and i think time has expired okay
if we keep going with this colloquy all
night we could be here we can go the
clock around so i am going to ask you to
be a little bit just a little bit more
uh it would help if when addressing the
the two doctors over here maybe the
panel could say just alternate or
whatever doctor taylor dr arnold so we
don't have to think i think i think
reasonable people could come to a
reasonable conclusion that let's use a
little common sense and i think it'll
get just work out just fine we always
try to let the question be answered but
when we start doing a little
dissertation back and forth that's when
we're going to stop the common sense and
we're going to say no i mean that's the
way it's got to be okay so if everybody
would work with us would try to get down
the report
the gentleman had not been able to
answer my last question but i do
appreciate your comment should we have a
little discussion about this uh do you
want to say something
thank you regular order let's go
um
i would like to
address my questions mr burns and um
before i do
i just like to say that i recognize that
the texas rangers are only second to
scotland yard in terms of longevity you
certainly have our deepest respect and
we thank you for coming here
thank you and
we
i guess just a couple questions
can you confirm that the fbi
in any way uh i know bill johnson talked
about this or wrote about it changed or
destroyed evidence at the crime scene
did did they change or destroy evidence
at the crime scene right
as you went in in your investigative
approach and the responsibilities that
you had to perform did you see
the fbi
changing the crime scene in any way
moving things around
things that were not normal according to
your
procedures established
yes sir as i i'd said earlier and didn't
get to finish the answer
they were moving the vehicles
which
destroyed valuable trajectory evidence
and in the end it turned out it wasn't
didn't matter because the but it didn't
seem to be standard
operating procedure according to what
you understand
was it i'm sorry i'd say when you see
that happening is you don't you don't
consider that standard operating
procedure certainly not in any crime
scene i've ever been on no
and were they as you worked with mr
jabar and and worked with the fbi did
you find them
pretty cooperative and
respected of your input
no sir
could you elaborate
i'm sorry could you tell us what you
just elaborate on that just tell me a
little bit what you mean by that as i
said earlier we
we had very little contact with them or
input
early on
the fbi
when they they run an operation they run
it and there's not you don't work with
them you work for them or you don't you
don't get along
but
it deteriorated to the point if if i
went over there uh the door was always
close to the where mr jamar was uh
several times i waited half hour 45
minutes to see him never saw him i
finally quit going over there
the uh we couldn't even get a phone call
through it was total lack of
communication uh we were not able to
urge any of our concerns
we had
voice concerns about what they were
doing to the outside of the crime scene
and we're told that they might have to
move the vehicles before they did they
would let us urge our concerns we'd
discuss it that did not happen
which was a very
uh
devastating thing i thought to us
do you consider this a pretty serious
situation i did yes uh and as i said mr
johnston considered considered it so
serious that i believe he literally
jeopardized his career with the u.s
attorney's office by writing that letter
to janet reno but but doing the right
thing oh yeah yeah and isn't this what
we're all about and trying to do the
right thing here yes sir and isn't the
criticism you kind of you get what's
your reaction to the criticism that
we're all trying to do this to be
anti-law enforcement and
these hearings are you know i mean
do you think that that's the case do you
think we're really trying to get at the
truth no sir i don't believe that that
these hearings are meant to be anti-law
enforcement uh
i think that some of the questions that
are asked you know were uh maybe not uh
what i'd want to be asking i've been
asked one or two i didn't want to be
asked here and didn't think they were
quite proper but that's that's
everybody's
privilege and i don't i don't argue with
that yeah i think they're anti-law
enforcement did you feel that the
situation relative to waco was properly
put to bed
by the internal investigations by by
both treasury and justice i mean it was
those two big books i mean did that do
it all or was there anything else that
came out after the fact that was it
properly just laid to rest we just tell
american people look this is an internal
investigation that's good enough or do
you think we really needed to go further
well i haven't seen the justice report i
have read the treasury report
it was uh i think quite
quite lengthy and exhaustive and covered
a lot of items but
i do believe
in just talking to people in texas there
are a lot of questions in the american
public about this and uh i think that it
does
cast doubt on all of law enforcement not
just federal society until we get the
questions answered to that end we need
uh to clear the air so to speak and i i
don't disagree with that at all mr potts
uh and and other folks uh did you get
the feeling that mr jamar was making all
the decisions on the ground there or he
was taking orders from
who
my my experience was that he was in
total command down there now what his uh
uh
my experience with the fbi is that that
normally they keep lying open washington
when they do anything so but that's
been my past experience with them on any
kind of a significant operation
that control is normally
exercised out of washington to a large
degree i believe so it's run out of
washington that's that's my
understanding i cannot say would that
indicate the reason why that on the 14th
i believe the earlier testimony today
that
he indicated to
the two attorneys that they had all the
time in the world and it would have
worked i mean there was no big rush and
then all of a sudden we had this plan to
move in on the 19th
i believe that could be one explanation
for it i certainly had no
input and very little communication then
although i had more than that i'd had
before
do you think let me ask both of you a
question to kind of think through
i i just have a feeling in my stomach
that i'm trying to figure out
where all this thing goes and who who
ultimately made a decision
prior to april 19th that that's that led
to this tragedy
and uh
do you get the funny feeling i don't
know maybe the texas ranger you might
want to mention this that i mean who's
responsible if you screw up
does the buck stop with mr cook or does
it i mean where where does it go all the
way up the line and the same thing with
the fbi and the same thing with atf
um
and and this tragedy do you feel and i
give both of you a chance just talk
about your frustrations talk about the
challenge that you
and what you walked away from this
incident because you're
you go anywhere in the country they're
going to ask you about this tell me what
your what were your problems what were
your challenges and where do you want to
see us where do you want us and
ultimately end up on this thing
of course our our problems as i've
already kind of gone over was the fact
that initially we had competing
interests down and we had the standoff
that had to be resolved before we could
proceed with that crime scene and do the
investigation once that was over
then of course we were left with a
situation that nobody in law enforcement
has ever
faced before
and i'd like to say that we did get
100 cooperation from the fbi laboratory
and support people
from april 19 on uh there's i can't say
enough good about them
we had a lot of help from other dps
people
so it was a joint effort
of course it was a very frustrating
investigation because
the crime scene had been totally
destroyed
as far as structurally
first of all we had the tanks running
around outside and moving uh vehicles
and things and then uh
initially on the 19th we see the tanks
uh you know
destroying
some degree the structure and then the
fire that totally destroyed that
structure so
we had been
making a a plan for 51 days down there
to go in and
number one get 100 live bodies out of
there
and do whatever we were going to do
whatever that
degree of culpability we could establish
there and do that do that but then to go
in there and and do a crime scene search
in a structure
and these plans you know no pun intended
literally went up smoke on the 19th so
we had to go back to square one and it
was
you know very
very depressing
i can remember sitting there in the fbi
command post forward command post on the
closed circuit tv cameras watching that
fire and thinking okay you know start
coming out you know you got to start
coming out of there and then pretty soon
we had about a 35 mile an hour wind that
day down there
and uh i realized real quick
they weren't going to come out it's all
over mr cook
well let me say i took also
uh captain burns's uh
information seriously about the
cooperation level that we were getting
to the point that i took the letter that
bill johnson wrote and i
got it to our governor
i gave it to our security guy that
was able to put in her reading and he i
had a personal note on there to her
explaining what our frustrations were
she called me
told me that she read the letter with
interest
considered the concerns
and gave me a telephone number in the
white house and said if you have any
additional trouble you need to contact
this number people have your name it's a
24 hour number
uh
the next day or the day after we were
scheduled to have a meeting
with a group of
people out of washington i think some of
the higher up fbi
uh and some different people and she
told me basically who was going to be in
the meeting and so forth and to
that thing should get better
uh gave me some assurances that they
would get better i have to say they did
get better i think
probably midway through i believe
captain burns will also say this that we
tend to be included more than we had
prior to that
you ask about authority and
i think that
the responsibility ends with the top
level that's the reason i went to waco
after i worked my day in austin i drove
90 miles a minute a day
not every day but almost every day
and i can pass on authority but i can't
pass on responsibility the director of
the agency who is my boss also went to
waco on a number of occasions we both
knew that our careers were on the line
also so we went there to make sure
what can we learn from these mistakes i
think that that's what law enforcement
training is predicated on is our
mistakes we're children and we fall down
we learn if we fall down we're going to
get hurt
we learn to walk
and sometimes in law enforcement we have
to fall a few times before we learn how
to walk correctly i would hope that this
would develop a better line of
communications with local law
enforcement and if there's no reason not
to trust the local law enforcement i
think that at that point maybe the
federal agencies should include the
locals a little bit more especially when
we have a
vested interest in the outcome however
we agree that the responsibility
for that hostage or seed situation or
whatever you want to call it
that that was the responsibility of the
fbi and we didn't intend to interfere
with that thank you very much
mr taylor you're recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman i have a series of
questions and since we only have five
minutes i've been asked five minutes
with questions and y'all can answer
midwill
i'd want to start this with the rangers
i've always i have a great reputation
much like mississippi highway patrol
would a brave man hide behind children
old women old men
true or false
well is your mic on i'll say okay mr
chairman i want to open this up with the
rangers you know we've heard about david
koresh he said he was a messiah he said
he was there to uh
taking christ's place in effect
would a brave man hide behind children
would he hide behind women and old men
well i think that kind of goes without
even answering and to say
the obvious is that no
i think bravery has a much more profound
meaning than to do that
if
is it the opinion of i want to ask the
theologians
i haven't seen everything you've seen
where parents gave their 11 and 10 year
old children to crash
for him to sexually exploit
gave their wives to crash gave
everything their own correct
if crash had told his followers to walk
out
after the first raid if he'd said walk
out
but they have done so
they've given him the most precious
things they have yeah they couldn't get
him to walk across the field
could i say first uh uh the premise of
the question that he gave these are
until uh kerry jewell testified on
wednesday to my knowledge there was no
sworn testimony
uh we had newspaper reports uh media
reports if i may interrupt this paper
yeah i'm sorry i've done it
that young lady
when given to her mother in shared
custody
i'm talking about her only under the
condition that you go nowhere near david
koresh my position is that unless
something's established legally that we
can't say a lot about it we can suspect
things and so i didn't accept the
premise i i think most of us are
persuaded that these things are true i'm
just saying they've been talked about
not established uh by testimony but but
the uh that was the premise the question
was what if he told him to come out
would they come out
i think he would have to couple it with
an explanation from scripture now if he
was capable of coming up with that i
think
they would have but uh in listening to
the
250 hours of negotiation tapes you begin
to see
that what he does is always persuade
them from scripture he doesn't just say
i am the dictator you now walk out at my
command that wasn't the style it would
be let's go to the book of habakkuk
let's go to the book of nahum is this
what god requires us to do that was more
of a yes or no question
well that the answer is with scripture
they would but ordered no sorry
and i want to turn back to the
gentleman from the texas rangers
we have seen in the case of hussein
sometimes right now in the bosnian serbs
the atrocious use of other human beings
is human shields
isn't it accurate to say that koresh
kept those children those old men and
those old women around as human shields
i mean after all i'm going to turn back
to the theologians
christ knew
according to the bible that his end was
near
christ told if i'm not mistaken judas do
what you have to do
he didn't grab the apostles around him
and say bring me a bunch of children to
surround me
if quresh was really christ-like don't
you think
he would have done what christ did
the truth of the matter is the man was
nowhere near christ like he was a coward
there's a coward who hid behind children
old men and old women who could have
told them to left that he didn't
because he was a coward
and it just absolutely drives me crazy
that this committee has spent now five
days
trying to paint the bad guys as the good
guys and the law enforcement community
of this country is the bad guys
they won't even allow the people who
wrote the series the central messiah the
opportunity come talk before this
committee won't allow the lady who says
she was held for three months against
her will to come talk to this committee
a person who said the crash had a hit
list
come talk to this committee mr mcclure i
know there's something that you've been
waiting to say please when the time i
have left me saying
mr taylor i've
trained negotiators from alaska all the
way to the southern tip of florida and
from several foreign countries
when you go back to negotiations basics
101 there's two areas that you stay away
from
in negotiations
one is religion
and the other is politics do you know of
a single instance
do you know of a single instance where
an outside negotiator prevented
solved a problem
we keep hearing if they just
turned to some outside negotiator that
everything would have been we're not
negotiators sir and never claimed to be
do you know of a single instance
that is your job with the
atlanta police department retired from
atlanta police and present league
commander of criminal investigation with
douglas county sheriff's office
[Music]
do you know one yes or no no sir i don't
thank you sir
i have promised to ask every panel the
same question
thus far
and the question is if you know of
anything have you heard of anything have
you seen anything
that would justify the killing of four
atf agents the wounding of twenty more
by david questions followers let me say
that the only person who said yes
when i asked him specifically which one
of the law enforcement officers
whether it's mr
robert williams
or conway le view
or stephen williams
or todd behan
he couldn't name it one that he said
should have been killed
but one of the defense attorneys one of
the criminal defense attorneys said they
should have been killed
do any of you think that the atf agents
were murdered justifiably
sir you are bringing up a question that
was discussed this morning at great
length
and as i i'm no lawyer and i don't
understand the legal matters of all
these technicalities of what murder is
or what my involuntary manslaughter is
but the discussion this morning by dicta
garrett and jack zimmerman made the
point that they were found innocent of
murder
now you're saying
is there was there murder justified
i don't think that anyone should be
killed i think what happened was wrong i
think that it was completely unnecessary
that anybody died those agents i weep
for them that they were killed and the
davidians who were inside
and but i don't know what happened that
day i was not there it's a sad day and
it was unnecessary you know take that as
a no
you take what is a no your answer sir
but no to what question exactly
can you think of any reason
for those people to have died at the
hands of david koresh
i can't think of any reason that would
justify people being killed there unless
there was an aggressive attempt to
assassinate
david koresh and i know of no evidence
for that thank you sir
i don't think the deaths on either side
were justified
i would include the six that were also
killed on the other side and as well as
the four
as well as those wounded judy snyder was
shot while nursing her baby through the
chest
so
you know she showed it on the video
showed her thumb showed her wounds
uh
that's certainly unnecessary all of the
uh wounding and killing was unnecessary
mr cook
well let me say that if i should die
in the future executing a lawful search
warrant i would hope that this committee
took that issue up they would think that
it was not justified in someone killing
me for doing what the state expects me
to do or the united states government
expects me to do
having said that sir do you think
have you heard or seen or read anything
that justifies the murder of the poor
atf agents no
no i do not thank you sir mr burns no
sir i have seen nothing uh everything
quite the contrary there was no
justification for what they did
the davidians did
thank you mr mcclure i don't see any
justification whatsoever mr taylor
thank you very much thank you for
bearing with me mr chairman
okay
uh we have a nice day
uh five minutes thank you mr chairman
uh there was some discussion previously
and i forget which one of
the rangers referred to it the letter
from
assistant united states attorney bill
johnston to the attorney general
uh was at the letter dated march 23rd of
93
i believe that's not mr barr
martin that's right i believe i've got a
copy of you here okay that's more yeah
march 23rd
like unanimous consent if we could have
that included in the record at the end
without objection so ordered thank you
that is correct that's a date okay thank
you
i do have a couple of questions for the
two rangers but before i do that i'd
like to extend welcome from as a
representative of the seventh district
from mr frank mcclure who is uh from the
seventh district of georgia it's an
honor to have you here frank thank you
thank you very much um
it uh
with regard to to the the hierarchy in
the chain of command uh mr cook perhaps
you'd be in the best position to answer
this who did the texas rangers report to
i report to the director of the texas
department of public safety and that
person reports to the governor no sir he
reports to a three-person commission and
that commission is appointed by the
governor at staggered terms so we don't
directly report to the governor
okay is one of the primary duties of the
rangers to conduct criminal
investigations
it is okay uh is uh what is the point to
or the goal of conducting one of those
investigations would it be fair to say
it's it's a search for the truth and to
obtain
uh evidence objectively
absolutely okay
uh during the course of your
investigations is a standard procedure
for somebody
at a higher level than the rangers that
you've identified to direct your
investigation cease
well there hasn't been anything
usual about this particular
investigation as far as the rangers
working so i'm not talking about this
particular investigation i'm talking in
general terms
unusual yes but not unheard of okay
would it be unusual to receive a
directive that says stop interviewing
uh
witnesses uh because they they may be uh
developing exculpatory evidence
well i think if you said that that was a
reason for stopping
the developing exculpatory information i
think you'd have to look a little
further to make sure that's exactly what
the intent of that directive would be it
would raise a question in your mind that
would have to be explored a little
further
well exculpatory evidence is something
that we develop from time to time when
we do an investigation you know there's
a certain amount of exculpatory evidence
in any investigation absolutely
uh should whether or not an
investigation though proceeds forward
say an early stage
be determined simply because it may
churn up or turn up exculpatory evidence
should that be the reason an
investigation proceeds forward or not
well i think first of all as an
investigator i have a responsibility to
develop and report excuvatory
information if for no other reason to
get the prosecutor advised to what it
lays in weight out there so i would
think that that would be a necessary
step to investigate that but keep in
mind in the context of i think this
letter we heard some of the earlier
testimony
in
investigations in our own agency we have
some of our administrative
investigations stand down until we get
our criminal investigation done because
because they can take our reports and
use them in the administrative
investigation which usually serves a
purpose
but we can't take necessarily theirs
because there's there's certain rights
that go along with employees that we
interview if there's
if we can force them to give us a
statement of the civil process or under
the administrative process where we
can't do that on the criminal if if if
such a a directive came down if there
were
the sort of situation that you've
described where there might be an
administrative proceeding as well as a
criminal investigating investigation
proceeding
would that directive indicate that the
reason for requesting that you stand
down on one investigation be temporarily
to allow another to proceed forward for
example
yes or that that would be the reason
okay uh simply receiving a directive to
to stop
uh so that no further evidence is is
accumulated that would be would that be
unusual
well i don't know it'd be unusual i
think that
these type of investigations are unusual
first of all so we don't have these are
not a common investigation where you
have a personnel interest or a
administrative interest as well as a
criminal interest okay maybe i
misunderstood i i thought that the range
has conducted a a wide range and a large
number of of investigations each year is
that not true
outside this investigation yes i'm not
talking at all about this investigation
the only administrative investigations
that we conduct are on our own personnel
on the texas rangers themselves as far
as outside the department or in the
department that is usually handled by
our internal affairs or someone else but
we do conduct criminal investigations
that involve our own personnel in our
agency okay that's what i'm really
talking about is a criminal
investigation
would it be unusual to receive a
directive that a criminal investigation
stopped
simply because it may develop evidence
and might be exculpatory down the road
well i can say that i never received
such a directive okay and and and
and how many criminal investigations
have you participated would you hazard a
guess
well i don't know that hazard to guess
i've been in law enforcement 30 years
and i've been a texas ranger for 21
where i primarily investigate offenses
so i've investigated hundreds okay let
me ask you very briefly uh mr cook about
another area and that is uh the media
do the rangers have guidelines
concerning contacts with the media in
ongoing investigations particularly
undercover investigations
spell out very clearly that the
circumstances under which statements may
be made to the media prior to an
investigation going down
prior to the investigation going down it
is discretionary with the
personnel involved in the investigation
once the investigation or once charges
are filed
now in the case where charges are filed
we defer all news inquiries to the
prosecutor simply because we don't want
to jeopardize the case right but prior
but prior to that would one of the would
one of the determining factors uh for
example be
uh the risk of disclosing an undercover
uh investigation prematurely
to answer your question we we very
seldom
in fact we have a no uh comment press
comment and we do not interact with the
press with regard to our criminal
investigations
uh
that i can recall uh we just don't do it
is that basically in your interview a
pretty sound law enforcement policy
it's not a it
it's a it's a policy that's presently in
in drafting stage because i'm putting it
in writing prior to that we've had a a
verbal policy
that we restrict contact with the media
except where we have to make contact
we don't go out and if you've noticed
we've never been on top cops we're not
on any of these shows we stay out of the
media as much as we can
we would not advance notice
the media that we were going to do a
raid if that's what you're asking that
that is what i'm asking i thank you mr
cook
you wanna you wanna pass
okay
by prior arrangement we're gonna pass on
on this side um i'm gonna yield now to
mr boyer
five minutes
thank you mr chairman dr arnold dr tabor
were either of you uh interviewed by atf
or treasury with regard to their reports
no we weren't
no no not at all
i think it perhaps is a little
outrageous for mr conyers to have said
today is some some purpose to try to
rehabilitate koresh that is pretty uh
an outrageous uh comment
because i think what i'm getting out of
today is we're hearing from witnesses
whereby they're not in this the
administration likes to stand by this as
though it is the complete record and
we're finding out that it is not
um we're discovering that uh perhaps
there were
uh and hopefully we can get into it
between tensions between the the texas
rangers in the in the fbi
uh first of all before i get into that
type of thing
let me say uh extreme compliment not
only to your heritage of texas rangers
uh but also to the magnificent job you
continue to do
extend that confident gentleman thanks
for for coming up here
um of course it's easy for me having
having been not only a prosecution and
defense i it's just inquisitive to me to
say why would treasury have brought you
up here and whined and dined you if in
fact they were so worried about some
things
it's amazing it's that coaching process
uh right guys
well i think it's it's good intelligence
to be able to come out before you yeah i
hear you i hear you good uh you're also
very tactful as a ranger thank you let
me um also say that i think what is what
has also been obvious is there's a
tremendous disconnect
a disconnect between those who are on
the ground who are the operators and the
negotiators
and that of the politicos
in washington
the politicos in washington that are
captured by the do something mentality
we have to do something we have to do
something and you know it's easy to look
at waco in a vacuum but we also have to
remember what was going on in the
dynamics of the politics at the time in
the early 1993
uh about the administration in turmoil
and domestic policies and foreign
policies and trying to
you know catch traction and they
couldn't catch traction a lot of things
that were going on a lot of people can
uh can remember
the the uh one thing that in fact has
bothered me though
uh is that we heard testimony today
uh from the two defense lawyers uh who
were also part of the negotiations about
a deal
about the deal and and and mr koresha's
mental state it's about whether it was a
deal or wasn't a deal
and and my question to you dr tabor
you've listened over 250 hours of these
tapes
uh um
it appears to me by some of the
transcript here of these tapes that
david crash was pretty convinced that if
he could be permitted to finish writing
the seals that he was going to
participate in the surrender and that
there was a change in mental frame of
mind and people on the ground knew and
believe and i think it's quite obvious
the defense lawyers felt they got used
in the process because
perhaps the politicos in washington they
were going to do something
and not really yield to those on the
ground who are actually trying to move
towards a peaceful settlement
and so this disconnect in the
communications is very bothersome to me
and before i ask this this final
question the other thing that's
bothersome to me was you know we have
the two defense lawyers discuss about
the deal and their mental aspects of the
deal and then we have uh the gentleman
um
who was it it's the i guess i want to
call it part of the damage control team
uh richard scruggs assistant attorney
general has to run and get on pbs to say
there was no deal there was no deal
there was no deal if i see the gentleman
sitting right there behind you uh that
that's pretty amazing would you please
dr tabor
bring us
up you know you're listening in your
opinion about those five days in the
mental state of mr karesh on whether
there was a deal or wasn't a deal
obviously i wasn't there i'm going by
the tapes that's what i meant basically
there were three things there was a
signed letter that david sent out with
his legal papers that he considered to
be a legal
surrender
offer or plan doesn't give the details
of when but had to do it the manuscript
but you've got to go back a little we
might not do it on this question
understand why that was a breakthrough
he's responding directly to what we had
suggested to him when the fbi allowed
material to go in on the last day that
the lawyers went in april for sunday
before passover this is a direct
response to that we can explain that
later the other thing is listening to
the tapes
you can exactly see the mental state of
the people inside it's buoyant david
says did you take a shower for me dick
yeah i took a couple they're talking
about coming out they're excited about
it and finally interviewing the
survivors i spent a month with david
thibodeau in israel
trying to help him through the grief
process
introducing him to people over there
that i knew trying to get his mind off
waco
we talked many many hours he said we
were so
joyful that weekend
because we
knew we were coming out that finally
david had got his word of how to do this
legally the lawyers and theologically in
terms of his system so that's the
evidence the evidence is uh in the tapes
i would urge
all of you who have time to listen to
the last five days it's very clear but
when you have what i said the disconnect
is when you have those operators on the
ground the negotiator is actually saying
you know we've got a deal the mental
state here of mr crush that he's going
to write these things and we're going to
move out but yet in april 14th we're
going to get into this next couple of
days about the meetings that with the
attorney general uh about you know how
are we going to move in and we're going
to do something by golly and we're going
to we're going to move in and we have
this huge meeting and what discussions
then were related to the president we
don't know we'll have to see and the
president wants to use executive
executive privilege on stuff he can do
that and we can talk about that janet
reno kept asking is there an argument
for waiting give me an argument for
waiting one of the things that we would
like to know i would like to know i'm
sure you would like to know was she
given this argument for waiting i know
she was shown
something about the letters that we can
explore in a further question but was
she given the argument that i just gave
you
to the texas rangers as i understand
there were three surrender scenarios and
there was some indication that koresh
would have surrendered to the texas
rangers and not the fbi would you
comment on these three surrender
scenarios and whether or not that
indication was true or not thank you
to my knowledge there was never an offer
by the uh davidians to surrender to the
rangers
there was some some conjecture at one
time early on
uh that that they might do that uh
captain bobby prince and i who was
involved in that at that time
went to see mr jamar
and offered
a ranger
to help negotiations if that would be
helpful not one not one of the captains
but one of the rangers that had been
trained most of them by fbi uh he
thanked us for that offer and we never
heard anything else about it
the
later on
captain cook and i met with
mr zimmerman and mr de guerin
and mr guerin talked about
them surrendering to the rangers
the
captain cook told them that that would
have to go through the fbi because they
were in in command there it was their
deal that we would not approach them uh
that they would have to in other words
approach us uh that before that went
from there i don't know we had one
meeting i was there i think captain cook
can talk about some other conversations
mr guerin
after the
the fire and we got into the
investigation we were listening to the
uh the rangers that were listening to
the negotiation tapes for
uh
inculcatory or
criminal type information
uh
one time i was called in to listen to a
excerpt of the state tape i believe on
about march 12 with steve snyder
where he's talking to the fbi and the
negotiator tells him that the ranger's
going to be doing investigation
and he in fact interrupts the
negotiator and says i'd like to talk to
one of them sometime the negotiator goes
on to finish his statement and snyder
comes back and says what would be the
chances of me talking to a ranger
uh and he goes through then the
negotiator talks to him about well we'd
have to clear with the bosses here and
in washington and and in a scenario and
it's passed over so that
if that's what you're you're talking
about that's what i know about it but as
far as a formal
offer or declaration from the biddings
that they would surrender to us to my
knowledge that was never made
gentlemen's time has expired
mr scott from virginia is recognized for
five minutes thank you mr chairman the
gentleman from texas is a member of the
governmental reform and oversight
committee and would like to participate
and obviously can't so i'll yield my
five minutes to him he's been a member
of the texas was a member of the texas
legislature prior to coming to congress
and i'm delighted yelled my full time to
him thank you and and uh thank my
colleague from virginia he also served
many years in the virginia legislature
and in fact in the senate so
i appreciate this courteousness let me
first say that obviously captain cook
you know from all the years is
growing up in texas and we have a lot of
pride in the tradition
of the texas rangers but no one's always
perfect obviously but uh and i think
today a lot of our colleagues are
recognizing that and there's high
expectations
today
you know for the rangers being here let
me first say and this is not necessarily
for the for the panelists but uh my
colleague mr boyer has made some
allegations here concerning uh whether
the
the mark of the new administration and
does if there's any shred of evidence
that the president or the administration
was involved i would hope that
if they haven't called a witness it
would say that that we would
maybe we could call other witnesses in
the 90 or more than we have but let me
remind my colleagues that in march of 93
we had a new administration in fact i
think the president would probably love
to go back to those poll numbers he had
in march of 93 in april of 93 instead of
what he's seeing today so whether they
uh they needed a success or not in in
waco considering what was happening in
new york with the uh uh with the world
trade center bombing i i would hope that
we would look at fact finding instead of
making political allegations let me get
down to the questions now and i think
i've learned something from these days
the hearings one is that and captain
cook if you can
that the fbi and the atf did not
associate local law enforcement
you offered the deputy sheriff's office
and
and the fbi takes takes it over and they
don't bring anyone in
do you think we ought to try and change
the law that unless there's allegations
of local corruption that that we would
require a federal agency to associate
and bring in local law enforcement in
this case obviously the texas rangers or
maybe the the deputy sheriff because
there are allegations of of child abuse
it's a violation of texas law may not be
federal law and so uh maybe we should
require that do you think that would be
uh something we should look at
well i think there's certainly room for
federal law enforcement as well as state
law enforcement
i think that
this congress should give a lot of
consideration not to make it a national
police force and invest in all of the
power in one entity in the federal
government such as the fbi
as far as the atf uh
quite honestly we work real close with
atf because they have a lot of people
that have a lot of local law enforcement
influence in their agents and we have a
a pretty strong bond with atf
this doesn't change the outcome of our
investigation of course but but i would
have to say that at all fairness to to
that okay
so
you know you don't you think we should
because again if you're concerned as a
national police agency like the fbi if
we require them to
to bring in whenever there's something
particularly if there's a violation of
local law in this case in waco i think
when you have a shared interest yes i
think that somehow i know there should
be a a shared
understanding there because the local
agencies have an interest and a vested
interest in what's going on in their
community
but i don't know how you get that done
in a way because there's different
levels of uh trust there's different
levels of violations there's different
levels of lots of things and and just
like in this case the fbi was the proper
person to handle
the
uh
the
siege part of it because they're better
equipped they've got more personnel
power
they've got more equipment they've got
sophisticated stuff
you know probably one flight of the
airplane would probably
eat up our budget so
i can understand that let me you
mentioned earlier and some questions of
concerning
your service of a search warrant or
arrest warrant
in a in a similar situation that
you're charged like the atf on federal
level or all law enforcement to serve an
arrest or search warrant
if you could and again we're all monday
morning quarterbacking here how would
the texas rangers do it differently
knowing what you know
about mr koresh and you had a
a search warrant an arrest warrant for
that location that individual
i was afraid we was going to get asked
that question
that is a difficult question i want to
still be your friend ken okay thank you
and i do yours but
that's a difficult question to answer
because
we
train different we think different a lot
of times and
even though we have the same overall
objective of of
executing the search warrant i'm not
sure that i have and this is kind of a
cop-out but i have all the details
available to me even though i know a lot
of things i've heard in the committee
and so forth to make that assessment i i
i would tell you first of all probably
today with a lot less people just
because that's the way we do
uh and we might have those resources and
quite honestly we might have even
knowing all the weapons were in there we
might have gone up knocked on the door i
don't know that we would have done that
i think that that's the reason i have
captains it's the reason we have
lieutenants we would have got together
we would have discussed it in all
probability we would have discussed it
with even people who wasn't even
assigned to the to the task force or to
the search warrant uh david mike can
shed some light on that
burns if you could mr green what i think
he said was he'd send me to the door
that's right
that's what
captains and lieutenants are for uh i
saw them folks
now ranger captains are designed to lead
and quite honestly i find it real
difficult not to get personally involved
in lots of things but i
accept my administrative responsibility
our first panelist we had was an author
who has well known us in texas
dick rivas who in the jacket of his book
and i have to admit i haven't had a
chance to read his book but it says mr
rivas points out that the government had
little reason to investigate uh koresh
even less to raid the compound at mount
carmel do you feel like that the federal
government had reason to investigate mr
and because of the information you know
that uh
any other law enforcement agent other
than the fbi or atf would have
investigated him and also um
had reason to arrest him absolutely and
i would say to this committee that i am
somewhat embarrassed that the texas
rangers even though we are a small group
and we don't know of all the crimes
going on in texas i'm somewhat
embarrassed that we were not aware of
what was going on in the compound
because i personally don't think that we
would have tolerated it any more than
anyone else and for that reason you know
i i i feel bad that we did not have an
opportunity to put a stop to it
mr chairman i won't ask a question but
let me just remind the panel of the old
saying in texas is that instead of
having 90 agents there was only one
mount carmel we might have only needed
one ranger to take care of it
thank you very much time has expired
now the chair yields to mr cobalt from
north carolina for five minutes i thank
the chairman uh
i just came back from a supper meeting
it's still supper to be not dinner
and many people have portrayed these
hearings as democrats versus republicans
which i think is very unfortunate but
since some people insist upon doing that
i just met with a democrat former
elected official
in the south
ardent democrat
and i told him where i was going and he
said to me when i saw it on tv
almost two years ago
he said i said to my wife betty
have the federal agents lost their minds
that was his instinctive response and
then he went on to elaborate inserting
gas
for their women and children
and i thought i would share that with
the committee it happened about an hour
ago hour and a half ago
mr cook as you pointed out
you stumble
you try to find out what caused you to
stumble not do it again
and that's the purpose of these hearings
find out what went wrong and then
correct it i just said to my friend from
maryland i said i've never met a texas
ranger before today
but i think i would like most of you
now
walker
texas rangers a little too smooth for me
sometimes
you boys are a little closer to the
ground
good good to have you all
and that's a compliment well i
appreciate you making that observation
hey thank you for that uh description
that doubt home good to have you all
here and speaking of down home i want to
welcome dr tabor he does not live in my
district he does live in my state
dr taylor i'm sure many people say to
authors oh i'm going to read your book
the next four or five days
dr tabor i will read this book
prior to the year's end
but but before this year ends i will
have read why waco
i want to pick up appreciate the
gentleman from from mississippi his
questioning to you to the two religious
experts
i am not uncomfortable
strike that
i am comfortable
being a presbyterian
i probably would not have been
comfortable at mount carmel different
strokes different folks
but one feature that
doesn't that escapes me and see if you
fellas can bring me in tow
or get me in tow i'm a pretty
broad-minded guy
but i cannot square anyone
accepting the fact that his wife
and his daughter
should be
surrendered to anybody
there obviously must have been
a scriptural foundation for that because
as we've heard today and and prior to
today
these many of these folks were
intelligent sound people
illuminate for me
well why don't i say a couple of words
about it and i like dr taber uh enlarge
upon it uh briefly uh just right to the
point
david koresh interpreted psalms 45
that
as a messianic prophecy that in the last
days
a
prophet-like figure would come
to whom many many
wives would attach themselves
and he took a verse out of first
corinthians where the apostle paul
writes
that those of you who have wives be as
though you have none so there were two
or three passages that he used in his
own way
believing that he had somehow been given
this revelation of what those verses
meant
and he was able to uh exercise that
there at mount carmel my point is there
were religious reasons for his actions
as disgusting as they are to us
what i would say on that is
it's covered in the book
there's a whole section on that but my
concern in these hearings and uh in this
testimony
is to say what could have been done
to get them out
irregardless of of these practices that
i think
just about all of us would find uh
bizarre if not absolutely immoral
and so uh it's not sidestepping the
issue because we need to understand what
was going on inside when you come down
to it it comes down to a question of not
how he behaved
and justified it scripturally i think
it's interesting that's why i have to
cover it in a conference a book on waco
but when the government confronts such a
group
even if the leader is totally evil
by by any normal standard
what are the procedures for dealing with
such a person so that would be my
answer but the details are are in the
book i'm glad you're going to read and i
look forward to reading that doctor but
and and gentlemen i i i must
declare uh consistency with you
i don't care how evil
or how despicable it was within
and it from what i can gather it
probably was
it goes back to what my friends said
tonight
have they lost their minds
retrospect 2020 hindsight i will admit
but
bad things happened at waco both inside
and outside
doctor did you want to be heard again
i wanted to make one comment as an
example of a problem uh that i think
needs to be solved
relative to your uh issue your subject
i believe it was yesterday when some atf
agents were testifying
it was amazing to me to hear
uh the honorable agent uh uh was it
rodriquez correct uh robert uh make the
statement
that
he
communicated
the teachings of david koresh
to his leaders
and one of those leaders i'm sure it's
on the record
was asked the question whether or not he
understood
that the branch davidians were expecting
to be attacked
in their prophetic interpretations that
is
did their did he understand their
prophetic interpretations represented
that they would be attacked someday
and the answer i thought was going to be
no we didn't know they were thinking
that or we wouldn't have done that
because that would have been
self-fulfilling
his answer was yes i knew that
because robert had communicated that to
us
that's what we want to help
stop ever happening again with law
enforcement
if a religious group has an
understanding
of prophecy some kind of religious
position that it's taken you've got to
factor that into your law enforcement
activity
or else catastrophe looms on the horizon
why didn't atf go to an expert in
religion and say we've got this preacher
out here what is he up to what would
happen
if we pull up with 80 men and point
shotguns at them
doctor that ever present red light
illuminates i will withdrawal thank you
mr chairman
all right thank you
uh mr schiff from arizona for five
minutes
well mr chairman texas has always
claimed us on one end and i suppose
arizona does it the other but new mexico
is right right in mexico i thank your
pardon
captain burns very briefly you made
reference to uh sometimes i'm asked not
the questions i want to be asked
there's a particular question about this
you want to be asked
no i said i was asking questions i
didn't particularly like to be asked
um
mr uh
um
captain cook you said that mr bill
johnson wrote a letter to the attorney
general would you say again who mr bill
johnson was
yes he was a united states attorney that
was there in waco in the waco office and
substantively quickly what did he say to
the attorney general in that letter
well he was basically having problems uh
he felt like her that the whole
operation had problems with the
acting uh
uh united states attorney in san antonio
that was the that was his boss
and also that there were some other
problems with just coordination in there
with the fbi
so it did point out some of the problems
that we were having and did you see that
letter
yes sir i have been here in front of you
agree do you agree with its content yes
sir i do
uh if mr chairman i ask unanimous
consent the letter be in the record if
that wasn't done earlier without
objection so ordered
mr chairman i'm going to yield in a
moment but i'd like to just say before i
do
that i've heard witnesses ask over and
over again if anything justified the
death of four atf agents on february
28th
and i want to make it very clear that
nobody is trying to justify those deaths
quite the contrary i think one of the
major purposes of this hearing is to try
to prevent such deaths from taking place
in the future to law enforcement agents
as well as to
people who are not law enforcement
in this particular case
these agents were ordered forward
in a plan that was poor to begin with
the agency insisted upon a military kind
of strike against any other
consideration of any other approach
it was a poorly executed plan from
having undercover surveillance people
who were easily spotted to going ahead
after surprise had been lost and was
poorly managed throughout
and i believe that the main point is
that law enforcement agents are often
ordered to go forward in inherently
dangerous situations and when it happens
again and it will at some point we want
the agents to have a better chance of
surviving than those four agents had
with that i'd like to yield any time i
have remaining to mr micah
thank you mr ship um
just a couple of uh
points gentlemen the first to the texas
rangers uh
if i'm from florida not from texas but
if you looked out the window and saw a
hundred heavily armed people running
towards your house with their guns drawn
in texas what what would be your
reaction would you think you're in
danger
well if i had
more guns in my house than was being
charged and knew that some of them were
illegal and
had been sexually assaulting folks and
i i think i'd know why they were there
but you didn't know i mean the texas
rangers didn't know that was the
situation uh
uh you
i think you testified you didn't really
know what was going on in there we were
told pretty close to it weren't you we
were told the day before it but didn't
someone during this attack dial 9-1-1
weren't they calling for help from
inside yeah sure they did
um
i have a question um to uh doc last
question to dr arnold
uh
the the reason that we have this
you know this whole proceeding is you
know you have an executive branch a
legislative branch the executive branch
did their review and it's also contained
and their findings are contained in this
report
and
they assembled some of the best experts
in the country
and the best experts in the country
including dr sullivan from a harvard
university said the lack of knowledge
about religious religions among law
enforcement agencies may simply reflect
the wider cultural unawareness about the
nature role and importance of religion
and an inattention echoed in other
realms of public policy and cultural
analysis from corporate boardrooms to
congressional hallways newsrooms of
television networks or newspapers in
college classroom rooms do you concur
with their finding
yes i definitely do i think that
that there are many americans who don't
realize that there are many other
millions of americans who have very
strong religious faith
that this religious faith is not just
secondary to their lives but is primary
to their lives there are people jews
christians muslims who study their
sacred scriptures every day they pray
they feel as if they have a personal
relationship with their religious faith
and
often you can find with madison avenue
culture where the daily soap operas
reigns supreme on television that this
this importance of religious faith is
left out but my understanding is in
reading the report again every one of
these conclusions say that we we didn't
pay enough attention or our law
enforcement federal law enforcement in
this instance didn't pay enough
attention or consult independent uh
experts or outside counsel on this
doctor arnold you you've established a
task force to assist law enforcement
agencies understand religious groups
isn't it true the fbi has sort of said
uh don't call us we'll call you
we wrote a letter to attorney general
janet reno in
1994
we sent copies uh to uh fbi and to
assistant attorney general they
basically done nothing so that that is
correct we received a reply back one
month but since then uh there's been no
phone call purpose of this is to find
out what we can do to make this not
happen again and correct the situation
and you're saying
and this report uh confirms really that
they have recommended something and then
done nothing i want to ask my final
question to the texas rangers if this
incident took place in texas
uh under your watch and you know the
situation here would somebody have been
fired or did
you know i i bring my chart up all the
time and show that even the guys that
were fired got rehired nobody
a couple of people were uh retired early
with full benefits and then we paid back
if this had happened under your watch
wouldn't there been a heck of a stink
and people be fired in in
in texas
well first of all i think the at least
the aftermath would point that we would
fire unhonorable people i'd like to
thank them and you'll be fired for lying
uh as a texas ranger gentlemen
time has expired you can just answer the
question they just asked and then not
only fired but under the circumstances
prosecuted because something that the
committee has not asked but we were
commissioned
early on in this as deputy united states
marshals to carry a special commission
so that we could prosecute federally
anyone that lied to us
and we feel real comfortable and captain
burns does that we were lied to i thank
you
mr chairman i don't want to be out of
water could i respond to mr michael
mr chairman
if he could oh absolutely
i've heard
over and over the the question and all
brought up about
uh if religious experts were consulted
uh with this situation have turned out
differently
in 1987 i was involved in a situation in
atlanta where 1400 cubans was holding
121 hostages
their religious beliefs was very
important to them
during that period of time those
hostages were held for 12 days
every time that we gear the negotiations
and responded to their religious
questions and got into their head or
tried to get into their head and they
tried to get into hours
about religion no progress was made
when we talked about secular issues
substantive issues
we got people out
from what research i have undertaken at
waco
mr koresh was given every opportunity in
the world to come out
mr koresh lied several times to the
negotiators he said that he was going to
come out after the first tape was played
but he didn't come out
the ultimate decision
and
i wept for those people
that died there i wept for every one of
them
but the ultimate outcome was in the
hands of david koresh he was given every
opportunity
all those people in there were given
every opportunity and as a negotiator we
give them those opportunities
no matter how we have to do it if we
have to bring in other law enforcement
agencies and other law enforcement
consultants we do it
whatever we have to do to resolve a
situation without loss of life that's
what we try to do
negotiations in this particular instance
got out 35 people
thank god those 35 people didn't die
inside that place i'm sorry i just had
to respond
chair now recognizes mr shattuck
five minutes
thank you mr chairman i want to start by
saying that at the start of this
particular panel one of my colleagues
from the opposite side made the remark
that much had been done today through
the first panel to attempt to
rehabilitate mr koresh
that was the exact language to
rehabilitate mr karesh that is an
outrageous charge no one here is seeking
to rehabilitate mr kresh what we are
seeking to do is to find out some facts
about what appears to be a pretty badly
botched raid that resulted in the death
of four courageous bataf agents and in
the ultimate death of 80 other people
including women and children and
it seems to me that that is an important
task and it seems to me we ought to be
asking as many serious questions as we
can i want to begin uh
captain cook from the texas rangers with
you
early on in this hearing we determined
uh through some testimony that one of
the agents of batf was offered a chance
to go into the compound and to look at
these alleged weapons
he declined at the time to do that he
later told his supervisors about that
offer
yet from that moment in time forward at
no point in time did they ever take up
the offer from david koresh to go in the
compound and look at those weapons had
you been in charge of this whole
situation and been offered early on a
chance to go in and look at the weapons
that were allegedly illegal
would you not have taken up that often
this is prior to any of the
shooting or anything yes sir
well of course i'm second guessing
uh what the
reasons were for this person not doing
it but my gut feeling is to answer your
question say yes sir i would have gone
in and
i feel it been a good intelligence find
in fact finding it and i'd got more
probable cause for the search warrant
you bet
and you might for example if there was
an allegation of a meth lab given that
meth labs put off a lot of odor you
might have been able to make some sense
of whether or not there was a meth lab
the purpose of any investigation is to
determine what you don't know a lot of
times and that would be to me would be
just an investigation to determine
what is going on there's quite a few
things that you might get determined
absolutely uh captain burns what about
you if you've been in charge would you
have gone in
the only reason i wouldn't have gone in
if it
uh the circumstances i was in in the
investigation of the stage where it
would have compromised something
uh
you know i don't believe fresh
you know if he has any sense dogs gonna
show me an illegal weapon now you know
but uh i'm like captain cook if if you
can get in there and look around and and
find out something
you should be better off but i would
have to you know condition that on the
fact that not knowing where he was and
what that would make could have done to
his investigation but i think with all
things being considered in all things
being equal i would probably have tried
to take advantage of that well if for
example at that point in time you'd
known how many weapon bodies and how
many additional parts he
purchased at least from that agent
or from that seller
you had known that if he was supposed to
have had 230 weapons that he had
purchased and you went in and he only
showed you 10
you've at least known that his offer
wasn't genuine wouldn't you
yes sir i believe you would okay
um
you gentlemen i assume have listened to
the testimony about the whole issue of a
dynamic
entry uh it seems to me if you were
going to try to seize this compound uh
you certainly would want to have the
element on your of surprise on your side
would you not
yes
yeah sure i would
and would that suggest to you that you'd
perhaps raid the compound at an earlier
time of day then
10 a.m in the morning
well of course there again having not
maybe having all the facts i i'm not
i've often thought that if if i was in
the planning stage given everything i
know now and i'm not sure i wouldn't
have rated it whenever i knew that they
were having a religious service where
they were all gathered in one place
where they
normally would not have guns and i see
our religious leaders shaking their head
that that wouldn't be a good time but
that's still my law enforcement opinion
they would all be there and unless they
hand them the gun when they come in at
worship they would probably not have any
weapons in there
what about the issue of arresting mr
koresh
outside the compound is that something
you would have at least explored
extensively from your experience i think
i would have considered it however
it's pro and con because number one you
take their leader away from it and they
might be at more confusion and and maybe
uh
more prevalent for violence than than if
karishma himself was there so i think
it's pro and con on that
i don't know that i'd have taken him
outside i think that
given that last scenario i might have
considered that given all the facts that
i know today dr arnold or dr tabor
what's your view of he'd been taken on
the outside uh would he have cut the
head off the snake would resistance from
the compound have been diminished yes i
agree with joyce sparks when she said
that uh for something tragic to happen
to the community he would have to be
there with it the body would have to be
there together the whole group
i wanted to say that i am very very very
concerned that the message that we're
trying to bring here is not really
getting through we're not saying that
that this group just had general
religious views that we should have
really studied and investigated it might
have really been nice to have done that
what we are saying is in this particular
case
that the group followed
certain specific teachings in this book
that they thought were in this book
they were following a literal script
scripted out every detail every day
everything they did was planned
according to their prophecies that they
that they had studied 10 years before
we're bringing you a very special
insight here this group had very
specific detailed teachings dr arnold i
need to have an expert to show you what
those were i hate to cut you off but i'm
going to run out of time here in a
minute and i want to ask uh
mr foster one last question you're a
trained negotiator
my name is mcclure i'm sorry mr mcclure
you're a trained negotiator yes sir okay
and and you've had special training in
that haven't you yes sir have you ever
been involved in a negotiation where
there were women and children who were
in the area where the hostage situation
whether they were hostages or or not
i've been been involved where children
were involved yesterday would you ever
in a hostage situation
if there were
children present
and if there were
women present and they were not at least
so far as you knew actively involved in
crime
or in criminal conduct
would you ever
ignore their presence and just assume
that what you had was not a hostage
situation
but a situation where everybody involved
was a criminal and there was an
obligation to get in there and arrest
those individuals
in any hostage barricade situation
there's some basic alternatives that you
have of course
immediate assault being one
use of a counter sniper gas being one of
course contain the situation and
negotiate
from day one in negotiation training we
start and say that if you start at the
lowest level of force
go all the way that you can with that
you can always escalate the amount of
force that you use in a situation but
it's very difficult to de-escalate the
amount of force
that is used
to be specific in answering your
question
if there were children involved and i
have been involved with situations like
i said involving children
i would have hated
to have to insert gas in there
depending on the situation itself like
the situation in waco
i don't think
let me let me put it this way i think i
would have tried to exercise some more
options
and tried some more things before i
would have inserted the gas
thank you very much sir
you uh you want us to go with more okay
mr elect maryland five minutes
uh
thank you mr chairman i
guess i'm compelled to make two
observations before i ask my questions
my first observation is this so
only on capitol hill
could the characterization of david
koresh as a and i've kept the list
self-proclaimed proclaimed prophet
child molester
statutory rapist
evil
despicable
mentally unstable
head of the snake by my friend from
north carolina
sick
likely manufacture of illegal weapons
and a real bad guy
on this side of the aisle
be deemed an attempt at rehabilitation
by someone on the other side of the eye
i think i included despicable
my second observation
particularly for the rangers is this
i hope you all know from being here that
what we're trying to do
is maybe to some extent rehabilitate but
also to strengthen
the american people's confidence in law
enforcement
at the federal level
and i think you can see
how sincere we are and the commitment
that we have
by the number of members present on this
side of the aisle at this time of night
now my question to the rangers to
captain cook and captain burns is this
i have an opportunity to uh
do a review of the abc news
interview
from a few weeks ago
and i got from that the conclusion i
drew from that was that
it was your opinion that koresh
really did want to surrender to the
texas rangers rather than the feds
and in our attempt to try to get to the
bottom line with respect to factual
conclusions i really want to ask you
that question i realize you've you've
testified to this issue
uh probably an hour ago but what is is
the bottom line testimony what is your
bottom line view with respect to that
issue
well first of all i know captain burns
will want to comment on this also i
don't believe you've seen me on the news
saying anything about that that's true
that's true it's captain purchase yes
and second of all i i don't know of
anything other than the testimony by the
defense attorneys and dick garrett and
titan guarantee is an honorable person
that i know from texas and he is one of
the most respected defense attorneys
that i know of if i got in trouble
that's who i'd want to defend me
but all that said
uh
my negotiation or my involvement with
david koresh surrendering was through
dick degarin and him and i had a
conversation on the phone several times
and we met in person and i took captain
burns with me because he was a site
commander and we did discuss the
possibility but there was one thing that
was paramount is that we would not
negotiate
that surrender with the fbi because that
was dick de garin's idea and i felt like
he needed to carry that idea to the fbi
because i didn't want to give the
impression that the texas rangers were
grandstanding on any of this this was
too serious for the rangers to try to
um stage if you'd have it the fbi that
was not our goal we have we do respect
the fbi and it's difficult for us to
come in a public forum and discuss
our misgivings or our problems that we
have in law enforcement because i really
think that a lot of that can be worked
out on our own
but now that you know what
uh problems we might have had uh maybe
y'all can help working out
uh thank you captain person
well in that interview you saw me i if i
gave the impression that i thought they
were going to surrender i
uh i didn't mean to do i think i said
that there was some uh
discussion that they may have and that
guerin had indicated they would i
personally do not believe that karesh
would have surrendered
ever come out of there that's my
personal opinion i'm sorry sir repeat
that he would not have surrendered to
anyone
i do not believe he would have
surrendered to come out and i i base
that on what i think is logical thinking
now whether he thought logical or i
don't know but i look at it in
reward and punishment we had no reward
to give him to come out
i mean he
he didn't have anything to gain by
coming out uh so i i do not think he
would have surrendered
okay
uh
one last question for the rangers and we
really appreciate your appearance and
your time here tonight
are you familiar with the the memorandum
that has been produced here and it's
been the subject of questioning by
various members particularly mr barr
concerning the production of exculpatory
material and the directive from
department of justice
with respect to the criminal trials
yes sir we've discussed that with the
committee earlier
how long have you all been involved in
law enforcement each of you
i've been involved 30 years 26 years
have you ever seen a similar
directive
in the course of your professional lives
no sir i have not no i have no
thank you mr chairman you'll yield back
to maynard time
any anybody on our side want to finish
his time
chabot thank you
um captain cook um you said that
government officials
lied to you
and that you could
you uh the texas rangers i believe were
actually
uh deputized as u.s federal marshals
so that you could go after anyone
if they actually it was proved they lied
to you uh one thing i think is
interesting is that's that's the first
time that's not mentioned in either the
uh justice department report it's not
mentioned in the treasury report so
there's a couple of other things that
weren't in there
um for the record um you had said that
there were some folks that did lie to
you
um could you say which government
officials uh did lie
and
your best reasoning as to why they were
not prosecuted
i would defer that question if it's okay
to captain burns because he was closer
to the situation absolutely that's fine
captain burns the two two persons we
believe why lied is uh chuck serbian or
chuck serbian and phil onowski that was
referred to mr johnson heard mr johnson
or criminal prosecution we asked him to
proceed
with whatever measures would be to file
under i believe it's rule
1001
my understanding as of friday i spoke mr
johnson about that i believe it was
friday morning of last week he said that
had been referred to main justice and i
would assume it's under advisement there
we did attempt to have them file them
for that we think we've got a good case
thank you time has expired
chair recognized mr bruce from oklahoma
five minutes thank you mr chairman
sorry i had to miss part of the meeting
i was at another meeting
uh
this may have already been asked but i
know that you said that you were aware
of april 19th raid on april 18th
were you aware of the one that started
february 28 prior to its starting atf
raid
i was not personally made aware of it
but our area commander captain prince
that was in waco was advised the day
before
but you weren't involved and they they
didn't invite you to help them plan the
raid or or work it anyway those are not
the texas rangers there were some
department of public safety swat team
people some negotiators and so forth as
part of the atf overall plan i think
there was at least four
of those personnel present at the site
but did not participate okay
now what i want to do is let each of you
uh
tell me anything that we haven't asked
that we should have
start with you commander cooks or
anything that you want to bring to this
hearing that
has not been
that you haven't had the opportunity to
say because this is a rather unusual
format here
well
we're somewhat humbled by being here
first of all you know being from texas
and the congress to have an interest in
us and we've certainly been
treated politely and and i want to thank
the the committee for that
uh as far as
as offering new evidence or testimony in
regard to this i think so far our
testimony has been adequate
there's been lots of questions asked and
i have nothing
uh we're here at your pleasure and we'll
certainly respond and i guess one of my
favorite sayings is that if you don't
want an answer don't ask the question
and that's our position
well i would uh echo captain uh cook's
uh thanks to the to the committee and uh
we are honored and privileged to be here
uh i have a a concern i think
that's that's greater than this
and i've written to my congress and uh
senators about it
the first time i've ever done that in my
life and that's my concern that we are
fast going down the road the federal
police force in this country we seem to
have a tendency to federalize every
crime right now everything from
carjacking to evading
child support is a federal crime in this
country
uh you know and i that really worries me
and i think in this kind of hysterical
state we're in after oklahoma city we
have a big
run a big risk of passing some very
repressive laws that are going to be
in years to come detrimental to our
civil rights in this country
and as a law enforcement officer i worry
about that
i think that for law enforcement to be
effective it has to be accountable
and to be accountable it has to be
controlled at the lowest possible level
uh and and it worries me
to think that that we're vesting and i
don't mean to be uh you know singing the
fbi out but but we seem to be
investing a tremendous amount of
authority in the fbi
uh to take over every aspect of civil
law enforcement in this country and i
just you know i feel strongly about that
i think that it's detrimental to our
continued freedom in this country uh
because i don't believe anybody wants a
national police force in this country
and i certainly don't and i just i just
think that we need to kind of step back
take a deep breath and look at this
thing and you know all the malicious
stuff and all that and it is serious
there's no doubt about it but maybe we
ought to try to figure out what has
happened to
to disaffect so many of our citizens
with our with our government you know uh
what has happened over the years because
these people have so
just absolutely passively hate the
federal government uh
and you know people talk about being out
of government i think sometimes i'm in
our government you know i i
i don't like paying all the taxes i pay
and and
a lot of other things you know and i
resent the fact that that i think every
aspect of our daily life is included
into some way by some level of
government i'm not going to go out and
take up arms against this government by
quite the contrary i'm going to defend
it i'm going to defend the constitution
of texas in this country as long as i
can but i i just think that we ought to
look at that and and i i thank you for
your indulgence on that and i didn't
mean good on my soapbox thank you that
bird you echoed what about every ranger
i've ever talked to you said
thanks for your comments well i if i
could just add that that
we can't
separate sometime our personal feelings
from our professional stances
representing our agency and and and i'd
say that several of our comments may
have come from the heart as opposed to
what our agency has asked us to
represent
dr arnold any uh
thing that you've not been able to say
that you would like to quickly because
we're going to add time shortly
yes i'd like to say that it's important
all of us whether we're democrats or
republicans or whatever we may be to
to
take a moment to consider the fact that
a lot of times there are accusations of
people being uh cultists or zombies or
uh holy rollers or all kinds of ugly
words are used it's sort of like hate
speech
and sometimes that reduces someone who
has a strong religious faith that we
totally disagree with but it can reduce
them to simply an object as a member of
a group
and we have to watch that and not be
influenced by those in our society who
would like for us to reduce religious
experience to to some kind of
brainwashing
disease what we want to do is look at
people as individuals
call in experts from the american
academy of religion or the society for
the scientific study of religion and get
their opinions at least
before we take law enforcement activity
against them very good point our tabor
i think what uh you ask what we haven't
had the opportunity to say is why april
14th was a breakthrough in david's
theology why they were coming out
from a theological viewpoint i think you
can make a strong argument
and what the gentleman mentioned
no positive reasons for him that he
would do so
uh i think uh there are very positive
reasons
so i haven't been able to bring it out
yet but i expect that we will
okay mr mcclure
i would just like to say mr brewster
that uh
sure i think there was some mistakes
that were made and maybe some bad
judgment in certain situations
but again i i fall back to my premise
that once the situation was in progress
mr koresh had every opportunity in the
world to come out
he lied over and over
to the authorities about coming out
uh
i think that was very significant
why then should they believe him when
all of a sudden this revelation
uh came forth that he was going to come
out
it's hard for me to accept
that a man on the inside of that
compound who deemed himself who referred
to himself as god
how in the world could you trade
and offer him to come out and be an
inmate
to me he never would have come out of
that place
i think he would have stayed in there
and in fact he did stay in there until
what you might say the bitter end
uh i think all of the negotiation
efforts
possible were put forth and he was given
every opportunity in the world any of
those people could have came out anytime
they wanted to they were given that
opportunity
i think mr karesh had that hold on it's
one of the major questions of whether
the end should have occurred on april
19th or maybe may 30th and given an
opportunity for more days but that's mr
your time has expired
did did anybody get shout out mr tabor
did you feel like you could shut up
and your answer would be okay well
uh he he simply asked what we haven't
brought out yet and i mentioned uh why
it was a breakthrough and what the motor
would be i assume we will explore that
but i didn't want to take five more
minutes to do it thank you for that i
appreciate that mr heineman from north
carolina is recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman
to the two gentlemen from the texas
rangers
i have over the course of my 38 years in
law enforcement
conversed with
30 40 000 police executives and police
officers
and by far you two are the most
impressive i've ever sat and listened to
um
i think your organization and the whole
state of texas can be very proud of you
not because you said you answered
exactly as i would have answered
but because but because you're extremely
impressive thank you
i had a hundred questions to ask you but
after three hours every one of them has
been exhausted
but i want to get back to to april the
14th
mr um the guerin had a had a supposed
deal with uh with quresh
that he he was going to have mr karesh
surrender to the texas rangers
and you were aware of that
was the fbi aware of that
i can't say because i don't think i can
tell you is what mr guerin said and he
said that he did convey that to the fbi
okay
and just some quick questions i promised
i would yield some of my time to mr
bryant
mr mcclure how would you have brought
closure to these siege
in ten words or less
i would say come out excuse me i would
have told them i said come out now you
have every opportunity that you can come
on out put your arms down and come out
and if he did not do that
i would have waited
okay mr table
same question how would you have brought
closure
to that siege allowed him to deliver the
manuscript he was working on which was
the key to
the whole thing when you understand it
and do you believe that he would have
surrendered to the texas rangers
that was an important part of the
agreement he was a very low uh texas boy
in that sense he had this sense of
southern independence didn't like
dealing with
what he called the beast
that would be the federal government how
would you brought closure to it
as i said to allow him to finish it and
come out and if he didn't
oh if he didn't come out
my job was over i did what i could i'd
have no
nothing to do with it obviously mr
ronald
yes i would have words or less yes i
would have waited
and
we had the promise
a promise this time that was based upon
his religion
and that was the very reason he waited
all that time
and finally he had the word to come out
he would have been out within about 10
days i'm absolutely convinced of that
and don't doubt it for one moment
listen to the negotiation tapes the last
three days and you'll agree with me okay
i like the
thank you gentlemen i like the balance
of my time from mr bryant
thank my friend from north carolina uh i
have some questions i'd like to ask but
uh and i usually try to refrain from
commenting uh but uh i've listened to
some of the comments that have been
spoken earlier tonight and i want to
again stress publicly that no one
on either side of this aisle has a
monopoly
on moral superiority in this
case
and in fact i don't know the biographies
of
my colleagues on the other side of the
aisle but i can look around me on this
side of the aisle and see
chief heinemann with 38 years of law
enforcement of police chief i can see
another in addition to me another former
united states attorney to my left
a state prosecutor to his left
mr shift state prosecutor in new mexico
and i think at least one more steve
boyer military prosecutor a number of
folks on this side of the aisle
that have made those hard choices it
would be easy to sit back and just say
well david koresh was a bad guy
and he deserved what he got
but those of us who have been
particularly close to law enforcement
over the years are concerned with the
reputation of law enforcement and i'm
very pleased to join in with mr
heinemann and my commendation to the
texas rangers you've certainly lived up
to your reputation
but unfortunately as the proof has
developed other people have made
mistakes in the federal side and perhaps
uh are facing a sagging reputation
across this country
and one i think this oversight of this
committee is responsible for restoring
if we can do that now with that said the
topic at this point is negotiations
and i want to get back to negotiations
and uh particularly the texas rangers
you were there firsthand uh do either
one of you gentlemen know
that you hear from any federal agent out
there before
august 19th before the final raid
any reason
any reason they gave
for having to go in at that particular
point in time and not waiting later on
why did why did what did you hear as a
reason why they had to go in that day
we were not included in the tactical
plan whatsoever but i would defer that
to captain burns and let him respond to
that also as i testified earlier i was
called on the afternoon of the 18th and
by mr jamar to come to a meeting and i
was briefed on the plan that it would
start at 6 00 a.m and
this
what the basics of the plan were
i was if there was a reason given uh and
i don't believe there was i don't recall
it uh just that that's what they were
going that was the next step in the plan
okay now mr mcclure you you've
referenced a a prior uh siege you had at
the
uh or atlanta i'll get a minute atlanta
cuban uh refugees
i assume
one of the first things you did as a
negotiator was try to find somebody who
could speak their language of course
somebody would communicate to them in
spanish and
and uh i sort of equate this with the
same way we i see a fault here that we
didn't have the people
in place giving advice that could speak
david koresh's language
i know he spoke english but i'm talking
about the language of the bible that he
referred to
and that would that was a concern i had
uh
from the standpoint of giving advice
don't would you agree that would that
would be accurate apparently you have to
i think you have to communicate to the
subject on his or her level uh again
referring back to the situation in
atlanta we did we brought in trained
spanish-speaking negotiators
so that they could speak their language
and understand but again they would
train negotiators
i like to use the example
uh a psychologist or a psychiatrist with
all due respect
i don't know of any of them that's
negotiated with people holding
negotiated with anyone holding a gun to
anyone's head
negotiate or treat people in a clinical
setting we deal with people that have
shot and killed people
and try to get them out without any
further loss of life whatever we have to
do to do that that's what we try to do
i agree thank you
thank you
mr spearman
thank you mr chairman and and let me
thank the witnesses and i know it's been
a long long day
captain burns were you here during the
previous testimony of the last panel
yes ma'am okay when they had talked
about quresh and the davidians were
peaceful practitioners of christianity
and who were just merely defending
themselves from attacking you contacted
the criminal investigation
based on your investigation and if you
could do this real quickly what really
happened in your eyes
i think that a lot of those people in
there most of the people were true
believers
i think they were totally committed
uh my personal opinion is that karesh
used religion and i think somebody on
his panel said he didn't use the bible
he abused the bible and i believe that's
what happened okay and there was some
controversy this morning about paul gray
do you remember who recommended paul
gray
what happened with paul gray getting
there about on day two after the fire uh
i was told and i believe by as an
assistant u.s attorney that a national
arson team was being assembled in
washington d.c to come work to arson
that tickled me to death i had about 500
things to be doing i said fine i put
that aside the first time i ever heard
of paul gave when he showed up down
there maybe the next day okay that's all
i know about it and the evidence we've
had a lot of controversy in this hearing
about the evidence and i understand you
all hold the evidence and the arsenal or
or whatever we've talked about bringing
it up here not bringing it up here
briefly could you just give us an
account of what you found
uh well there was about uh
i think about 300 weapons found in there
including two 50 caliber
weapons barrett's what they call barrett
they were
i believe the firearms export expert
testified in court and up here that
48 of those weapons had been
converted illegally to full automatic
there were silencers
in various stages some of the weapons
had silences on them we recovered five
live hand grenades out of there and
outside the compound some of the people
came out of the fire dropped
there was uh machine tools in there that
were capable of altering these uh
weapons and also manufacturing the
silences we found tubing it was
consistent with uh the tubing used on
the silencers so it was pretty massive
oh yeah okay a tremendous amount of
evidence thank you and i don't mean to
cut you off but i'm yeah um dr tabor or
dr arnold uh
first question i need to to ask you is
prior to the time coming to talk to the
fbi to become a part of the negotiators
had you ever talked to mr quresh prior
to that
no never okay then let me let me go to
the report very quickly because in the
report um
they actually mention
you as being one of those that sent in a
tape so you were a part i mean i
realized you showed up but they did
allow you to have some contact with mr
chris correct
yes i think was agent jabar did permit
an audio two audio cassette tapes to go
inside okay let me just suggest to you
that there were several others i don't
know if you've seen this report that
actually were brought on there was a dr
bill austin um the chaplain of baylor
university there was one by gerald
bingham
who actually had known koresh
uh bingham recalled that koresh plotted
to seize control of the branch davidians
from former leader george rhoden he
recalled that koresh thought of the
branch davidian movement as a game for
game bingo mentioned that quresh likened
himself to the biblical king of cyrus
and that those who did not follow
him were with satan and there's reverend
trevor
delafield
dr wallace dr fredericks
dr michael haynes and dr gwen hilburn so
in all
fairness here
um none of these people are getting an
opportunity to testify before this
committee i mean you can see that that's
happening here
part of the reason perhaps is that
korres responded directly to us and
maybe not to these others and now i've
never charged that the fbi did not
consult religious experts uh what i have
said is the fbi on the final three days
did not take into consideration
the dynamics of the religious
apocalyptic situation that is they
delivered the koresh
of what he thought someday would come
and that is the death of the community
well in one of these and i don't know
that i have time but there is one in
specific here that does talk about that
that was his area of expertise and these
were seventh-day adventists these were
people who had done those things so most
of them like like joyce sparks uh she's
not a religious expert but knew the
community if you recall everyone who's
known has said uh you shouldn't have
gone in like that that's not the thing
to do with the religious community okay
let me let me ask another question mr
mcclure let me ask you before i get off
this issue um
in your years of experience
would that have been the proper way to
go about these negotiations is by
bringing in several of these different
people to sit down talk discuss what was
going on
we would have consulted people in those
particular areas but we would not have
let them actually participate in the
actual negotiation and why is that
uh
we
teach in negotiations again 101 that
you try to stay away from using third
parties
because they're not trained as crisis
negotiators
they may be used to sit down to talk
across the table with someone and argue
views back and forth
religious philosophy whatever it might
be not just necessary religion but they
are not trained in dealing with people
in crisis situations okay and and the
fact of the matter is they could have
different opinions of
and interpretations of what had happened
here one last question
one of the things that has really
bothered me through all of this
is
that we really almost have two different
groups of people
here
we have those that left we have the lisa
gents the robin bunts the carrie jewels
those and if you heard my testimony
earlier the question i asked earlier
specifically
giving us
the indication
that that this prophecy would be
fulfilled i mean the details would
change as david received more messages
from god but there was never a time when
we didn't expect to be killed by the
feds who david saw was babylon that was
carrie jewell
and and so forth and so on and then
we've got the group that comes out
i mean is it a possibility
and i don't know this i'm
that there were those i mean
lisa gent said that this new coming that
she went to a hotel and read the bible
because she was very concerned about
being taken away from her husband was it
a possibility that there were those who
were still mesmerized by mr koresh and
those that had gone out and said you
know i just really don't believe what
he's saying anymore that we might not be
getting a really good account in in that
kind of a situation
i guess we're referring to those that
came out survive the fire oh before that
well before that and and who left before
that right well yes i i think there
weren't a question during the 51 days
there's no doubt there were some people
who began to disagree with david koresh
on the theology they did that because
they studied his theology they
determined it was false but see it's a
thinking process they're looking up
hebrew words greek words consulting with
rabbis and teachers it's not that they
just fell out of being hypnotized
they studied themselves out and others
studied themselves in it was a very
complex intellectual kind of religion
believe it or not oh i no i i think it
all is
any
chair would like to uh recognize mr
bryant from tennessee for five minutes
thank you again mr chairman uh mr
mcclure i don't think anyone here and i
don't think dr arnold dr tabor are
advocating that they should have been
the ones doing the negotiating
negotiations i think what we are trying
to say and i think you're in agreement
with on this is that
perhaps the negotiators the trained
negotiators should have used folks like
that
uh who were more familiar with the
branch davidians uh to give them counsel
and advice as an example
this idea that david koresh did not like
babylon the federal government and
perhaps rather than having him negotiate
directly with the federal government the
fbi atf
he apparently had a better relationship
with the local sheriff or the texas
rangers and had
maybe the federal agents had a better
appreciation for this babylon this
federal government perhaps
a better negotiator could be found who
was actually trained in that field
now the second thing is i want to again
i'm i'm asking mr mcclure because i
think you
you've been invited at the invitation of
the other side here and i wanted to you
you haven't asked answered a lot of
questions but you haven't been asked a
lot of questions tonight but would you
agree that that this technique that the
fbi did choose to use
where they played i understand nancy
sinatra music and and hopefully not
these boots were made for walking but
that and uh uh the the sounds of
screaming dying rabbits uh would that
be what you'd want to do or would you
rather try to develop rapport you know
we're not talking about manuel or
noriega wouldn't you be trying to
develop a rapport at least and wouldn't
that be harmful to that in shining
lights at night
as a negotiator that's one of your
purposes mr brian is trying to establish
trust and rapport with the person that
you're negotiating with
i agree with you i don't think the
decision
was a wise decision
to play those chants and so forth
in atlanta at the federal pen we used
similar techniques
but we played the positive messages and
that's my understanding prior to all
that music being played they were some
positive messages being played so that
everyone inside the compound
would know what the negotiators were
trying to do
that's what we tried to do in atlanta so
we can make sure that all of the cubans
inside there knew what the negotiators
were trying to do and the message would
get out to all of them
to directly answer your question i don't
think it was a wise decision at all to
play those chants and music
especially whatever nancy sinatra was
saying
uh to be clear we we don't want to bash
miss sinatra achievement oh no i
i wouldn't thank you uh a moment ago i
think you did answer a question and
perhaps uh dr arnold and dr tabor maybe
may have disagreed from their from their
gestures about this issue of david uh
uh you felt he lied a number of times
and and i just want to give them the
opportunity to respond uh
in terms of mr mcclure's statement that
mr kresh had ample opportunity and lied
several times that he was coming out but
rather did not i'm not sure where this
has come from it's become folklore now
representative schumer gave you the list
he could only come up with four out of
51 days i would contest three of them
the last one was what would happen on
the 14th that was a lie
so that was the future i mean on the
19th you know that he would come out
the only i went through
very carefully tallied kept score
uh the one i can find that could be
called a lie would be the march second
promise when they played the tape he
said he would come out after playing the
tape
um he explains that for the next 50 days
that's one of the things they talk about
constantly
if you're a man of god why didn't you do
what you said and what he says is
i got a word as i was being loaded on
the stretcher to wait i've only had this
a few times in my life it's a voice when
i hear it i do it and i connected it to
a scripture the fifth seal where it says
that they will wait
for a period and that's what he says and
he says i that's what i had to do
then he got a word right
at the end and so actually it's it's
fairly consistent wait
and write and that's the 51 day the rest
of it is basically talking about
many many things
some boring some fascinating
some just uh javier
joking back and forth about what we're
going to eat when we get out
a lot of those so-called lies have to be
looked at very carefully on the
negotiating tapes and i think you'll
find it's really it's sort of 50 50.
there's always the other side of the
story uh maybe he didn't send someone
out but then again he thought he was
going to get some milk but the milk was
not coming to the to the women and to
the children and the women no longer had
milk because the stress had dried up
their milk producing capabilities so
there was some going back and forth on
issues like that so
you know i'm sure people are going to
follow us saying look at all these lies
he told
i just say
listen to negotiation tapes and decide
for yourself on that
wait he waited 51 days and then he said
the word came to him and said right
and he wrote
this was brought out with day of the
fire by one of the survivors he was
keeping his promise of april 14th
we believe it would have all come out
safe
i think it's interesting that mr schumer
who must have combed the record came up
with four examples the last of which was
a prediction of the future that he
wouldn't have done it so that's you know
so really went up with three
uh and i would contest the two middle
ones i think uh surely he would have
found them had they been there your
statements again i don't think anyone
here is trying to adopt mr karesh's
theology and to uh become a convert or
uh make excuses for him but i think what
you're saying is it just points out that
you needed some people who were somewhat
familiar with what he was trying to say
to get into his mind as mr mcclure is so
well stated
and perhaps i think you two folks have
said it very well we could have avoided
these unnecessary
deaths out there if we had perhaps done
a better job in negotiating
and i see my time is about up you have a
quick comment well just very quickly
it's not a matter of agreeing with him
or believing his theology it's a matter
of discovering what he was trying to say
what the script was
reading ahead in the script
in the book of revelation
and then you'd know what he was going to
do next
that's what we tried to do
we tried to do that other experts could
have done it too but we just tried to do
what we could
thank you your time time has expired
uh the chair now yields to mr mccollum
for five minutes thank you very much mr
chairman we're about to come to an end
to this evening's a long long hearing
but i want to ask some questions
that i don't think have been answered
yet and a couple of these i'm going to
ask to the texas rangers
because there have been real
clarifications questions raised in some
of these writings that have gone on
about the events at waco that need to be
resolved am i correct mr burns that the
texas rangers took statements from
virtually all of the atf
agents who were involved in the raid or
in the raid preparation uh as part of
your investigation yes that's correct mr
colin we started taking statements uh on
march 2nd
some of the agents were in the hospital
we took the statements from we ended
that on about
i believe march 18
on agent kenny king who was the most
severely wounded you know fell off into
the compound there he was not able to be
interviewed until then and i believe a
total of about 85 agents that were out
there
any of those statements
did any of the atf agents state
that the shots that were fired first
were fired by atf agents in their
opinion or an atf agent
no sir uh and i don't know if this came
from the statement but i think agent
balosteros
stated at one time and it may have been
in the statement that he initially
thought that it was the atf dog team
that was firing they had a a group of
people that there were a bunch of dogs
around that that stated that compound
and then they had people
designated if the dogs uh were going to
attack him to kill those dogs so he
stated and i think he testified to that
uh yesterday
testified but nobody only won all i want
to know is that anybody uh say that and
nobody did do you no none of them at all
and what about with regard to firing
from the helicopters did any of the atf
agents tell you that there had been any
shots fired from the helicopters quite
the contrary all that we could find no
evidence that there was ever any
shots fired our best evidence is that
they peeled off at about 300 and 350
meters because there was gunfire and
those those pilots were not going to fly
over that compound and if indeed there
were as mr de garan described today to
us bullet holes in the roof of that main
building that had to have come from
above did you ever find any evidence any
explanation for why there would have
been bullet holes and how they could
have come from above if they didn't come
from the helicopters no sir i did not
and mr guerin talk to me about that
tonight i met with all right thank you
now i want to ask you about something
very important to the fbi part of this
and very important in my opinion to what
ultimately happened the hostage rescue
team that the fbi had according to their
report
was getting very tired uh they needed to
go back if they continued this and we
didn't have the assault that occurred
and have some training and regrouping
although there were some questions about
it it appears pretty clear they were
and there was some consideration of
doing that but in the process of that
consideration
they
seem to have and again we haven't heard
the testimony but just reading the text
of this seem to have decided that they
couldn't really do that because they
didn't trust
uh swat teams or anybody else to be able
to maintain the perimeter around the
compound they said they just didn't have
a force they didn't have the right under
the law possible slaughter the military
do it and they didn't have confidence
that they could get any swat teams that
could do their job but just maintaining
the perimeter and keeping people from
coming out and so forth they're going in
uh is that in your opinion knowing that
texas
officers y'all don't have swat teams do
you at the texas rangers but the state
police do don't they yes dps has a swat
team and and either the state police or
the local officials in the area were
those were there swat teams or
combinations thereof that could have
been put together from state law
enforcement or local law enforcement
that could have maintained that
perimeter for a few days
or a week or two if necessary to let
this fbi hostage team regroup had the
negotiations continued for another month
or something
well to answer your question
just generically yes uh practically i
don't know and let me say that
the the hrt team in my opinion
is probably the most highly trained unit
for what they're doing in the world and
i think they they're with people to be
there and i don't doubt that for a
minute i'm not even questioning that i'm
just asking because i know you may not
know all of this but we we've looked
into it and it appears that that is a
factor we're going to hear more from
them about it i've never heard that
before but but whether it is or not the
question i was really asking was just
because you're here tonight uh you
believe that at least from the
standpoint of holding the perimeter and
i'd ask that to you as well captain cook
that state
police or or swat teams from local
police units could have been mustered if
you'd been asked and consulted with to
do that
even though they wouldn't have been as
effective at it perhaps as the fbi's hrt
team is that right or not
i think that that could have been
accomplished i think that's just a basic
law enforcement trait number one i mean
we have police officers trained in
different areas all right thank you very
much child abuse we've heard a lot up
here today about child abuse in this
past week
local law enforcement that's their
problem mr burns or captain burns
it was not a federal law that was
violated i've heard some of my
colleagues say and i've even heard some
officials downtown this past week say uh
you know because of all the child abuse
in there the atf needed to go in and do
its thing uh
in in your opinion if it were just child
abuse and the guns weren't involved
couldn't the texas rangers have taken
care of that
i would hope we could yes
right
we work child abuse thank you now i've
got to ask dr tabor a question dr tabor
you have said several times this evening
that you had positive reasons why you
believed affirmatively that the
negotiations on the 14th would have
succeeded where you were absolutely
convinced they would
and you needed about five minutes to
tell us and you said you're sure you're
going to be asked to do that sometime
well i that forget that light over there
once i've asked the question you can
take the five minutes if i weren't going
to do it that's what mr zeller is going
to do we've got the mr boots going to
yield we have the last time here so
forget that light and just tell us what
those positive reasons were
thank you
it has to do with
what dr arnold referred to as the script
let's call it an apocalyptic scenario
and it's essentially built around
david's system of how
the end of the age comes many
apocalyptic groups have such
events they're they're ordered sequences
of events
and david had his so the question we
became rather concerned when we found
out early on uh arnold talking to tom
murphy fbi agent
he thinks he's in the fifth seal
now the fifth seal says
that a number of the group would be
killed and then you wait until the rest
are killed
now that's in the bible
at some point in history if you take the
bible literally there'll be some sort of
martyrdom of the people of god
various other ways to interpret it but
that would be the literal interpretation
this
terrified us and i think the fbi as well
because it obvious if he thinks he's in
the fifth seal what are you waiting on
till the rest will be killed there's
this is a scenario mrs thurman was
referring to
that uh various people that have left
the group have talked about that someday
at the end there'll be this final period
of martin what's after the fifth seal
the sixth seal
and it might as well be the seventh
because it's over at that point that's
what everybody refers to
popularly as the end of the world the
judgment
now
what we presented to korrashin and the
legal work had to be done first because
he had legal concerns as well but once
the legal things were done and the exit
plan was worked out literally who would
go out first second third how would it
be handled
the question then was
as we presented to him was separate the
man from the message every prophet wants
to be heard we said david
you are
on the cover of time newsweek people
you're mentioned hourly on cnn every
night on the news whatever day it is but
what do we know about you you claim to
be the messenger to the world
what is it that you're saying we don't
know anything you're saying
and in the book of revelation the key
passage that i think got through to him
is in chapter 10 where it says that this
messenger he claims to be is not to
write the message he can present it
one-on-one like he tried to do to
rodriguez all his other people says
write it not
but at the end of the chapter
it says he will go forth and write it
and so what we suggested to him i think
he goes for it in the letter if you look
at the letter carefully there's a little
bit of what we would call i think
nonsense in it about earthquakes i don't
know how many people believe david could
cause an earthquake but look at what he
says over and over here's what comes out
consistently
i you can i'm gonna come out
and you can deal with the bizarrity of
me in the flesh
i will answer any and all questions
before man
he says this three or four times exactly
what
not that we had caused it we had simply
tried to convince him that this was not
the fifth seal it's not the time this is
the time
and and the fbi by the way had also
tried to say this is the time for their
your message to go for it
what he felt i think was that with this
manuscript the fact that two scholars at
at universities with phds had said david
will look at it
he kept saying we're not a bunch of
idiots i do have a doctrine i've got
something to say we in effect said
fine
what is it we'll read it i don't we read
it the press will be saying when you
bring it out
what did that guy teach anyway you see
that was the positive motivation now he
would have to face the court that's the
negative
mr garren had convinced him i think
true or not i don't know that there was
a good case
not about child molesting or anything
that hadn't even brought up legally but
what happened on the 28th that the
davidians had a good case that they'd
acted in self-defense
so that would come out positive in the
meantime his message would go out
and so what he became convinced of he
still believed that someday
there would be a group of martyrs at the
end which many fundamentalist christians
believe
in fact most fundamentalist christians
believe
but
he could see that this was not the time
but he wasn't sure that's why i was
waiting he was waiting to see
and to determine in his own mind and
however he got his revelations is at the
time now what happens on the night now
he sits down to write
and we've interviewed his typist
this is ruth riddle on sunday night
she's typing the manuscript why because
the fbi said
well we have to wait a week two weeks
you look at the transcript we gave you
he says i'm out of here i'm so tired of
eating mres you get these quotes he says
lock stock and barrel it it's clarified
i'm splitting this place at the very end
he says
yes yes yes i'm coming out i never
intend to die in here
now that's literally two days before the
fire so what happens on the 19th in his
religious mind you've got to understand
what you're dealing with here
when tanks come in
inserting the gas
and saying
what should have never been said
vernon you're not the messiah
you're fi you're 15 minutes of fame are
over come out and surrender to proper
authority
that's that attack of the beast you see
in other it's what his mind is saying i
think at this point and this is not
psychoanalyzing him it's common sense
obviously you don't write a manuscript
and get your message to the world
god must want to bring out of this after
all the martyrdom in others we are in
that time we're in that tragic time
where we
will die
and we must have been in the fifth seal
after all and so the fbi inadvertently i
don't think they intended to do this
confirmed him in the previous view
remember that someday i'll be attacked
he's attacked on the 28th
and then 19th
they will come in with gas and tanks and
somebody mentioned the prophecies he'd
read about chariots of fire surrounding
and so forth
uh it fulfilled the scenario now the
other alternative would be come out
and answer any and all questions the
message is is what was key to him
i think he thought that we would be
when we read it as he said to the
negotiator it'll blow your socks off
well you got chapter one it's in the
back of my book
it's pretty hard to understand frankly
we give a little commentary to help
i i would say it's respectable
exegesis given his view
could have been discussed
uh we don't we didn't get the other six
chapters so i guess we'll never know but
uh this was his logic
uh so it fits
uh
his own self-interest to come out and
the group self-interest and the tapes
show that they were buoyant over it and
happy
and excited they were finally coming out
that's when
that lasted till sunday at two o'clock
when they began moving the cars out
front
and he got very upset and these are the
last words basically of course he said
i'm gonna write it or i'm not
it's up to you
and what he meant there was
if
you act as babylon against me then i
guess about you know the end is near
it's up to you are you the people who
bring the end or not
or i'll write it
if you want to hear my message this was
his own view as arnold said a couple
it's not my view certainly not his view
but it was courageous view and certainly
the view of the ones inside
so uh
you know one way to trivialize it it'd
say well was it worth waiting 10 days
for the lives of those kids i mean
that's kind of a silly way to put it and
that's not how i would put it
i don't know how long i would have
waited but certainly when
a legal written agreement
the evidence of the negotiators and and
they were encouraging him they were
saying well you need to get back to that
you see because you're coming out they
were saying things like i'm anxious to
read it
he was under the impression that it was
as we say a done deal
and it fit finally the alternative
scenario is that we're not in the end of
the world what foolishness there are
lots of things we said think of all the
things ahead
and uh there's a future in other words
lots of things to be talked about lots
of things to be done i think that had a
great appeal to him
thank you sorry it was probably more
than five minutes thank you well it was
uh but but we thank you for your
testimony both of you
uh and the texas rangers we thank you as
well and uh i i just had one troubling
thing uh both captain cook and captain
byrne um
oh i'm i'm sorry i need to yield to uh
mr blute my good friend from
massachusetts for five minutes
i'd just like to thank this panel i
think it's been very informative i think
these hearings have been very
informative for the american people at
this time i would yield a balance of my
time to chairman zela
and and the thing that's troubling me is
that
we've talked about serbian and winosky
and you said that they lied
and uh we certainly heard the testimony
yesterday
and the problem that that uh that that a
lot of us have with us is that we had
this tragedy over 80 folks were killed
americans
um
a lot of mistakes were made everybody
admitted mistakes and nobody paid the
price nobody was held accountable nobody
was responsible
and these two gentlemen were fired and
then rehired
uh and we still don't know a lot of the
details about the rehiring and and and
all of that
um if this
situation had developed at waco and was
turned over to texas rangers
uh not only the child abuse apparently
wasn't a drug connection uh we'll assume
that at least
and you only had to deal with the
weapons and you had to deal with the
child abuse and there was a complaint
how would you have done it differently
well i think we were posed that question
earlier and maybe in a little different
format it's difficult to say that that
we would have gone and knocked on the
door like so many people think that
that's the way the rangers would handle
it
i want to tell you our resources are not
what atf are but i think probably what
we would have done is if that
information came to us
quite honestly we would have gone to atf
for assistance we would have gone but i
think at that point it would have been a
joint operation
as opposed to a single provisional
51-day siege and then the ultimate
decision to use gas the quantities that
was used would you make that decision
well there again in that y'all probably
have more information than we do
in regard to the conversations on the t3
tapes and so forth with regard to what
was going on in there
i would like to think that that
we would have
i don't know that would have continued
on with the siege
whether we would have ended the siege
at some point in time it had to end
i don't think there's any doubt that
that at some point in time and i've
heard uh
just
comments that we should have just built
a fence around and put pickets and uh
left them there and the penitentiary so
as to speak you know not a bad idea is
it well in retrospect
and in retrospect because we still would
have had the lives alive
but we could not allow or continue to
allow from our perspective a continuing
criminal offense which
if we sincerely felt that we do that
there was sexual abuse going on and so
forth it's pretty hard to allow that
offense to continue in our presence so
at some point in time we would have had
to end it would it have been that day
i'm not going to sit here and tell you
it would have been that day
i would like to think that uh through
the use of dicta guerin that my report
our report
we might could have established i have
worked just a few more days extra harder
i'm going to tell you that it's still
hard to second-guess the bureau and say
that they acted improperly but i'm just
saying that you know when you write a
letter if i write a letter and i reread
it i'm going to tear it up and write it
again well let me let me ask you this
and i'd like mr captain burns to also
comment um
you have two of your texas ranges if
they lied
and you fired them
would you re-hire them under what basis
well we don't have the same latitude to
the same rules probably that the federal
government have and i've heard the
testimony about being reinstated and i i
certainly appreciate management
standpoint in in uh uh
bringing them back in a non-commission
for fear that they would come back in a
commission spot or in a gun carrying
spot and it sound like to me from the
testimony that's the reason for the
cave-in was to to make certain
uh that that wouldn't happen i would
like to think that we can fire texas
rangers for lying uh uh we're fine
pretty good reason to get rid of people
isn't it well certainly it is and and
you know our integrity level is much
above the lie zone so would you gone
further than that would you would there
be any kind of criminal uh
penalty or
charges
we would based on what you know as a
policy we pursue criminal charges on our
own personnel
at the same pace that we would on anyone
else we don't feel like our people are
exempt from criminal charges
which is what we suggested in this case
in regard to this captain burns has
testified that we recommended criminal
charges be filed that
is no different than if we would work in
any other criminal case whether it be on
our own people or not
and i can tell you a personal situation
but i'd rather not because it it does
involve our people but uh recently we
had to make that decision and we made
that so you you believe in
accountability certainly do and at some
point blame has to stop it has to go
someplace doesn't it it does
i guess the only other question that
that i would ask you is that you met
with ron noble
week before last i believe and i'm just
curious
what was your discussion with him
relative to this case and
uh
anything that you'd like to add mr
zeliph that's kinda and i have to have
to say this with a smile
because we met not only with mr noble
what we met with the congressional staff
and it was really
funny mr noble was not as inquisitive
but it seemed like every time we met
with a group they said what did they say
what did the other side say don't be
interested well i'm not going to make
that distinction but i can tell you that
that's exactly the same comments that we
were getting what did they say i think
mr noble is an honorable person that
that is trying that that we found to be
honorable with us i can judge him only
the way he treats me personally the way
he treated the rangers
and our personal interaction and that's
what i'm telling you that the way i feel
is that he has treated us professionally
and and has never
never attempted to
circumvent or change our testimony in
one way or the other
i i didn't imply that
the only last thing i would i would like
to say mr bugar last night ended up
in uh probably the same place that you
might want to end up
we we just uh are very appreciative that
uh that you came all the way from texas
to join us here
uh to be part of what we're trying to do
in terms of seeking the truth
um and his indication was that this is
good for the atf these hearings that we
would hopefully get to the bottom of it
that if there are any problems or
that need to be corrected that they
could be corrected in in the end would
add an awful lot of credibility to law
enforcement across
not only state local and federal
any comments that you would like to add
well i think it would be our goal like i
said earlier we don't like to air our
differences
in public but since we have
then we would like for all the good that
can come out of this in order to make
law enforcement better and as it was
stated from the committee that we would
like if there is a problem with
credibility with the american
public then we would like to to be a
part of reestablishing that
and that would be our goal here
is to say that law enforcement is
committed to doing the right thing i
really believe that i think at the
federal level i know we've had some
harsh words for the fbi
in this we've told the truth we've been
honest with you
uh
and
i guess that's where i would like to end
is saying we've tried to be totally
honest good place to end it
we thank you very much and and just
asked in any way possible did anybody
here trash or hurt or demean law
enforcement
you certainly have not us and and from
our testimony or from our hearing of the
committee i have not
seen anything i think sometimes you have
to get honest with one another and
sometimes you have to disagree with one
another and i certainly if i disagree
with one of you or you disagree with me
i hope that i'm in a position to
stake my case
and and still come out with the ultimate
objective of getting to the truth thank
you very much i'd like to thank all of
you
i have a point of procedure sure there's
been a lot of discussion today about
about this deal and references to a
signed document that dr tabor has i'd
ask you to ask his consent that that uh
signed agreement be submitted for the
record
without objection so ordered
it's included in our opening statements
and also in dicta guerin so it's
probably already in there but it
wouldn't hurt to put another copy on
sure i have a similar career mr chairman
um there have been several uh references
to tapes and i know one was admitted but
i heard taped plural can they do we have
those tapes are they tapes relative to
the last five days were referred to do
we have those submitted as evidence
yeah we have uh several of you gotten
the actual cassette i believe i mean i
personally would like to have those
tapes uh
yeah i was going to say that
i was going to say that
i have made copies of tapes i think
there are three and you should be
receiving those either tonight or
tomorrow and there is one tape
that's called key excerpts and you can
hear the women and children talking
about why they're there during the 51
days why don't anybody on either side
let us know through your leadership who
wants copies and we'll see that they get
duplicated if that's okay
we have the key excerpts duplicated
already i can hand it to you right now
well we'll stop down and pick them up
i'd like to thank you mr mcclure
texas rangers uh dr taber dr arnold the
joint oversight committee is in waco
stand adjourned until 9 00 a.m tomorrow
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
due to the length of house and senate
floor sessions this week c-span and
c-span 2 have not been able to air all
the waco and white water hearings in
their entirety
we expect lengthy house and senate
sessions over the next two weeks as well
we plan to show all the